ON RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT PUBLIC
CENTERS AND END STAFF- WE MUST
LIMIT ON NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING INCLINED TO THESE
SOURCES AND WITHHOLDING THE
SENSUAL HEARING. AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINGENT HAVE
EXISTED LET'S SAY PROCESS BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES WE COMPLY WITH THESE
WORDS WE'RE HOLDING. OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH TESTIMONY BY THE
MINISTRATION LET'S SAVE ELLIS
OFFICE BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY
WITH THE USE OF TELECONFERENCES
THEM FOR THOSE WHO PURCHASED A
MILITARY POLICEMAN HE GAVE
TELEPHONES AND COMPUTERS
PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING AT
MEETING THEMSELVES IN THE WISH
TO SPEAK. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK EVERY TIME YOU
HAVE TO MAKE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION PLEASE USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM WAS RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
CHECK THE- ISSUE. HE WISHED WE
WILL BE REFERRING TO INTEL OUT
FOR THE PUBLIC WILL BE
MEETING MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
DISSENT CHAMBERS GALLERY TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS WELL. IT WILL BE
USING A TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WAS TESTIFIED TO TAKE WE
MOVED TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
CALORIE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNISTIC THEY WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THE
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE. AT
THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID CAUSING PEOPLE LIKE
YOU MUST MOVE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OF THE
PHONE IS IMPORTANT YOU HEAR WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL.
MAINTAIN THE CORPSMAN DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DISRUPTIVE WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICES OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS NEEDED
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT THE
HEARINGS IT IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS CATHERINE THERE
MAY BE SOME LAP TIMES FOR
PRACTICE. TESTING TO THE U. OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AT FOR ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES AT THE
HEARINGS LET'S BEGIN THE
HEARINGS WHICH THESE. AGENDA
INTO TWO PARTS PART A WE'LL
COVER TRANS. IN ISSUES PART B.
OKAY NATURAL RESOURCE.
ENVIRONMENTAL WE FIGHT ISSUES
TO DISCUSS AND- SUBJECT IN PART
BE. CENTER START HAS ADDED ITEM
NUMBERS. IN PART BE PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE. A AT THE IN THE-
THOUGHTS WE HAVE SEVEN ITEMS
DISCUSS AND PART B. IN ADDITION
TO THE FOREGOING COUNTER. I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. WE'LL BE
HEARING ALL THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA BOTH PART A PART B.
PRIOR TO TAKING. ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN PUBLIC WHAT WE- WHAT
WE HAVE HEARD. ALL THE ITEMS ON
THE EDGE AFTER WE'VE HEARD ALL
THE ITEMS ENGINE WE HAVE ONE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT AND ANY
IDEA OF THE AGENDA SUBSEQUENT
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
WILL VOTE ON THE AGENDA ITEMS
AND ADAPT TO SEPARATE
CONDITIONS. IN SEVERAL BLOCKS
AT A TIME. WE WILL. HAVE A HARD
START AFTER SIX HOURS. BUT
BEFORE WE GET OUT TO THE AGENDA
LET'S SEVENTY COURT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CENTERS LIKE HEALTHY
HERE DAWALY MCGUIRE MORNING
STERN. PERFECT AS A COURT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED CHAIR
RECOGNIZES CENTER STERN. BUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I KNOW
OUR TIME IS BRIEF THIS MORNING
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF. SPACE
FOR HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS A ONE
ITEM THAT I DID WANT TO RAISE
UP FOR PERHAPS FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSION A RESPONSE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS TO DO WITH
THE SPEAKERS ALTERNATIVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PLAN AND TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF WHAT KIND OF
DOLLAR SAVINGS- WE WOULD BE
ACHIEVING. BY IMPLEMENTING THAT
PLAN IN THE NEAR TERM WHAT KIND
OF SAVINGS COULD BE ACHIEVED IN
BENEFITS- SO GOING FORWARD AS
WE APPROACH A SORT OF BROADER
STIMULUS STRATEGY AND TRY TO
FIND A WAY THROUGH THIS
RECOVERY BE LOOKING FOR THOSE
KINDS OPTIMIZATIONS GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
MISTER CHAIR DULY NOTED THAT-
NOW LET'S BEGIN MOVED OUR FIRST
DISCUSSION ITEM ON PART A THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO MATTERS-
MEMBERS THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION. I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND REPRESENTATIVES FROM
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DO YOU WANT TO PRESENT THE ITEM.
FOUR THE MORE YOU WORK ON THE
ROAD FROM THE FINANCE AND- AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA OF THE
VISION IS THAT THE NUMBER OF
TRANSFERS AND LOANS FOR VERY
SPECIAL FUNDS TO HELP. SOUNDS
JENNIFER. THREE TRANSPORTATION
TRASPORTATION- ALONE TWENTY
ONE MILLION FROM THE LOCAL
AIRPORT LET ME COUNT- ONCE I
TRANSFER A HUNDRED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT AT ONE TIME TRANSFER
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE TRAFFIC CONGESTION THE
FUND. THESE MEASURES ARE. THE
PRODUCT I DON'T SEE THE STATE
BUDGET. HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
BUT FOR TRANSPORTATION YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. NO SIR WE HAVE
NOTHING MORE TO ADD. THE LA
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS
YOU HAVE A COMMENT. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS CAN HEAR ME
YES- FRANK JIMENEZ AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
IN REGARDS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
TRANSFER A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
HIGHWAY COUNT. THE GENERAL FUND
AND WE JUST LIKE THE COMMENT
THAT ARTICLE NINETEEN OFTHE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
GENERALLY PROHIBITS REVENUES
FROM THE GASOLINE AND DIESEL
EXCISE TAXES. FROM BEING USED
FOR- NON TRANSPORTATION
PURPOSES- HOWEVER ARTICLE
NINETEEN THAT'S AND- EXPLICITLY
LIMIT THE INTEREST- EARNED PUT
ON THOSE REVENUES WHILE THEY
SIT IN THE STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT. AND THAT HAS OUT THAT
IS HOW THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED THIS TRANSFER TO THE
BEST OF OUR KNOWLEDGE THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME A TRANSFER LIKE
THIS FROM INTEREST HAS BEEN
USED. SO THERE IS NO LEGAL
PRECEDENT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
TRANSFER- THAT'S WHAT WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE- SEEK
A MORE FORMAL LEGAL OPINION
FROM LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL. AND
ALSO POLICY QUESTION AT HAND-
IF THE TRANSFER IS COMPLETED-
UNTIL TOMORROW EVENING- BUT
SPENDING ON HIGHWAY PROJECTS.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THIS A STAFF RECOMMENDATION
NOTES THAT THAT TRAFFIC
CONGESTION RELIEF TO COUNT-
CONSIST OF THE REMAINING
BALANCES OF THE PHONES ARE
TRIVIAL TO THE ORIGINAL GENERAL
FUND TRANSFER. AND THAT TO NEED
SOME LEGAL CLARIFICATIONS A
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO. IS
TO HOLD THE MATTER OPEN. VERY
GOOD OKAY THE CENTER BAR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR ON
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE IN REGARDS
TO THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION TRANSFER FROM THE STATE
HIGHWAY COUNT TO THE GENERAL
FUND THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IS
THIS THIS GOES AGAINST A
PROMISE A PROMISE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN THE THEN
GOVERNOR- IT MADE IN PROP SIXTY
NINE. THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
SOURCE WHETHER IT'S DIRECT FROM
THE GAS TAX THEIR INTERESTS
ITSELF THAT IS FROM THE GAS TAX
WOULD BE SPENT ON ROAD
IMPROVEMENT IN HIGHWAY PROJECTS
I THINK THIS IS A BROKEN
PROMISE A BROKEN PROMISE IF
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MOVES FORWARD
WITH THIS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
GAS TAX IS DOWN BY
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
MILLION WHICH WE KNOW IS GOING
TO IMPACT ROAD IMPROVEMENT
HIGHWAY IMPROVEMENT IN BRIDGE
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE I BELIEVE THAT THIS
MONEY COULD BE BETTER SPENT ON
THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED FIXING
THE ROADS OF CALIFORNIANS.
CENTER DOLLY. HEY RICHARD
SHARED I ALSO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SECOND
SENATE DISTRICT THAT. I HAPPEN
TO BE ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ACTUALLY PAYS A HEAVY
WEIGHT USE TAX- FOR OUR-
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES THAT TRIBE
TRAVELED DOWN A HIGHWAY IN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT THEY
ACTUALLY TOOK THAT MONEY. TO
PAY OFF BONDS THAT ENDED UP
HELPING FUND THE GENERAL FUND-
TRANSPORTATION GENERAL FUND-
WHICH IN. MY MIND IS NOT TO
WHAT THE LAW ACTUALLY. I WAS
PASSED TO DO SAME WAY WITH THE
GAS TAX- WE'RE WE HAVE
RECRUITED DECREASING REVENUES
BECAUSE OF- THIS SITUATION
WE'RE IN AND WE'RE GONNA NEED
EVERY PENNY- TO GO TO THE
ROADS- AND THEY HAVE A
STRUCTURED NEEDS THAT OF
CALIFORNIA IS LAGGING WAY
BEHIND IN- SO I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE TIME WE SHOULD PUT
THAT MONEY AND IT ALSO WOULD
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY BY
PUTTING THAT MONEY BACK IN- TO
CREATING JOBS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT THE STAFF
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD
IT OPEN WE'LL GET TO THAT AT
THE END OF THE AGENDA LET'S
MOVE TO AT NUMBER SEVENTY TWO.
THIS IS A LOW EMISSION
BUILDINGS. A PROGRAM BUILD WITH
THAT- ENERGY RESOURCES- FINANCE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT THE
ITEM. WHAT A MINUTE FIGHT IS.
PROVISIONING A REQUEST FOR
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
EXPENDITURES ALREADY BEGINNING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR INCREMENTS
OF BUILDING INITIATIVE FROM ALL
NATIONS DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
COSTS ARISING AS THE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN AT CERTAIN BILLS.
THIS WOULD BE REDUCED GHG
EMISSIONS FROM BUILDINGS ARE
PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR
ADOPTING YOUR MISSION YOU'RE A
TECHNOLOGIES ENABLE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS ADMINISTRATOR OF
THIS PROGRAM. WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COMMISSION REBEL AND WHO
WILL MAKE ME. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
OKAY OIL AND THAT ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON THIS
BUDGET REQUEST THE FIRM MAY
REVISION. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
WAS ROSS BROWN WITH ELIO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS REQUEST IT'S IMPLEMENTING-
EXISTING LEGISLATION- HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS WELL JUST IN
CASE IT'S- HELPFUL TO KIND OF
MOVE THINGS FORWARD WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ISSUES OR CONCERNS
WITH THE REMAINING. ISSUES ON
OUR AGENDA- BUT ALWAYS HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH. VERY GOOD FOR. ALL ALL
KNOW AD- MEMBERS CENTER STERN
THE AUTHOR OF A FOURTEEN ESPYS
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WE
RECOGNIZE. THAT THANK YOU MR
TWENTY COMMITTEE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THEIR WORK ON IMPLEMENTING
THIS PROGRAM- AND WOULD BE
CURIOUS TO GET A SENSE OF- IN
THE NEAR TERM WHAT KIND OF
ECONOMIC BENEFITS THIS COULD
YIELD FOR. LOWER INCOME MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES THAT ARE
HURTING DURING THIS TIME- WHEN
THAT. FURNACE OR WATER HEATER
BREAK DOWN AND YOU GET A SWAP
OUT FOR SOMETHING CHEAPER WITH
THE- INCENTIVE FROM THE STATE
ARE THERE ANY SENSE OF-
PROJECTED ECONOMIC BENEFITS
HERE. THANK YOU. A COMMENT FROM
FINANCE. ALL RIGHT YES I WOULD
I DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT DREW
OTHERWISE I'D BE HAPPY TO GET
BACK YOUR STAFF OR- SHE
PROGRAMMATIC STUFF. YEAH THIS
IS DREW BOWING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- I COULD ADDRESS
THAT GENERALLY- IF YOU HAVE A
MOMENT YES. OKAY SO WE HAVEN'T
NECESSARILY PROJECTED EIGHT
DIRECT JOBS IMPACT JUST YET.
HOWEVER WE HAVE LOOKED AT IS-
THIS THIS FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES TOO- NOT
ONLY HELP REDUCE GHGS BUT TO
REDUCE INDOOR AIR POLLUTION IN
THEIR HOMES WE LOOKED AT A
NUMBER OF THINGS WE COULD LOOK
AT HOT WATER HEATERS TO GO FROM
GAS TO ELECTRIC WE CAN LOOK AT
STOVES WHICH IS WHERE THE
INDOOR AIR QUALITY. PROBLEMS
THE MOST PRONOUNCED WE CAN LOOK
AT IN THE ATTIC TYPICALLY FOR
HEATING SYSTEMS- WHAT WE'VE
DONE AN ESTIMATE ON THOSE WITH
THE REBATE LEVEL WERE
ESTIMATING FOR WATER HEATERS WE
ESTIMATE THAT THIS FINDING
COULD PROVIDE ENOUGH FOR
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND. NEW
HOMES- WHAT THAT TRANSLATES
INTO EXACTLY IN TERMS OF JOBS
WE DON'T KNOW DO YOU STILL HAVE
YOUR SCALE THAN THAT A NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES IT CAN
BE TOUCHED. BY THE PROGRAM
THAT'S THE NUMBER WE'VE GOT.
THE CARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING THE WEATHER- AND- HANDS
UP FOR MEMBERS WE WILL- WE GET
TO THE VOTES WILL- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET LET'S MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER. SEVENTY FOUR
WILDFIRE PROPOSAL. THIS IS ABC
AT TEN FIFTY FOUR FINANCE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT THIS ITEM.
S. A. MENOMINEE AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE REVISIONS TO STAY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST A
NINETY DAY SHOULD START DRESSED
YOU SEIZE NEW REGULATORY
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
801-054-8111 SP NOT A ONE. THEY
USUALLY REQUEST ELEVEN NEW
POSITIONS FOR THE WILDFIRE
SAFETY DIVISION AND STATE
POLICY DIVISIONS EVALUATE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS FOR
TOTAL WHILE I REQUESTED FORTY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION NINE
HUNDRED FOR PHYSICIAN. HUNDREDS
OF ORGANIZATIONS OF THIS TOTAL
REQUEST THIRTY TWO POSITIONS
ARE FOR THE NEWLY CREATED WHILE
OUR SAFETY DIVISION AND TEN
MILLION. DOLLARS IS A CONTRACT
OR- THANK YOU. LOU THIS PC HAVE
ANYBODY ANY COMMENT DEPARTMENT
OR COMMISSION. YES HI THIS IS
ALICE STEBBINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR I HAVE- THREE
INDIVIDUALS WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. OKAY
GREETED AT THE SECOND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
ADDITIONAL THIS IS ELEVEN
ADDITIONAL. PERSONNEL IN
ADDITION TO THE NINETY THREE
FROM THE JANUARY PROPOSAL. I
WILL WE DON'T HAVE ANY- ISSUES
OR CONCERNS TO RAISE BACK
ANSWER QUESTIONS OKAY CENTER
DOLLY RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU SO
MY QUESTION IS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING PRIOR TO THESE
POSITIONS BEING. PROPOSED IN
THIS BUDGET WELL AS FOR THE
INSPECTION OF THE TRANSMISSION
LINES. THANK YOU SENATOR RACHEL
HERSELF. YES GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE RACHEL PETERSON DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT A POLICY WITH THE
C. P. C. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING US THIS MORNING- SO
AS FIRST THE THING I SHOULD
NOTE THAT BEFORE THE-
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
WILDFIRE OCCURRENCE AND
INTENSITY IN CALIFORNIA THE
ENFORCEMENT WORK AT THE
COMMISSION IS MORE FOCUSED ON
INCIDENT INVESTIGATION AND SO
WITH RESPECT TO ACTUALLY HAVING
OF A BROADER INSPECTION-
FUNCTION THAT HASN'T
TRADITIONALLY BEEN PART OF.
WHAT THE AGENCY IS RESOURCE
FOR- IN ADDITION THERE IS SOME
JURISDICTIONAL- FRICTION I
WOULD SAY BETWEEN- THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
TRANSMISSION LINES IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE MUCH CLEARER
JURISDICTION WITH RESPECT TO
DISTRIBUTION CIRCUITS AND
INSPECTION OF TRANSMISSION
LINES IS- SOMETHING ABOUT-
QUESTION AS TO FIRST VERSUS-
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTION
NEVERTHELESS WE RECOGNIZE THE
SAFETY. THE SAFETY- RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH TRANSMISSION
LINES IN THERE FOR THE
INSPECTION WORK NEEDS TO
ADDRESS TRANSMISSION LINES AS
WELL. SO I HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION CONSULTING SO. WE HAVE
ALLOCATED. A LOT OF RESOURCES
AND ALSO THE UTILITIES IT CAME
THROUGH AND GOTTEN. THE BILL
THE BILL TO RAISE THEIR RATES
TO DO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE WOW. WHO WHO'S
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR ACTUALLY
MAKING SURE THAT THE WORK'S
GETTING DONE IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND AT A- REASONABLE COST. AND
YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT ONE YEAH
PLEASE. SURE THIS IS CAROLINE
HOW MR- JACOB THE DIRECTOR OF
THE WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GREAT- SO
WITH THE DETACHMENT OF THE LONG
PART THANK YOU VISION WE NOW
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
REVIEWING AND APPROVING A LOT
FOR MEDICATION PLANS WHICH
INCLUDES THE UTILITIES
ARTICULATION OF HOW THEIR
REDUCE WILDFIRE IN. AND THEN
HOLDING THEM COMBINED TO THAT
SO WE HAVE A COMBINED BRANCH
WHICH IS INCLUDED IN THE
PERSONNEL THAT ARE BEING
REQUESTED HERE. AND THEN ALSO
THE- MONEY THAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A NEW CAPABILITY TO YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION IN TERMS OF
DIRECT FIELD INSPECTIONS. SO WE
NOW HAVE A COMPLIANCE ASSURANCE
CONTRACTOR ON BOARD- ALONG WITH
OUR CLIENTS BRANCH AND ARE
EXECUTING FIELD INSPECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
COMPLETING. ACTIVITIES AT THEIR
ARTICULATING IN OUR PLANS. YEAH
AND THIS WILL BE AS A SEPARATE
PORTS NOTES BEGINNING IN JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THAT IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
WE'LL HAVE A- THE NEW OFFICE OF
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SO. THE
FUNCTION I PRESUME WILL REMAIN
THE SAME BUT IT'LL BE A
DIFFERENT- AGENCY. SOME PAGE
FIFTY THREE ACTOR. THE CENTER
MORNING RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
VERY BRIEFLY- I KNOW THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN BUT- I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF THE POSITION FOR DIABLO
CANYON DECOMMISSIONING THAT IS
MOVING FORWARD SAFETY REMAINS
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY- IN SO
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THIS- FOR THE
RESOURCE OF PC OVERSIGHT OF
THAT DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS
THANK YOU THE TRICK KNOWLEDGE
THAT- DEVIL CANYON POSITION
BEING IN THERE. OTHER MEMBERS
NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED ON A WILD
FIRE PROPOSAL THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN. OKAY LET'S MOVE THE ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE THIS IS THE
STUDY OF THE LEASE- CANYON WITH
THE P. U. C. ONE CONTRACT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION WITH FINANCE
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT. YES AND
WE KNOW DEPARTMENT FIND AND
OPERATIONS TO STATE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUESTS FOR
ONE TIME CONTRACT ALREADY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
VALUATION DANCING THAT MUCH AND
THAT WAS A CANYON NATURAL GAS
STORAGE FACILITY. THE
COMMISSION WILL RETAIN A
CONSULTANT TO LOOK AT SPECIFIC
SCENARIOS WHICH COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED ENTIRELY REPLACED.
AT LEAST CAN YOU CONSOLIDATE.
THANK YOU. DOES ANYBODY AT THE
COMMISSION HAVE A COMMENT OR
UPDATE FOR THE COMMITTEE A
SUBCOMMITTEE. NO CHERUB NO
TERMIN THIS IS ALICE DEVON'S
AGAIN BUT WE ARE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
LMAO YOU'RE YOU'RE FINE. THAT'S
RIGHT MISTER CHAIR NO NO
CONCERNS ALL RIGHT. SINISTER
YOU RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. IT'S BEEN A FEW YEARS
SINCE THE BLOWOUT ITSELF BUT
THE CONCERNS STILL REMAIN LOTS
OF ONGOING HEALTH ISSUES WE'VE
BEEN HAVING IN THE COMMUNITY
AND EVEN CONCERNS AS RECENTLY
AS LAST WEEK ABOUT NEW LEAKS. A
LOT OF ODORS IN THE COMMUNITY
I'M JUST MY QUESTION TO THE
COMMISSION IS WHY IF WE'RE
TAKING OUT A CONTRACT TO REALLY
STUDY- CLOSURE FEASIBILITY AND
HOW THAT WOULD WORK WHY SO
RIGID IN THE PLANNING HORIZONS
WHITE WHY ARE WE ONLY LOOKING
AT TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN AND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE A LOT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN. IN THOSE SUBSEQUENT
DECADES- AND THE PC ITSELF IS
MODELED A MAJOR CHANGES IN THE
ENERGY MIX ESPECIALLY IN THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASIN SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF THERE'S
ANY FLEXIBILITY IN THE CURRENT
CONTRACT TO BE STUDYING
ALTERNATIVES A STAIR STEPS
SCENARIOS. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR HI RACHEL CAN YOU TAKE
THAT PLEASE. A YES GOOD MORNING
SENATOR- SO THE ORIGINAL BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL USE THOSE TWO
YEARS 202-728-4054 A COUPLE OF
REASONS ONE IS GROUNDED IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LETTER FROM
DENTURE BY SIMILAR TO THEN
PRESIDENT TICKER ABOUT LOOKING
AT A TEN YEAR CLOSURE PLAN. AND
THE OTHER IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE SP ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FORTY
FIVE TARGET FOR MOVING ALL
RETAIL SALES TO RENEWABLE
ENERGY- THAT SAID THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION IS ABSOLUTELY YES
ONCE A CONSULTANT IS CONTRACTED
UNDER THIS- PROPOSAL THE CDC
CAN WORK WITH THEM TO EXAMINE
TO SEE ABOUT THE FEASIBILITY OF
EXAMINING OTHER STAIR STEPS
SCENARIOS BETWEEN THOSE YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT TWENTY THIRTY IS
A CRITICAL TIE LINE FOR
INSTANCE IN OUR SP THIRTY TWO
GOALS AND THERE MAY BE OTHER
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONES THAT WE
CAN MODEL BASED UPON BUT I
APPRECIATE THE CPC'S FEEDBACK
INTELLIGENCE ON THIS MATTER.
AND GET TO STUDY GOING OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX THIS IS CAL SPEED.
SPEED TESTING MORE SPEED RACING
TODAY LET'S HEAR ABOUT PAT T.
MOBILE AND ALL. OUR PARTNERS GO
AHEAD FINANCE. INSTEAD THEY
WERE VERSION INCLUDES TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AND
REPOSITION THE COMMISSION IT'S
A BROADBAND MAPPING
CAPABILITIES BY RESTRICTING THE
CALCIUM MOBILE TESTING PROGRAM.
B. TESTING WILL GATED DATA DATA
TO BETTER INFORM THE STATE'S
PRIMARY MAP AND PARCEL NORMAL
MERGER AGREEMENTS HELP IDENTIFY
AREAS WITHIN THE STATE ONE
FIFTH OF THE TOTAL REQUEST IS
ELIGIBLE TO BE REIMBURSED BY T.
MOBILE IS A CONDITION THAT
NEARLY FREE. OF THEIR NEWLY
APPROVED MERGER WITH SPRINT
HOUSE MEANWHILE IN OTHER THINGS
IMPROVE SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
AFTER DISASTERS KANSAS STATE
AND- FEDERAL BROADBAND FUNDING
AND BETTER INFORM THE STATE.
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. SHE THE COMMISSION
THEY- I'M NOT SURE WE'RE JUST
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GOT YOU THIS IS A- NICE
WORK ON THE- TERMS OF THE
MERGER- BELIAU I. DON'T SEE
YOUR HAND UP HERE OKAY. NO
CONCERNS MISTER CHAIR VERY GOOD
THIS IS A STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS HOLD OPEN- MEMBERS WHO HAVE
ANY QUESTION ON KILLS BE
TESTING. SENATOR DOLL YOU
RECOGNIZE THE MOISTURE- JUST
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON I KNOW
THAT CHICO STATE DID. A BROAD
BAND. THE BASICALLY CHECK
PAROLE BROADBAND IN MY
DISTRICT- SOMETIME BACK AND I
WAS WONDERING- WHAT CAME WITH
THAT I KNOW THAT DURING THIS
COVERT SITUATION THERE ARE MANY
SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND- CHILDREN
IN THE RURAL AREAS THAT ARE
ABLE TO- THAT DO THEIR WORK-
BECAUSE LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SO I WAS WONDERING- WHAT
HAPPEN TO THE PAST INFORMATION
THAT WE ARE GATHERED THROUGH
THESE- MAPPING SCENARIOS AND
WHAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE TO-
IMPLEMENT. RULE BROADBAND
COMMISSION CAN YOU TAKE THAT
QUESTION. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
I'M GONNA PASS THIS OVER TO ROB
OSBORNE MY DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS ROB. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR QUESTION
YES- CSU CHICO CONDUCTED A
STUDY ON- AGRICULTURAL
BROADBAND USING MOBILE AND- WE
CAN WE'LL BE HAPPY TO SEND YOU
THE REPORT ON THAT BASICALLY
ARE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TESTING
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING SO FAR WE
HAD UP UNTIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOR MOBILE- WHICH FOCUSED ON
URBAN RURAL AND TRIBAL BUT NOT
SPECIFICALLY AGRICULTURAL LANDS
SO THAT STUDY WAS LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AGRICULTURAL
LANDS. I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
GAP MAY BE IN ORDER TO
INTRODUCE PRECISION AGRICULTURE.
AND SO WHAT WITH THIS PROPOSAL
BE. SO THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
REINSTITUTE OUR STATEWIDE
TESTING AND THE REASON WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO TESTING
MULTIPLE TIMES A YEAR IS THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING AS ARE THE HANDSETS SO
EACH TIME A NEW HANDSET COMES
OUT EACH TIME THE TECHNOLOGIES
UPDATED. WE HAVE TO RETEST
UNDERSTAND HOW COVERAGE HAS
CHANGED HOW MOBILE PERFORMANCE
HAS CHANGED WHAT YOU CAN DO-
ZOOM CALLS AT HOME FOR SCHOOL-
WHETHER AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE
COVERED FOR PRECISION
AGRICULTURE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND FIRST A
BASELINE OF WHAT THE COVERAGES
BEFORE THERE'S ANY DISASTER.
AND THEN WHEN THERE IS A
DISASTER WHAT THE- URGENCY-
BASICALLY COVERAGE- SYSTEMS
THAT ARE BROUGHT INTO PLACE TO
PROVIDE THAT EXTRA COVERAGE
WHEN CELL SITES GO DOWN I
UNDERSTAND THAT PERFORMANCE
LET'S FINALLY. AT THE END WHEN-
THERE'S RESTORATION BEING PUT
IN PLACE BASED ON THE CELL
SITES ARE BEING BROUGHT BACK UP
ONLINE. RABAL TO MONITOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M I'M KNOW
THAT WE'VE JUST DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN WE'VE INCREASED TO. THE
NINE ONE ONE FEE SO THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO- COMMUNICATE UNDER REAL
IN REAL TIME FOR WILDFIRE. AND
NOW WE'VE WE'VE SEEN. NOT ONLY
LIKE YOU MENTIONED ZOOM AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THROUGH- WORK AT
HOME OR- THE STATE HOME ORDERS-
SO I GUESS IT IS THIS GONNA BE
HOLISTICALLY LOOKED OUT WITH.
HELLO YES AND ALL THOSE
PROVIDERS THAT PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SERVICES OR IS IT
JUST GOING TO BE SITE SPECIFIC
TO LIKE WHAT WE DID WITH CHICO
STATE WITH AGRICULTURE. LIKE
YOU SAID CENTER THIS IS DONE IN
COORDINATION WITH CAL WE
ABSOLUTELY PROVIDE DATA FOR
THEM FOR THE BASELINE COVERAGE
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THE CARRIERS. THAT THEY HAVE A
GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE THE
HOLES ARE. AND THEN IN THE CASE
OF A DISASTER WERE ABLE TO GO
IN AND DO TESTING. TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOURS ARE STILL UP AND
RUNNING AND THEN FINALLY IN THE
RESTORATION. ONCE SITES ARE
COMING BACK. SHARE WITH YOU. S.
PREVIOUS FIRE SITUATIONS ONE
LAST QUESTION THAT'S AWESOME
THANK YOU- WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
DO EXISTING DO WE KNOW IF WE
HAVE EXISTING HOLES- NOT JUST
FOR DURING AN EVENT BUT HOLES
WHERE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
BILL THE BILL TO COMMUNICATE
AND WHAT ARE WHAT ARE OUR
OPTIONS TO. ALLEVIATE THOSE
HOLES. YES SO WE DO KNOW THEIR
HOLES UNFORTUNATELY WE STOPPED
THE MOBILE TESTING BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE COMING BACK TO TRY AND
RESTART THIS PROGRAM. SO WE ARE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE HOLES
AND- THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN WE
CAN LEVERAGE THAT INFORMATION
TO TRY AND STEER FEDERAL
DOLLARS INTO THOSE AREAS TO TRY
AND SUBSIDIZED NEW BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENTS. THANK YOU I CAN
SHOW YOU- WITHIN A HUNDRED MILE
RADIUS OF MY HOME AND ALL THE
DEAD SPOTS. YEAH ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT
IS WITH THIS TESTING IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THESE THREE NEW
POSITIONS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
AT THE COMMISSION AND THEN
THERE'S SOME. CONTRACTS THAT
THEY GOT IT AUTHORITY TO ENTER
INTO CONTRACTS AND WE'RE
WONDERING WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING WITH THE COMMISSION
WHAT'S THE MIX WHAT IS THAT WHY
IS IT NOT ALL BROUGHT IN HOUSE
TO DO THAT. TO FIGURE OUT THE
HOLES WITH- YES AND- THE
COMMISSION SO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN GOING ON. I THINK ONE
OF THE- THINGS IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING AS A LEGISLATOR IS
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO. WE
HAVE- YES WE HAVE CAL FIRE WE
HAVE. WE HAVE THE PROVIDERS
THERE WE HAVE AND WE'VE WE'VE
INCREASED RESOURCES THROUGH
BILLS LIKE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE WHICH BRINGS- THE CAST FOR
THE FUNDS TO- THE LAST MILE
UNSERVED COMMUNITIES- BUT
SOMEHOW THERE NEEDS TO BE. A
ONE AGENCY THAT THAT SAYS OKAY
IF WE'RE GOING TO FILL THIS
HOLE MAY WE CAN TAKE SOME FUNDS
FROM. THE NINE ONE ONE WE CAN
TAKE SOME FUNDS FROM SIXTEEN
SIXTY FIVE AND WE CAN FILL THE
SPOTS BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS WE GET SILO DOUBT. AND
THERE'S NO ABILITY TO CROSS
OVER AND ACTUALLY FIX THE DEAD
ZONES THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE SO
WE CAN COMMUNICATE WHEN WE WHEN
WE NEED REAL TIME- IN EMERGENCY
SO I WOULD BE. OPEN TO IDEAS
FROM FROM YOU GUYS THERE OR
EVEN LEGISLATORS ON HOW WE CAN
GET- THOSE- DEAD'S DEAD ZONES
AND THOSE UNSERVED POPULATIONS
OUT THERE SERVED THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. ART SCENE NO OTHER
CONCERNS WITH MEMBERS AND
SEEING THAT WERE CLIPPING RIGHT
ALONG WE WILL NOT PAUSE- N.
THANK YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING
IN OUR PARTY THE AGENDA. AND
NOW WILL BOOST MOVE ON THE PART
BE. I WILL WITHOUT OBJECTION-
THE SUBCOMMITTEE SECTIONS WHICH
WERE TAKEN AT THE MARCH FIFTH.
HEARING ARE RESCINDED. AS A
FRIENDLY REMINDER FOR THOSE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
PLEASE MOVE YOUR MUTE YOUR
PHONES AND COMPUTERS
PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING ENEMY
THEMSELVES AND THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATED THE ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED EVERY TIME YOU
MAKE A COMER QUESTION I USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE ON THE
PROGRAM. WELL ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE AGENDA ITEM WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- ONCE AGAIN
SANDERS TURNED HIS. PULLED ITEM
NUMBER SIX FROM THE CONSENT
MORE HERE AT THE END OF THE
CALENDAR WE HAVE SEVEN ISSUES
IN PART BE FOR DISCUSSION LET'S
START OFF WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW- BUT THE RESOURCES
FROM THE- LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WELCOME. BELIAU GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS IF I COULD I WILL-
SHARE A SCREEN I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF POWER POINT SLIDES. I
THINK I NEED TO BE VERY GOOD
ENABLED- IS THAT GETTING WORKED
OUT I WILL I JUST NEED YOU TO
AGAIN MY NAME'S BRIAN BROWN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WERE ASKED TO GIVE A
VERY BRIEF. EVEN TATIAN ON- THE
ADMINISTRATIONTHEY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION- AND
SO WE HAVE A FEW SLIDES HERE.
SO GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT AGO.
THIS. WE HELLO GUYS THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I'M USED TO
SEEING IN JUNE. SO LET ME. MR
BROWN'S BEAUTIFUL WORLD WORLD
ALONG WITH THAT. I DON'T KNOW
ARE YOU ABLE TO SEE MY- THE DAY
SLIDE TITLED OVERVIEW OF
GOVERNORS MAY REVISION I JUST
SEE YOU. JUST ME I APOLOGIZE. I
MIGHT NEED SOME HELP FROM LDC
HERE. THE SHARE SCREEN
APPLICATION THE WINDOW I GET A
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I'M USED TO
SEEING. IF THIS DOESN'T WORK I
CAN I CAN WALK THROUGH VERBALLY.
ONE TICKET TO MUCH TIME ID.
LET'S GIVE LDC A CUP OF WHILE
TO FIGURE IT OUT. THIS.
FOR
MEMBERS CAESAR THESE ARE ITEMS-
STARTING AT PAGE. BOTH A AND
PART B. HI ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THROUGH ISSUE NUMBER THREE ON
YOUR HAND OUT A HUNDRED PAGE
UNDER. RIGHT. WHAT IS IT IS IT
WORKING NOW SENATOR WE HAVE IT
IN A RATHER LARGE FONT. A LARGE
FILE OKAY. I KNOW YOU HAVE BIG
IDEAS MR BROWN BUT WE WANT TO
DOWNSIZE THEM A LITTLE BIT FOR
THAT OUR DISCUSSIONS TODAY
THERE YOU GO. HAVE YOUR SLIDES
COMMENCE OKAY ALL RIGHT I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY- SO
AGAIN SO THE WELL JUST RUN
THROUGH RELATIVELY QUICKLY HERE
AT A HIGH LEVEL THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT OVERVIEW. OF THE
COMPARISON OF THE MAY REVISION
IS A JANUARY BUDGET I'LL JUST
NOTE TO THEIR A COUPLE SLIDES
HERE THAT DO INCLUDE SOME
INFORMATION. ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THAT'S
REALLY JUST FOR THE REFERENCE
OF THE COMMITTEE BUT ALSO FOCUS
ON RESOURCES. AND ENVIRONMENT.
SO THIS IS THE FIRST SLIDE
HERE- THE FIRST LIGHT HERE
SHOWS OVERALL SPENDING IN THE
MAY REVISION RELATIVE TO
JANUARY. AND IF YOU LOOK AT
NATURAL RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION WHAT
YOU'LL SEE IS THAT OVERALL
SPENDING AND THIS INCLUDES
GENERAL FUNDS SPECIAL FUNDS AND
BONDS FINDS. IS ACTUALLY
RELATIVELY FLAT OVER THE TWO
THE TWO PROPOSED BUDGET-
UNDERLINED THAT THOUGH
IMPORTANTLY- AND ALL GO INTO A
LITTLE BIT OF THIS IN THE NEXT
SLIDE. R. A NUMBER OF
REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THE OFFSET
IN SOME CASES BY INCREASING
SPENDING AND OTHERS MOST
NOTABLY IN SPECIAL FUNDS. AND
BONDS FUNDS. SO ON THIS SLIDE
IN THE NEXT SLIDE. IS A TABLE
WHICH SHOWS GENERAL FIND
SOLUTIONS IN THE MAY REVISION
RELATIVE TO JANUARY- FULL
BRIDGE THE CIVICALLY RELATED TO
EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS- I WILL
CERTAINLY GO THROUGH EACH OF
THE SEVERAL EITHER ON YOUR
AGENDA THIS AFTERNOON. THIS
MORNING STILL. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE WHAT YOU'LL SEE REALLY
IS THAT FOR THE MOST PART THESE
ARE NOT REDUCTIONS. TO BASELINE
SPENDING AND RESOURCES PROGRAMS
INSTEAD MOST OF THESE
REDUCTIONS RELATIVE TO JANUARY
OUR WITHDRAWALS OF JANUARY
PROPOSALS. THEY ARE FINE SHIPS
SO REDUCING GENERAL FUND
SPENDING FOR PARTICULAR PROGRAM
BUT BACKED ONLY NOT IN WHOLE OR
IN PART THE SPECIAL FUNDS. OR
THEY'RE PAUSING CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS EITHER ONE PROPOSED IN
JANUARY ONES AUTHORIZED IN
PRIOR BUDGETS BUT IN SO DOING
KEEPING EXISTING FACILITIES-
FUNDED IN AN OPERATING. YEAH
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF IMPORT
EXCEPTION TO THAT YOU SHOULD
EITHER ON YOUR- AGENDA TODAY
THE FIRST IS WITH RESPECT TO
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
ABOUT HALFWAY DOWN THE SLIDE. A
TRIGGER REDUCTION OF THIRTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION THIS WOULD BE A
REDUCTION OF BASELINE FUNDING
AGAIN I WILL SPEND MORE TIME.
ON THAT BECAUSE THAT IS ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY. THIS IS JUST A
SEC SLIDE THE CONTINUATION OF
THAT TABLE ANOTHER- BASELINE
REDUCTION AGAIN ON YOUR AGENDA
TODAY. IT BUT NOT ON THIS TABLE
IS A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND REDUCTION. FOR
STATE PARKS- THE REASON IT'S
NOT ON THE TABLE BECAUSE OF THE
PROPOSED TO BE IMPLEMENTED NOT
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. BUT IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. YOU CAN SEE
THERE- AND THIS IS JUST THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURE
REDUCTION GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS IN THE MAY REVISION
THE NUMBER OF EVEN SMALLER ONES.
IN ADDITION REALLY THE AREA
THAT PROVIDED THE MOST GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT THOSE LARGE
GENERAL FUND SOLUTION. IN THE
MAY REVISION FROM THESE PROGRAM
AREAS ARE ACTUALLY SPECIAL FUND
LOANS AND TRANSFERRED. TO THE
GENERAL FUND THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT A COUPLE OF THESE AND
TRANSPORTATION ALREADY- BUT YOU
CAN SEE THE LIST HERE IS QUITE
A FEW. DIFFERENT LOANS AND
TRANSFERS TOTALING ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S A
VERY LARGE BENEFIT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. IT IS AN
IMPORTANT NOTICE TO JUST ONE
TIME BENEFIT SO ONE SEES- LOVE
THESE FUNDS ARE LOANED OR
TRANSFERRED- THEY ARE NOT
AVAILABLE. FOR DOING SO IN THE
FUTURE. AND IMPORTANTLY TO THE
ONES THAT ARE LOANS AND POINT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
FUTURE GENERAL FUND OBLIGATIONS
THAT'S CREATED BY THAT TO REPAY
THOSE. FUTURE THE- MAY REVISION
ALSO INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION SO
WELL MOST OF THE FOCUS IS ON.
REDUCING COSTS- TRANSFERRING
FUNDING IN ORDER TO. MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFIT TO THE GENERAL FUND
GIVEN THE GENERAL CONDITION
THERE ARE A FEW PLACES WHERE
THAT THERE WHERE THERE ARE
CHANNELS AND AUGMENTATION.
AGAIN A COUPLE OF THESE ARE ON
YOUR AGENDA TODAY BUT I JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE FIRST TWO IN
PARTICULAR UNDER PARKS AND
CDFA. THIS IS FUNNY THAT WE
VIEW IS GENERALLY NECESSARY IS
TO BACK FILL FOR THE STATE
AFFILIATED FAIRS AS WELL STATE
PARKS TOO THEY CAN- OPERATE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. OR PAY FOR
UNNECESSARY COSTS. EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE A REDUCTION IN
REVENUES FROM THEIR SHIPPING
FEES OR FROM OTHER BANDS SO
THESE ARE A NECESSARY COST
DRIVEN REALLY BY B. COVE IN
NINETEEN. CRISIS AND PEOPLE
STAYING AT HOME. IN ADDITION
YOU CAN SEE A FEW OTHER-
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
PROPOSE IN THE MAY REVISION.
IT'S NOT VERY MANY BUT- THERE
ARE A FEW NOTABLE ONES THAT ARE
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. A COUPLE
OF HIGH LEVEL- COMMENTS ABOUT
THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET AND
OVERALL ARCHITECTURE. IN
GENERAL I FIND THAT THE
PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE
EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS ARE
REASONABLE IN LIGHT OF THE
GENERAL FUND CONDITION THAT'S-
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MANY
OF THE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS ARE
ONE TIME IN NATURE OF THE LOANS
TRANSFERRED AND ALSO THE SHIPS.
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER WHERE
SPECIAL FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO
BACKFILL GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS. WINDOWS ARE JUST
ONE TIME AND WE DO PROJECT A
MULTI YEAR BUDGET PROBLEM. BUT
WITH RESPECT TO THE LAST TWO
COMMENTS HERE JUST- THE ARE
REALLY IN SOME WAYS THE SIDES
OF THE SAME COIN- BROADLY WHAT
ARE YOU LOOKING AT IT WHETHER
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE- CUTS
IMPROVE- PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION FOR THE AUGMENTATIONS-
THESE. ULTIMATELY ARE ONES THAT
REFLECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES AND SO WE'D
RECOMMEND THAT AS YOU LOOK AT
EACH OF THESE. THAT YOU
CONSIDER THEM- WHETHER THEY ARE
CONSISTENT WITH YOUR GENERAL
FUND PRIORITY AND NOT JUST
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF RESOURCES
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
BUT IN IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
BROADER STATEWIDE BUDGET WHERE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF- CHANNEL
FIND PRODUCTIONS THAT HAVE TO
BE. IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER TO
HAVE A BALANCED BUDGET. BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH. IT'S ALSO WORTH
MENTIONING THERE ARE A FEW
SIGNIFICANT SPECIAL AND BOND
FUND RELATED PROPOSALS AND THEN
A REVISION AS YOU KNOW A
SPECIAL FUNDS AND BONDS AND
ACTUALLY MAKE A VERY LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF OVERALL SPENDING
IN THE RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION PROGRAMS SUCH A
HIGHLY VERY QUICKLY JUST A FEW
OF THOSE YOU KNOW MOST OF THE
DISCUSSION OF LATE IS FOCUSED
ON THE- CHANNELS ON THERE ARE
SOME IMPORTANT PROPOSALS HERE
THE FIRST IS CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CONTINUES TO PROPOSE THE
SAME SPENDING PLAN AS IN
JANUARY INCLUDING A NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR DISCRETIONARY. SPENDING
PLAN IMPORTANTLY THAN A
REVISION DOES HAVE MODIFIED
BUDGET LANGUAGE THAT
PRIORITIZES THE REVENUES
TOWARDS CERTAIN PROGRAMS. AND
IN OUR VIEW THIS IS HAVING SOME
SORT OF PRIORITIZATION IS
REALLY CRITICAL THERE'S A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY GIVEN REDUCED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT POSSIBILITY
THAT REVENUES WILL BE LOWER. IN
THE BUDGET YEAR THAN HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN. ASSUMED SO
ESTABLISHING SOME SOME SORT OF
MECHANISM TO PRIORITIZE
REVENUES FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS
IS VERY REASONABLE. WE SIMPLY
POINT OUT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT YOU COULD STRUCTURE
THIS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ESSENTIALLY HAVE. TWO TIERS THE
FIRST SET OF PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD RECEIVE FUNDING. AS
REVENUE COMES IN AND ONCE THOSE
ARE FULLY FUNDED BEEN THE
REMAINING PROGRAMS COULD START
RECEIVING FUN YOU COULD HAVE
MORE CARE YOU COULD STRUCTURE
IT DIFFERENT WAYS. AND OF
COURSE MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
FINAL SPENDING PLAN SHOULD
REFLECT THE PROGRAM THAT YOU
THINK ARE MOST IMPORTANT. I
WORTH NOTING THE MAYOR
WITHDRAWS TWO MAJOR CLIMATE
PROPOSALS FROM JANUARY OF FOUR
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
CLIMBED UP ON. AND ALSO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR NEWLY ESTABLISHED CLIMATE
CATALYSTS LINED. AND TWO OTHER
QUICK NOTES- THE MAY REVISION
AND STILL CONTINUES WHAT IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD RELATE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. THIS IS TO
CREATE A NEW OVERSIGHT BOARD
THAT WOULD- IN ADDITION TO
DOING OVERSIGHT WITNESSED WHICH
SET FEES IN THE FUTURE AND ALSO
TRAILER THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH A NEW FEE STRUCTURE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS
ONGOING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND
THEN NOTABLY THERE'S ALSO
INCREASE SPENDING IN THE MAY
REVISION. FROM BOND FUND
PRICKLY PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
TWO YEARS AGO- THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT HELPS
EXPLAIN AND- WHY EVEN THOUGH
YOU SEE ALL THOSE GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS. IN THE BUDGET- THIS
INCREASE IN MONTANA IS THAT ONE
OF THE MAJOR REASONS THAT
OVERALL SPENDING APPEARS TO BE
FLAT. SO WITH THAT- I AM HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS OF COURSE
MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE TO HELP
ADDRESS. ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE- AS WE GO FOR THREE
GENDER. WHEN WE HEAR FROM
FINANCE ON THEIR COMMENTS AND
THEN WILL PASS WILL OPEN UP FOR
MEMBERS. DO YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
ANYTHING THE HERS. FINANCE IN
THE MORNING TO RESET HELLERTOWN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WHAT
ARE YOU LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM. ARE ALWAYS
AVAILABLE. FOLLOW OKAY- WHAT'S
THAT TURNED TO MEMBERS SAID
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE A
COMMENT IF YOU CAN KEEP THEM
UNDER TWO MINUTES WE ARE IN A
LITTLE TIME BASIS. HERE I'LL
JUST NOTED THAT. GENERALLY ALL
THE CAP AND TRADE ITEMS AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE AGENDA HAVE
BEEN- BUT PUSHED OUT SO WE CAN
HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THIS I
KNOW ONE OF THE CRITERIA THAT
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS USES.
REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THERE ARE OTHER VERY
VALUABLE PUBLIC POLICY PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE- THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PUTS OUT A PROPOSAL WE
HAVE. WORK THAT WE DO HERE
DETERMINING WHICH- PROGRAMS
GIVE US THE BIGGEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK BECAUSE WE STILL DO
HAVE A CLIMATE CRISIS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE USE WHATEVER
LIMITED SO FANS WE HAVE- SO. IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT.
OTHERWISE IN THAT CENTER DON'T
YOU RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- TIES HAVE A GENERAL
COMMENT FIRST I DIDN'T. WELL
THIS WHOLE I'M GONNA TAKE TAKE
OPPORTUNITY FIRST TO THANK MY
STAFF THAT HAS VIGOROUSLY WORK
SINCE THURSDAY NIGHT ON GETTING
FOUR HUNDRED BILLS OR FOUR
HUNDRED- PROPOSALS. ARE
REVIEWED AND I AND YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT BEING
DISENFRANCHISED VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA I FEEL REALLY
DISENFRANCHISED RIGHT NOW ON
THE BILL TO BE ABLE TO
COMPREHEND THE AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT WERE ASKED TO DO IN THE
SHORT PERIOD TODAY. NUMBER ONE
AND SO- THERE ARE A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE ABOUT HOW THIS
PROCESS IS GOING TO GO FORWARD
AND HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE ABLE TO EVEN HAVE ANY
OVERSIGHT AT ALL SO BUT I KNOW
THAT WILL BE FOR ANOTHER TIME I
NO WONDER TIME FRAME SO. I JUST
WANTED TO STATE THAT I WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF- WE WERE UP. WE
GOT A LOT OF THE STUFF LATE
LAST NIGHT ABOUT EIGHT O'CLOCK
AND WE WERE HERE AT SEVEN THIS
MORNING TRYING TO DIGEST ALL
THIS BUT I DID HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE- FOR THE LA O'S OFFICE
SO WE BASICALLY HAVE THE BUZZ
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE
AND THEN WE'RE TRYING TO
BALANCE BACK ON. WE REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THE PROCESS IS TODAY
WHICH IS WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
MASS VOTE HERE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY HEAR
THESE PROPOSALS THROUGH A
REGULAR- COMMITTEE PROCESS. SO
I HAVE ONE QUESTION ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE-
WE CREATED THE DTS C. TO DO
JUST THAT IS TO HAVE OVERSIGHT
SO THAT WE DIDN'T. AND WAS A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT CREATED
THEM- TO ALLOW THEM TO. FIGURE
OUT WHAT. THE EXPERTS ARE THERE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GO TO THE
EXPERTS FIND OUT WHAT. WE USE
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT'S IN A BARREL
OF OIL- THAT'S GOING TO.
CONTAMINATE OR NOT CONTAMINATE
OR HURT THE PUBLIC AND NOW
WE'RE GOING BACK AND WE'RE
ASKING TO RECREATE A BOARD TO.
OVERSEE THAT BOARD AND THEN
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO SET. UP FINES AND FEES
WHICH GOES BACK TO THEM IT'S
KIND OF LIKE THE- THE FOX-
GARDEN IN HOUSE SO I WHAT WAS
WANTED WHAT THE THOUGHT PROCESS
IS- IN THIS- PROPOSAL. YEAH I'D
LIKE THE LA- ANSWERED THAT IT
WAS PART OF THAT REVIEW PROCESS
THAT WE HAD THAT WAS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY HAVE-
AN APPEALS. BOARD BUT PLEASE
ELLIE A GO AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU- THIS IS BRIAN BROWN AGAIN
WITH THE LA- ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO IS REALLY OUR
LEAD ON PTSD I THINK IS STILL
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING IN- SEAN
MARTIN BUT- I CAN TAKE A FIRST
STEP IN THE INSURANCE. AND WE
CAN CERTAINLY GET BACK. TO YOU
SENATOR DOLLY IT AS NECESSARY.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS
PROPOSAL INITIALLY BACK IN
JANUARY- WE FELT LIKE IT WAS
ULTIMATELY A REASONABLE
APPROACH- GIVEN. PAST REVIEWS
BY. THE REVIEW PANEL THAT BEEN
CONVENTION. THE MAIN ISSUE NOW
I THINK THAT WE FACE IS THAT
THIS ULTIMATELY IS A- VERY
SIGNIFICANT. POLICY CHANGES
PROPOSED AND AS YOU MENTIONED.
THE COMMITTEE HAD NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. FULLY FLESH IT
OUT IN SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
OVER THE PAST. COUPLE OF MONTHS
WE DO THINK THE PROPOSAL
REASONABLE AT THE PROPOSAL TO.
LOOK REAL LOOK AT THE FEE
STRUCTURE IS REASONABLE GIVEN
THE ON GOING A VERY SIZEABLE.
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND IN THOSE
FUNDS AND AS OF JANUARY THE
PROPOSAL HAD BEE USED TO BEEN
TO USE GENERAL FUND TO BACK
FILL. THOSE STRUCTURAL DEFICITS
THE PROPOSAL NOW AMAZED TO USE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND BUT
THAT AGAIN IS A ONE TIME
SOLUTION SO THINKING ON A
LONGER TERM ABOUT HOW TO. DO
PROPER OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO GIVE IN PAST
PROBLEMS AND ADDRESSING THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS AND WE-
DEALT TO OTHER MAJOR FUN DATE
THAT WE THINK ARE REASONABLE
PROPOSALS. YOU COULD CONSIDER
WHETHER OR NOT- GIVEN THEM
PRIMARILY POLICY PROPOSALS YOU
COULD CONSIDER WHETHER TO.
WHETHER YOU WANT AN ACTING PART
OF THIS BUDGET OR WHETHER YOU
WANT TO DO THEM- OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS GIVEN THAT. THE
ENACTMENT OF THE TRAILER BILLS
NOT NECESSARY TO ENACT THE
CURRENT. BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. WHAT WHAT DO
YOU SEE THE ROLE OF THE
OVERSIGHT BOARD. SO I A. N. AND
I MAY WANT TO ASK IF FINANCE
WANTS TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION GIVEN
THAT IT'S THEIR PROPOSAL BUT AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT THE- AND AS WE
REVIEW THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THE PURPOSE OF THE
BOARD WHICH WOULD BE TWO FOLD
ONE IT WOULD HEAR APPEALS TO IT
WOULD BE TO- TO SET FEET ON AN
ONGOING BASIS THAT THE
INTENTION WOULD BE TO SET THOSE
FEES IN A WAY THAT ALIGN WITH.
THE APPROVED BUDGET- ENACTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE EACH YEAR. SO
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS IN THE THIRD IN
TERMS OF THE PARTICULAR FOR THE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY THERE
SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE
MONITORING AND PUBLIC
REPORTING- THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE SCHOOLS AND ITS ACT THE
ACTIVITIES UNDERTAKING. TO
IMPLEMENT- STATED GOALS. OKAY
THANK YOU RAISE THAT- THIRTY
SEE ANOTHER HAND. SENATOR STERN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
COMMENTS AS THESE ISSUES COME
UP FOR DISCUSSION BUT I JUST
WANNA MAKE ONE HIGH LEVEL
COMMENT WHICH IS A GENERAL
CONCERN ABOUT. THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL BUDGET. LOOKING
SOMEWHAT EXPENDABLE AT THIS
POINT BASED ON THE PROPOSALS
WE'VE SEEN WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER AREAS A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW IN THE GENERAL FUND.
AS WELL AS OUR SPECIAL FUNDS-
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT. TREATING
SAY THE FISH AND WILDLIFE'S
BUDGET. CUTS TO BACK FILL THE
GENERAL FUND IS A SOLUTION-
THAT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE A
SOLUTION TO ME- OUR CLEAN AIR
MONEY YOU BEING USED TO
BACKFILL- SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT MONEY
THAT IS GOING TO BE CRUCIAL TO
GET THROUGH THIS MEGA DROUGHT
THIS YEAR FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. CUT YOU LOOK AT
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC-
STRUGGLING AND HAVE TO. LOOK AT
THEIR ENTIRE MISSION A NEW ENDS
IN PROP SIXTY EIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION EVEN THOUGH I
CAN SEE. I APPRECIATE THE
EXPEDITED EXPENDITURE PUSH
WE'RE STILL SEEING MAJOR
PULLBACKS IN COMMUNITY ACCESS
AND OTHER CRITICAL FUNDING. SO
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
AREA OF THE BUDGET WHICH IS
BUILT IN ALREADY A SMALL
SECTION OF THE GENERAL FUND.
BEING UTILIZED REALLY FOR
BACKFILL SUPPORT AND NOT.
LOOKING FORWARD. THESE COSTS
WILL COME BACK TO BITE US
WHETHER IT'S GOING TO SHORTEN
PULLING UP SHORT ON FIRES THE
DROUGHT. ATTENDING EXTINCTIONS
OR THE CRISIS IN AGRICULTURE-
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO AWAY SO
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT'S IT IT'S
A GENERAL HIGH LEVEL COMMENT
BUT I HOPE THAT THERE'S SOME
WAY TO LOOK FOR AND I DID WANT
TO ASK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
DIDN'T I CAUGHT THE LA FRAMING
THE- THE WILDFIRE BANDA THE
CLIMATE BOND AS A WITHDRAWAL
BUT WHAT I UNDERSTOOD FROM MR
VISWANATHA ON IT THE GENERAL
BUDGET HEARING LAST WEEK WAS
THAT. THE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS STILL CONSIDERING- BONDING
AS A POSSIBILITY FOR FUTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING WHETHER
IT'S BUILT OR NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN WE GET SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THAT IS THERE
STILL OPEN THIS- THE SENATE.
SENT IN A LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR THIS WEEK- THE SIMPLY
DID THE SAME ON VARIOUS BOND
PROPOSALS BUT IS THERE STILL
OPENNESS TO USING GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDING IS ONE OF.
MANY MECHANISMS TO DEAL WITH
THE PENDING LIABILITIES HERE
MISS CALVERT YOU WANNA TAKE
THAT. THIS IS THERESA CALLING
AND- THE PERIMETER YEAH-
CORRECT WE HAVE JOHN THAT NIGHT
IT WAS WORKING FINE BUT-
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE ON
APPROACHES THAT ARE SPECIALLY
FOCUSED ON JOB CREATION WHICH
WAS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED.
PROVISIONS PAGES SO I DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION ON SPECIFIC
MECHANISM. BUT I KNOW THAT
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. THAT FOCUS
ON STOCK. I BELIEVE IT SEAN
MARTIN WITH THE LA- IT'S ON THE
PHONE TRYING TO SPEAK ON THIS
CAN WE- PATCH MEN. MODERATOR.
THIS TIME I'M AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND I WAS HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND I WAS JUST
ABLE TO JOIN THAT THE HEARING
IF YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT CAL JAM NOW I-
I'M DEPARTMENT TALK TO
SUBSTANCES CONTROL THE HAPPY
DANCE IN. WE'LL WE'LL TAKE
THOSE. FOLLOW UP BEFORE
THURSDAY'S FULL BUDGET HEARING-
FOR MEMBERS I KNOW- WE'VE ASKED
FOR A BREAKDOWN WE'VE BEEN JAM
FOR TIME ON THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT FUNDING BECAUSE IF
THERE'S A BIG JUMP FROM.
JANUARY YOU KNOW THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF THE FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR BOND IT WAS A BILLION
DOLLAR PIECE. NOW IT'S IT WAS A
HALF A BILLION NOW IT'S UP TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION SO. THE BREAK DOWN OF
HOW THAT IS BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
ITEM SHIPPED TO THIS CLIMATE
CATALYST FROM THE TO THE
CLIMATE BONDS. OFF THE CAP AND
TRADE INTO TWENTY SEVEN TO A
PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND JUST SORT
OF SORTING OUT THAT. VERY GOOD
OKAY. I SEE NO OTHER HANDS
LET'S- THANK YOU L. A. O. THANK
YOU FINANCE FOR THAT LET'S MOVE
TO OUR FIRST DISCUSSION ITEM
THIS WILL BE CAL FIRE- THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE TWENTY NINE
ON YOUR. SHE'S MEMBERS GO AHEAD
CAL FIRE IF YOU'RE ONLINE. YEAH
FIRST DOING BAD SO IT'S KIND OF
A QUICK OVERVIEW- IF I COULD-
FINANCE SO THE MINISTRATION
PROPOSES EIGHTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND.
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION I'M
GOING. FIGHTING POSITIONS BY
CALIFORNIA. BILITY THE FIRE
SEASON AND BEYOND AS FAR.
THAT'S THE GOVERNOR MENTIONED
IN HIS- MIRACLE EAR VERSION
RELEASE I WOULD SAY HE IS ONE
OF THE AREAS WITHIN. YOU NEED
TO WANNA MAKE OR INVESTMENTS-
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PREPARED
FOR- IF THAT IS THAT I CAN
CERTAINLY HELP. SO THEY REGION
MODIFIES A GOVERNMENT OF
WOLVES- BY ELIMINATING THE NON
FIREFIGHTER POSITIONS THAT WERE
BOTH PROS AT THAT TIME AS WELL
AS- VARIOUS ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS- INSTEAD IT
DEDICATES ALL OF THE FUNDING.
THE SAME LEVEL AS OPPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET GETS ALL
THE FUNDING TO FIRE FIRE FIRE
FIGHTER SPECIFIC RELATED
POSITIONS- AND THEN OUT OF
PORTIONS OF THE FINDINGS WILL
BE USED- ACROSS THE FIVE YEAR
PHASE IN LAND FOR. SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTING POSITIONS AND SOME
SEARCH ASKING RESOURCES AS THEY
WORK THROUGH THEIR ****
DEFINITELY ONE OF THE PERMANENT
POSITIONS BUT WHEN. THEY HAPPEN
REACH OUT THAT WAY I JUST KNOW
THIS WELL THE COMMITTEETHAT
OVER THE PAST YEARS STACEY'S TO
COMMENT. OF VERY SIMMERED
EASTON AS WELL AS SOMEBODY ACT.
ONE TIME APPROACH. TO HELP
ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF. JOBS
PAST YOU RELATED. NEEDS SUCH AS
FOURTH FIREFIGHTER AND
EXTENDING. THE FIRE. ENGINE
AVAILABILITY. RIGHT IN THE BACK
INTO THE FIRE SEASON IS ONE OF
THE MAIN FOCUS IS THIS PROPOSAL
IS TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE THAT
RELY ON. MY INSTAGRAM- THAT ONE
TIME NATURE AND. PUT IN CEMENT
BASE FUNDING TO GET.
ACCESSIBILITY TO TRY THOSE. ON
AN ONGOING INITIALLY KNOW THAT
YOUR FUNDAMENTAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS PROVIDE BOTH
FLEXIBLE AND PERSONAL RESOURCES
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT BOTH OUR
PROTECTION. AND FOREST
MANAGEMENT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
IT'S REALLY IN BOTH AREAS- ONE
OF THE KEY IMPORTANT PIECES OF.
PERMANENT STAFFING. IS THAT
THEY ARE AVAILABLE IN THE NON
B. SEASON TWO DUE FOREST. KILLS.
REDUCTION PROJECTS WERE THERE
BE. CAN HOLD THEM UNION AND
CLEARING OR PRESCRIBED THE
OTHER TOOLS AVAILABLE. SO I
THINK THAT'S REALLY HARD
FLEXIBILITY IN THE PERSON TOLD
ME THIS PACKAGE PROVIDES. AND
THEN LASTLY JUST. IT WAS RIGHT
AT JUST ABOUT TERM FUNDING WE
WILL THAT THAT AT THIS POINT
WOULD COMPROMISE SOME OF THE
ACCUSATIONS HE'S- AND IT'S YOU.
KNOW LIES ON STARTING AT LIKE
WE HIRE TEMPORARY OR SEASONAL
WORKERS- THAT HELPS ME KEEP
FIREMEN ALEXIS JUST TALKING
ABOUT HAVING THAT WORK FORCE IN
THE OFF. SEASON TO HELP
YOURSELF LAST THE BOARD THEY
NEEDS TO BE DONE WORKFORCE.
ALSO I THINK ONE OF THE-
REASONS FOLKS TALK ABOUT
SEASONAL IS THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF IT MAYBE IT'S LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN- HAVING A PERMANENT I
THINK WITH A NUMBER OF FACTORS
THAT COME WITH HIRING AND- AND
DOWN SIZING THE SEASONAL STAFF
AND THINGS LIKE THAT THAT'S
REALLY NOT. A GREAT DEAL OF
ACTUAL SAVINGS THAT COMES WITH
THAT A ROUTE OVER AND- THANKS.
I'M ALSO THE SEASONAL YOU GET A
LOT OF BODIES THAT HAVE LOWER
SKILL LEVEL AND- FOR INSTANCE
SO THAT THE LATTER SKILLS AND
TRAINING THAT YOU GET FROM THE
COMPANY OFFICER. PERMANENT
STAFFING REDUCES- THE
FLEXIBILITYAND INDEPENDENCE.
VILLAGE WORK INDEPENDENTLY AND
PERSONNEL AND WHERE YOU CAN
TAKE THE- I WAS. YOU CAN MOVE
IT AROUND THEY CAN GET A WHOLE
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT PIECES OF
THE NEED AND YOU LOSE A BUNCH
OF THAT VERSATILITY AND
FLEXIBILITY. YOU HAVE AN OVER
RELIANCE ON THE SEASONAL. SO
JUST WANTED TO. YOU KNOW ALSO I
GUESS LAST WEEK POINT OUT THAT
I WILL BE IN THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THE PERMANENT.
PHYSICIANS IN PLACES THAT IT
HAS THEM IN THE UNITS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS CONTINUOUSLY SO
THAT HELPS. SHIPS WITH BOTH THE
LOCAL LANDOWNERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT AND HAVING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS IS A REAL BENEFIT
ALSO TO- FORCE MANAGEMENT
PEOPLE BREAK. OUT OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS IN THE JUST
OPERATION IS NEEDED AT. THE
STATE LEVEL SO WITH THAT YOUR
AVAILABLE FOR. QUESTIONS ALSO
YOU SAW THE DEPARTMENT SO.
RESPONDING TO QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR THE CENSUS MISS PETERS
WITH THE LA YOU HAVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE. IT AS MR
KAREN AND MAN AND MEMBERS I
JUST COMPUTERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND SO IT JUST AND IN TERMS OF-
PUTTING TOGETHER YOUR OVERALL
BUDGET PRIORITIES AND AS A
PERSONAL FINANCES INDICATED
ALREADY THAT THE REVISION DOES
RETAIN A VERY SIGNIFICANT I'M
STOPPING AUGMENTATION FOR CAL
FIRE AND THERE ARE SOME SLIGHT
MODIFICATIONS AS WAS MENTIONED
TOO I'M REFOCUS SOME OF THE
POSITIONS I'M JUST A LITTLE
DETAIL AROUND THE SEASONAL
RESOURCES WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INCLUDES I'M FORTY FOUR MILLION
OF THOSE DOLLARS WOULD BE FOR
SEASONAL. AND SEARCH CAPACITIES
THAT ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
FUNDING WOULD BE FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING SOME IMMEDIATE RELIEF
COMING FIRE SEASON THIS SUMMER
AND OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE'S
GONNA NEED TO WEIGH THIS
SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATION
AGAINST OTHER BUDGETARY
PRIORITIES AND GIVEN THAT D. D.
CURRENT DRY CONDITIONS THAT WE
HAD IN THE LITTLE PRECIPITATION
WINTER THAT WE HAD THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF CONCERN THAT
THIS COULD BE A PARTICULARLY
BAD FIRE YEAR AND SO THERE CAN
BE VERY GOOD REASONS FOR
WANTING TO AUGMENT HEALTHCARE'S
RESOURCES. I'M AS DEPARTMENT
FINANCES INDICATED I'M ONE OF
THOSE OPTIONS COULD JUST BE TO
FOCUS ON THEIR SEASONAL
RESOURCES THAT YOU CAN GET ON
BOARD VERY QUICKLY AND I ALSO
SORT OF LIMITS YOUR ON GOING ON
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENTS AND
ANOTHER OPTION COULD BE TO DO
I'M JUST THE FIRST YEAR AT THIS
MULTI YEAR PLAN SO THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL. ARE
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THIS UPCOMING FIRE
SEASON AS WELL AS ON BOARDING
I'M UP FOR A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO ADDITIONAL
FIREFIGHTING PERMANENT
FIREFIGHTING STAFF- AND THEN
YOU COULD- WAIT AND SEE WHEN
YOU HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON
THE STATES FOR A FUTURE FISCAL
OUTLOOK AND THE GENERAL FUND
CONDITION IN THE COMING YEARS
AND GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE STATE
ECONOMIC CONDITION- I BELIEVE
THAT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
DOES AND. LAY OUT ONE OF THE
ALTERNATIVE THAT WE PUT. I'M IN
PARTICULAR JUST DOING THE FIRST
YEAR OF FINDING AND THAT REALLY
PUT YOU A LOT OF. IS STILL GO
FORWARD WITH PLAN OF ALSO
PRESERVE REFLEXIVE TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS IN THE FUTURE AS
YOU GET MORE INFORMATION ON THE
STATE. I'M HAPPIER GENERAL FINE
CONDITION WHICH IS ALSO
EXPECTED TO HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES. AND ALSO THE
BACKGROUND OR THAT WE HAD ON
THE 2% OF THE FOREST AT THE
STATE OWNS IN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE'VE SPENT OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON.
MITIGATION AND SUPPRESSION THIS
THIS CHANGES AS EACH FIRE
SEASON THIS HOW MUCH. PERMANENT
STAFF IS ABLE TO DO THAT THE
MITIGATION WORK THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE DONE- VERSUS FIGHTING A
FIRE THAT'S- A BLAZING AND-
DECEMBER SO WE WON'T REALLY
KNOW THAT. AHEAD OF EACH FIRE
SEASON. CORRECT. THERE MUST BE
CORRECT YES. I MEAN TROUBLE
GETTING MYSELF AND EIGHT IN
TERMS OF THAT THE- RESOURCES
FOR AUGMENTING THE FIRE
RESPONSE STAFF AND IT IS
CORRECT THAT THOSE RESOURCES
CAN BE AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE SUN
AND ADDITIONAL CAPACITY FOR
DOING THESE PROJECTS IN THE
OFFSEASON I'M HOWEVER AND I
WOULD KNOW THERE ISN'T GREAT
DATA ON THE AMOUNT OF THAT WORK
IS ACTUALLY BEING DONE WITH THE
STAFF THERE'S OTHER PROGRAMS
GRANT PROGRAMS IN OTHER STOCKS
THAT CAL FIRE HAS DEDICATED TO
DOING. CERTAIN PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS DEDICATED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
CREWS- AND THEN THAT FOREST
HEALTH TYPES OF GRANTS THAT ARE
BEING ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT AND SO WHILE THERE
COULD BE SOME CROSSOVER AND IT
DOES THE BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK IN TERMS OF THE FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES ARE GOING TO COME TO
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED AND SET
UP TO DO THOSE- AND AS YOU SAID
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
HOW MUCH CAPACITY. THESE ARE
FIGHTING STUFF WOULD HAVE TO
ASSIST WITH THOSE BUT I'M SURE
THE MINISTER SHOULD BE WIDELY
IN AS WELL MMHM OUR MEMBERS AS
YOU CAN SEE THE WE'VE TAKEN THE
ALLEY- SEGMENTATION OR ONE OF
THE OPTIONS AND FULLY FUND THE
FIRE- CAL FIRE AND THE RELIEF
STAFFING FOR A HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO POSITIONS THIS YEAR. THE
COMPLETE AMOUNT THAT- EIGHTY
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION AND THEN
AS WE GO THROUGH THIS FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT
THAT WE HAVE TRY TO LOOK
PRUDENTLY NEXT YEAR TO SEE
WHAT'S WHAT'S BEST WHAT'S BEST
WOULDN'T GIVE THEM THE FULL
FUNDING SO. ANYONE HAVE
QUESTIONS. FOR THE LA OVER. CAL
FIRE CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR I THINK IT'S MORE FOR CAL
FIRE INITIALLY. WE KNOW THE
FIRE RISK REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A
SEASON ANYMORE WE CAN CALL IT
SEASONAL STAFFING AT THIS POINT
BUT WE JUST HAD A MAJOR FIRE
LAST WEEK- IN THE DISTRICT AND-
IT'S ALREADY BEGUN. SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF. BABB
PRIORITIES AND HOW THESE
PERSONNEL STAFFING POSITIONS
WOULD BE UTILIZED TO THE CHAIRS
POINT- HOW MUCH IS SORT OF
ANTICIPATED TO BE IN THE
CROSSOVER SPACE CITY OF. FIRE
RISK MITIGATION VERSES. SORT OF
AN ONGOING SUPPRESSION STAND BY
RESOURCE HAS HAS THERE BEEN ANY
THOUGHT TO THAT BREAK DOWN. BUT
I CAN COVER THAT IF YOU LIKE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD BAND DIRECTOR.
WELL GOOD MORNING AND I SHARE
WORKOUTS SKI AND SENATORS- I
APPRECIATE BEING IN FRONT OF
YOU. TODAY HAND REALLY I'D LIKE
TO SIMPLY EMPHASIZE THAT THAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF PERMANENT
STAFFING TO MEET THE INCREASING
DEMANDS ARE PLACED ON CAL FIRE
TO MEET THE YEAR ROUND WORK
LOAD AS AS SENATOR STERN JUST
MENTION OF WHAT'S NOW A
UBIQUITOUS- FIRE YEAR IS KEY TO
MEETING ALL OF THEIR THE
MISSION ELEMENTS THAT CAL FIRE.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SO- AND
WHILE WE DO HAVE FIRES A YEAR
ROUND NOW- THERE ARE PERIODS OF
TIME WHEN THAT THOSE BUYERS ARE
LESS LIKELY FOR- REQUIRE LESS
OF A FULL RESPONSE MEETING
STATEWIDE- RESPONSE SO WHEN
THOSE THINGS ARE HAPPENING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THE
PERMANENT- EXTRA PERMANENT
STAFFING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL IS.
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
PRESCRIBED FIRE WORK FOR
INSTANCE IN THE NORTHERN PART
OF THE STATE WHEN WE'RE
RESPONDING TO WILDFIRES THAT
ARE HAPPENING IN DECEMBER
JANUARY FEBRUARY AND SOME IN
SOME CASES- IN ANOTHER PART OF
THE STAPLE THE SE- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE WILL THIS WILL
GIVE US THE FLEXIBILITY- AND
THE STAFF TO BE ABLE TO SEARCH
NOT ONLY TO THE PEAK FIRE
SEASON- THAT HAPPENS. ANNUALLY
BUT ALSO THE FIRE YEAR- AS WELL
AS TO MEET THE INCREASING NEEDS
OF DOING THAT FUELS WORK TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE- GOALS IN
REDUCING- CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
IN FORESTED AREAS BY- HELPING
THOSE FOR US TO REMAIN HEALTHY
AND ON- SEQUESTER CARBON. AS
WELL AS THE OF FUEL THAT COULD
CARRY FOR INTO NEIGHBORHOODS-
AND AREAS WHERE- POPULATIONS OR
INFRASTRUCTURE COULD BE DAMAGED
SO- WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
SEVERAL TIMES OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS BUT I CAN'T.
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT THIS IS
AN ABSOLUTE IMPORTANCE FOR US-
IT WILL PUT US ON A TRACK TO.
BETTER MEET THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AND WORK
TOWARD THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
WILL HAVE WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU CHIEF.
JUST TRYING TO GET A LITTLE
FLIRTY YEAH JUST TRYING TO GET
A LITTLE CLARITY SO ANY ANY
ANTICIPATED BREAK DOWN THOUGH
FOR THE SORT OF ABILITY TO MAKE
THIS STAFF USEFUL FOR SAY
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT-
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS
THAN ANTICIPATED USE. GOING
FORWARD YOUR- THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR BRINGING IT BACK TO THAT
IT'S OVER SO I WILL JUST FOCUS
ON- FUELS REDUCTION AND- AND
PRESCRIBED BURNING SPECIFICALLY
TO THIS- PROPOSAL. WHERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY AND WE'VE BEEN
HOLDING- VERY CLOSELY TO OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS IS MEETING
A YEAR OF- FORTY FIVE. THOUSAND
ACRES OF TREATMENT BY CAL FIRE
STAFFED SO WE'RE WORKING TOWARD
AN OVERALL GOAL ON PRIVATE
LANDS OF A HALF A MILLION ACRES
A YEAR. FOR SERVICE IS DOING
THE SAME ON THE FEDERAL LANDS
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR CAL
FIRE SPECIFICALLY TO BE- IN
CHARGE OF AN INVOLVED IN DOING
THOSE THOSE. CRITICAL ACRES IS
SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES SO WERE
TWO THIRDS OF THE WAY THERE-
ONE OF THE- MAJOR. COINS THAT
WE NEED TO GET OVER THE HURDLES
WE NEED TO GET OVER IS HAVING
PERMANENT STAFF. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
ENTRUSTED BY THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHAT HAPPENS IS WITH THE
TRANSIENT WORKFORCE THAT COMES
AND GOES DURING PEAK FIRE
SEASON- AND THEN INTO THE
SHOULDER SEASONS. THEY MAKE
THEY MAKE- SURFACE LEVEL I'LL
CALL THEM- RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE COMMUNITY WITH RANCHERS
WITH FOREST LANDOWNERS WITH-
OPEN SPACE. GROUPS AND WHEN WE
MOVED TO A PERMANENT WORK FORCE
AND THIS IS BEEN SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY WE BECOME PART OF THE
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE THOSE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE SHOWING UP FOR
WORK A YEAR ROUND AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE MEETING WITH PEOPLE AT
AT TOWN HALL MEETINGS- THEY'RE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY DOING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS
TALKING WITH INDIVIDUALS. ARE
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AS WELL TO BE A PART
OF THE COMMUNITY AND THEN TO
BUILD THE TRUST THAT IS. NEEDED
TO INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THIS
THIS PIECE OF THESE PERSONNEL
WILL GET US FROM THE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY TREATING TO THE
SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES WE'RE
WE'RE- INTENDING TO TREAT. BY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE. X.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THAT
INSIGHT- WE ARE OVERTIME ON
THIS ITEM IF YOU HAVE VERY
SHORT CENTER DOLLY. I'M I JUST
WANT TO FOLLOW UP THE TO THE
CHIEF. DO ARE YOU ABLE TO
ASSIST. PRIVATE LANDOWNERS IN
TO GET THAT GOAL YOU'RE MEETING
I KNOW THAT- AS A FARMER WE CAN
DO NAG BURN BUT THEY DON'T
ASSIST AS THEY COME OUT LOOK AT
IT AND THEN WE'RE ON OUR OWN
AND THERE'S A LOT OF RISK IN
THAT. ARE YOU ABLE TO ASSIST
THOSE PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO DO
THOSE BURNS. YES WE ARE AND AS
THE AS WE HAVE MORE STAFF WILL
BE MORE AND MORE CAPABLE OF
DOING THAT- THE CALIPH UTP.
THAT'S THE VEGETATION TROPE.
TREATMENT PROGRAMMATIC E. I. R.
THAT WAS JUST PASSED THROUGH
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY- BACK IN
JANUARY THAT IS THAT THE-
TEARING DOCUMENT THAT WE WILL
ALL BE ABLE TO USE. TO BURN ON.
A STATE AND PRIVATE LANDS- AND
WE'RE ALSO AND WE ALSO HAVE A
PROGRAM OF. BUILDING OUT-
PRESCRIBED FIRE SPECIALISTS IN
THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY THERE WILL
ALSO BE AVAILABLE. FOR
LANDOWNERS TO USE AND WE'RE
WORKING ON AN INSURANCE.
PROGRAM THAT WILL BE BACK IN
SOME WAY BY THE STATE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE. THOSE
PRIVATE BURNERS HAVE THE
BACKING OF THE STATE IN DOING
GOOD WORK AND WE'RE TRYING TO
GET US CENTER REQUIRE VERY
SHORTLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR OF THIS ADDRESS
TWO QUICK. QUESTIONS TO THE
CHIEF AND THEN. ALSO A QUICK
COMMENT I THINK PANDEMIC OR NO
PANDEMIC. THAT WE LIVE IN THIS
ERA IS. THE CHAIR HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON THIS FOR THE PAST
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. ERROR OF
MAYO WHILE THEN FIRES MEANS
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD ON STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS WITH CAL FIRE
THEY'RE- STILL UNDERSTAFFED
FROM WHEN THEY HIT THEIR PEAK.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND. THE NEED. FOR
THE ADDITIONAL PERMANENT. TO
FOR THE CHIEF CHAIR. NUMBER ONE
CAN YOU PLEASE ADDRESS THE
CONTRACTED TECHNO SILVA THAT
AND TALK ABOUT THE SUCCESS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN. CHIEF WITH THIS-
EARLY ADOPTION LAST YEAR I
THINK IT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE IN
REGARDS TO WHAT YOU CAN DO. ON
TACTICS WERE WHETHER IT'S
RESOURCES STRATEGY EVACUATION%
PLANNING. AND THE SECOND PIECE
IS CHIEF IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF. WHAT YOU
REALLY DO NEED TO HIT STRIDE
UNDERSTANDING. WHERE WE'RE AT
RIGHT NOW TO ONE YEAR NOT FULL
FUNDING DOES THAT MAKE SENSE
LOOKING AS WE MOVE DOWN THE
ROAD TWO YEARS INSTEAD OF THE
FIVE I JUST WOULD LIKE TO GET
YOUR TAKE ON THAT. CHIEF. HE
FORGOT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR YES- I MEAN I'M GONNA
HIT THE SECOND PIECE FIRST- SO
HITTING STRIDE- WE BUILT THIS-
THIS MAY WRITE REVISE PROPOSAL.
TO MEET THE ABILITY TO TRAIN
AND TO GET PERMANENT-
FIREFIGHTERS INTO SEATS. SO
YOU'LL NOTE THAT THERE THERE
WAS- AN AUGMENTATION AND-
JESSICA PETERS MENTIONED THAT
WE HAVE A SEASONAL COMPONENT.
THAT IS IN THE END THIS YEAR
THAT WILL HELP US MEET THIS
YEAR'S- SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT WE
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE- AND THEN
AS YOU SEE OVER THE SUCCESS OF
YOURS THAT SEASONAL COMPONENT
STARTS TO. DISSOLVE AND BECOME
PERMANENT. AND SO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IS IT HELPS
TO KEEP. KEEP THE MOMENTUM
MOVING FORWARD AS WE ADD THE
PERMANENT STAFF GOING GOING
DOWNSTREAM. IF WE DON'T AT THE
PERMANENT STAFF WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN A CONTINUOUS CYCLE OF
COMING BACK ANNUALLY ASKING FOR
AUGMENTATION. TO PUT THOSE
ADDITIONAL FIREFIGHTERS ON
ENGINES- TO HELP WITH THE- THE
WORKER BEES THE FIRE THAT THAT
THE- WHAT I CALLED THE HOST
DRAGONS AND TOOLS WINGERS- BUT
WE WON'T BE. BE BUILDING THE
NEEDED COMPANY OFFICER THAT IS
INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT WORKER.
WHO CAN MAKE DECISIONS YOU CAN.
ALL THIS ON THE FLY LINES.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
LOST IF WE DON'T MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO HIRING THESE
POSITIONS OVER TIME SO. WE
NEED. THREE YEARS TO GET TO
STRIDE AND WE NEED THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THE OF THE PROPOSAL
TO. ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
SOLIDIFIED OUR POSITION AND
WERE WE WERE. READY FOR THE
CHALLENGES SO. THAT'S THAT'S MY
ANSWER FOR THE SECOND PIECE
FIRST PIECE- TECHNO SOBER VERY
QUICKLY BY KNOWING THAT THAT'S
A SEPARATE- BUDGET PROPOSAL-
THAT'S THE RFI TO OUR- IN OUR
INNOVATION PROCUREMENT SPRINT-
WE HAVE SEEN. FAIRY IMPRESSIVE-
USE OF THAT PRODUCT. LAST YEAR
WE HAD IT FOR ABOUT THE LAST
THREE MONTHS OF THE SEASON.
SEVERAL FIRES- EVERY FIRE THAT
OCCURRED DURING THAT PERIOD-
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THEIR MODEL
AND THEN GROWN TO ITS
POTENTIAL- ONE- SPECIFIC.
EXAMPLE IS THE MARINA FIRE IN
VENTURA COUNTY WITHIN MINUTES
OF THAT FIRE STARTING- THAT- IT
WAS MODELED BY THE TECHNO
SILVER PRODUCT. AND WE HAD MAPS
IN HAND THAT WE WERE LOOKING
AT. ON SCREEN. THAT WHERE THAT
FIRE WOULD BE A SIXTY HOURS.
AND WHAT IS YOUR COMMENTS AND
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THREE ZERO
WHICH IS THE NEXT ONE WE'RE
GETTING A LITTLE AHEAD OF
OURSELVES LET'S KEEP EXPANDING-
CALENDAR THANK YOU CHIEF- SO.
THAT'S ITEM ISSUE NUMBER THREE
TWO NINE AND WE KNOW WE COULD
WE'RE ALL INVOLVED IN THIS AND
CAN TALK ABOUT- FOUR I NEED TO
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL TIME LET'S MOVE TO-
THE- INNOVATION PROCUREMENT
SPRINT ISSUE NUMBER. THREE
THREE ZERO WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE- CHIEF. AS FINDING. DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD. I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF JUST A YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING TO DO FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONGOING TWENTY FOUR
POSITIONS GENTLEMAN USING YOUR
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE BIG DRIVERS
ARE GREAT JOB OF- INTRODUCING
TO YOU- THIS INFORMATION IT
LOOKS LIKE IT'LL BE SUPER
CRITICAL BEING ABLE TO HEAR
REAL TIME. INFORMATION BASED.
ON REAL TIME WEATHER CONDITIONS
FUEL LOADS JUST REALLY HELP.
YES FOLKS RIGHT POSITION. AND
THIS TIME IT'S POSSIBLE TO HELP
WITH THAT RESPONSE- SO. ANYWAY
MR BENTSEN YOUR OKAY ABOUT
GIVEN THOSE REPORTS THE
LEGISLATURES ELIO HAS OUTLINED
IN THEIR- COMMENTS. YES WE WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THEY'RE
DOWN UNIVERSITY DOCUMENTS YOU
GET MOST RESPONSIVE STEP TWO
THEN WE WILL WE'LL SHARE SOME
DOCUMENTS- IF NOT TODAY
TOMORROW. X. MISS PETER. BELIAU
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND AS YOU
JUST MENTIONED AND THAT WE DO
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND GET THE REPORTS FROM THE
PROOF OF CONCEPT EVALUATION AS
YOUR MEMBER AND THE FUNDING
HERE IS REALLY STARTED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR- THROUGH AN
INNOVAIVE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
WHERE- DUE TO THE NATURE OF THE
TYPE OF THE PROCESS THAT WAS
BEING SENT I AM THE MINISTER
SHE WASN'T REALLY ABLE TO
PROVIDE VERY MUCH INFORMATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON. THE
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY IT MIGHT BE
PROCURING AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IN YOUR STOCK
HASN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SEE AND ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION
THAT WAS CONDUCTED IT HAS THAT
ADMINISTRATIONS INDICATED IT
SOUNDS LIKE THIS IS A VERY
PROMISING TECHNOLOGY- THAT THE
FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED HERE-
IT WOULD SUPPORT AT THREE TO
FIVE YEAR CONTRACT THAT'S IN IN
ENTERED INTO BUT THE FINDINGS
PROVIDED ON AN ONGOING BASIS
AND SO BEFORE YOU CAN BE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WE THINK THAT YOU
JUST WANT TO SEE ON THE SAME
REPORT SO YOU CAN FEEL AS AS
CONFIDENT THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
IS GOING TO BE USED ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AS THE
MINISTRATION. WE KERR MEMBERS
OKAY SEEMS STRAIGHTFORWARD
LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS- ISSUES
WE PATCH THEM ISSUES THREE TH
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE TO
THREE HUNDRED FORTY ONE DOES
THE FISH. AND WILDLIFE. LOTS OF
MOVE LOTS AND BY. DOWN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS LET'S
HAVE FINANCE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SERGIO AGUILAR WITH A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO YOU
MENTIONED THERE'S A LOT OF
MOVIES COMPONENTS THE PROPOSAL-
WHICH ARE OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA KIND OF GO OVER IT A
HIGH LEVEL SO. YOUR BROWSER IS
A HUNDRED EIGHTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS- GENERAL AND
STATE OPERATIONS WERE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
THIS REPRESENTS A NINE POINT
THREE. MILLION DOLLAR-
DECREASED OR SEVEN POINT 2%
COMPARED TO THAT POINT I
DECIDED I'D LEVEL WHEN. LOOKING
AT THE DEPARTMENT. BEING THE
SPECIAL FIND THIS. A ONE POINT
5% IN THE COMPARED TO ANYTHING
BUDGET ACT. OUR VISION OF
CONTINUES THE LOCAL GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WOULD STAND AS A
GENERAL FUND TRANSFERRED FROM
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
HOWEVER IN ADDITION WE ARE
PROPOSING NEW CRITICAL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH I NEVER.
FUN AND THAT WOULD REQUIRE AN
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND TRANSFER OF.
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE ODDS ARE
THAT YOU. I INDIA I'M THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOING. THERE IS INCLUDED
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION BASELINE REDUCTION THE
PART OF CHRISTIAN WILDLIFE
BUDGET OUT VERY PARTIALLY
OFFSET BY THE- EIGHT POINT
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS YET- I WILL KNOW THAT
WE DID INCLUDE THAT THIRTY
THREE POINTS AND THAT PART OF
THE FEDERAL TRIGGER. THE THEN
THERE ARE SUFFICIENT- BETTER
RESOURCES THAT ARE PROVIDED-
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO RESTORE
THAT THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN.
MILLION BASED ON REDUCTION AND
YOU KNOW BUT- THAT WOULD
RESTORE THE BASE I DON'T KNOW
JEN BUT THEN ALSO PROVIDES.
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE MOVIE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE PROPOSED
AS PART OF THE GOVERNMENT
RIGHT- AND WE ALSO HAVE GREATER.
BOTTOM LINES ON THE LINE. THE
QUESTION. WE FORGET TO DIRECTED
BY YOU KNOW OUR STAFF IN THE
LEGISLATE COUNCIL'S TALKED
ABOUT SINCE WE THE LIFE OF
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND THIS
IS GOING TO BE A FOUR FIFTHS
VOTE IN ORDER TO TAKE BACK THE
THIRTY MILLION THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE ME TO THE FUN.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT. YES WE
HAVE HAD RECENT DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE- THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL AND WE ARE AWARE THAT
THEY ARE. PUTTING UP FOR BOTH
WRESTLED- IN THE MERE VISION-
CRADLE BILL- SO- I WOULD KNOW
THAT. WE WERE CLOSE THERE'S
STILL A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION MAJOR VISION.
AND B. OF THE MAJOR REVISION
FURTHER BUILT- IF THAT IS
REJECTED THE AFFECTED THEY IS
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
SHARES. THE W. C. T. AND THEN.
BE EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
WOULD BE REDUCED FROM
ARTIFICIAL LIFE LIKE IT. BETTER
BE BETTER WE'RE KNOWLEDGE-
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE MOST
RECENT. POSITION THAT THERE MAY
BE CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS. ON
THE PROPOSAL BETWEEN. THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. WHAT WE DON'T
THINK IT'S JUST A THIS. BUT
BELIAU ONLINE AT READ. THANK
ARE YOU THERE MORNING EHLERS
WITH THE LEGEND OFFICE- WE HAVE
THERE ARE A LOT OF MOVING
PIECES HERE- ON ON THIS I THINK
THE FIGURE ON PAGE ONE OF SEVEN
OF YOUR AGENDA IS HELPFUL I
THINK THERE ARE THREE COMMENTS
WE WOULD MAKE FOR YOU TO THINK
ABOUT WITH THIS PROPOSAL. THE
FIRST IS AROUND THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND IS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED AND- THERE WERE A LOT
OF CONCERNS EXPRESSED ABOUT
THAT EVEN IN JANUARY WHEN IT
WAS PROPOSED BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACT ON WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD FROM WHERE THE FUNDS WILL
BE TRANSFERRED. NOW WITH THE
FORCES THOUGH FRESH OLD IT GETS
EVEN HARDER SO- THAT WOULD BE
THE FIRST IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO PURSUE AND IS THAT
SOMETHING EVEN FEASIBLE TO
PURSUE I THINK THE SECOND AS MR
BROWN. USING RESOURCES THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED FOR A BASELINE
KINDS OF THIRTY THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS PARKS IS
THE OTHER WHICH I'LL GET TO IN
YOUR AGENDA SO IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
NEED TO DO YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN A
LOT OF CLARIFICATION OVER HOW
THOSE CUTS WOULD BE TAKEN AT
THE DEPARTMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING THAT
THEY WOULD LOOK. AT WAYS
THROUGH USING THEIR SERVICE
BASE BUDGET BUT THAT DOESN'T
PROVIDE YOU A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPACTS OF THESE CUTS WOULD BE
IF YOU TOOK THEM. AND THEY ARE
BEING PROPOSED AS PART OF THE
FEDERAL TRIGGER BUT THAT WOULD
JUST BE IF WE GOT FEDERAL FUNDS
ONE TIME SO AFTER THE BUDGET
YEAR THIS WOULD BECOME BASELINE
CUTS. AND MORE- SIGNIFICANT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE H. C. F.
TRANSFERRED HELP OFFSET THEM.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA THERE ARE
ACTUALLY SOME AUGMENTATIONS
BEING PROPOSED HERE AS WEL SIX
POINT TWO MILLION IN TOTAL FOUR
MILLION FOR- GETTING CUTTING
THE GREEN TAPE INITIATIVE. AND
TWO POINT TWO MILLION FOR LANCE
MANAGEMENT WELL THOSE EFFORTS
MAY HAVE A LOT OF MERIT AND
THEY'RE NOT HUGE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
YOU KNOW WE JUST WOULD WANT YOU
TO THINK ABOUT IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO AUGMENT PROGRAMS AT
THE SAME TIME. YOU'RE BEING
PROPOSED TO CUT PROGRAMS AND
ESSENTIALLY IT'S PRIORITIZING
NEW EXPANDED EFFORTS OVER SOME
EXISTING EFFORTS AND IS THAT-
AND APPROACH YOU WANT TO TAKE.
DIRECTED BY. HOLDING OFF ON THE
BASELINE CUTS FOR A MINUTE CAN
YOU ADDRESS THE- THE CUTTING
GREEN TAPE AND- THE- THE- FUND
LAND MANAGEMENT AUGMENTATIONS.
MR GOOD MORNING IT'S NICE TO
SEE YOU AND ALL THE MEMBERS
EVEN UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO LET ME FIRST START WITH THE
CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE CONCEPT
WHICH IS A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
CONTINUATION OF A PROPOSAL
COMING OUT OF THE JANUARY
BUDGET. THIS IS GOOD WORK IT'S
SMART WORK IT ACTUALLY MAY BE
MORE STRATEGIC WORK NOW IF ONE
THINKS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
FUTURE STIMULUS. RESTARTING THE
ECONOMY AND PUTTING ENERGY INTO
GREEN JOBS. WHAT WE FIND IS
THAT APARTMENT IS WHERE ONE OF
THE- GATEWAY FUNDERS FOR
RESTORATION WORK ACROSS THE
WORLD LANDSCAPE AS WELL AS A
PRIMARY PERMIT OR OF THOSE
RESTORATION PROJECTS THE THINGS
THAT MAKE A RIVER HEALTHIER.
THE THINGS THAT OUR INVESTMENTS
TO BRING BACK OUR SALMON THE
THINGS THAT ARE FOR RESTORING
WETLANDS SO THIS FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. WOULD ALLOW US TO
INCREASE THE SCALE AND PACE OF
RESTORATION WORK. INCORPORATE
INEFFICIENCIES INTO OUR GRANT
MAKING SO WE CAN KEEP. MOVING
PROPOSITION FUNDS OUT TO OUR
NONPROFIT AND TRIBAL PARTNERS
AND PURSUE PROGRAMMATIC
PERMITTING OPTIONS THEY CAN GET
ALL OF THIS GOOD WORK DONE
FASTER. NOW IT MAY SEEM LIKE
IT'S NEW WORK BUT WE DO A LOT
OF THIS WORK ALREADY AND I
WOULD ARGUE IT'S POSSIBLE THE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS BECOMES AN
OPTIMIZATION. RATHER THAN AN
ENTIRELY NEW KIND OF WAR.
THAT'S THE CUTTING THE GREEN
TAPE ASPECT. ON THE LANDS FRONT
THE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN MY JUDGMENT IS A
PRUDENT INVESTMENT NO MATTER
THE ECONOMIC CLIMATE HERE'S WHY.
OUR DEPARTMENT OWNS AND MANAGES
ABOUT A MILLION ACRES ONE OF
THE THINGS WE SEE FROM OUR
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING EFFORT
IS ARE. LESS THAN SUPERIOR
ABILITY TO MANAGE THOSE LANDS
FOR THEIR FUTURE USE. THEIR
CLIMATE UP THE ADAPTABILITY
THEIR RESILIENCY THIS TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS WITH LET US
KEEP DOING IMPORTANT LANCE
MAINTENANCE OF OUR OWN
PROPERTIES WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
THAT CLIMB. HI EXCELLENT WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS SPENT
SOME. HOURS ON THAT SERVICE
SPACE- MANAGEMENT AND I KNOW
THAT ALL THE MEMBERS KNOW MORE
ABOUT A GAUGE STREAM- TESTING
THEN THEY THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD HAVE KNOWN ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS DON'T SEE ANY. COMMENTS
CENTER STERN JUST VERY BRIEFLY-
I KNOW WE TOUCHED ON THE- GREEN
TAPE INITIATIVE BUT- HI THIS IS
A BIT OF A HOBSON'S CHOICE HERE
AT NIGHT IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
WE HAVE ONE ALTHOUGH THE FOUR
FIFTHS VOTE THRESHOLD DOES END
UP BECOMING VALIDATED THEN
THAT'LL OBVIOUSLY GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE AN OPPORTUNITY-
PINE ON RESCINDING THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS TO FULLY FUND THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND THAT
pTHE LEGISLATURE ALSO SPOKE LAST
YEAR AND IT SEEMS TO
CONTRAVENE. OUR INTENT AND IT'S
NO. DIRECT CRITIQUE OF DIRECTOR
BONHAM OR CDFW IN FACT YOU GUYS
ARE STILL UNDER RESOURCE. BUT
ROBBING FROM PETER TO PAY PAUL
OR TO KEEP ALL THESE PROGRAMS
UP AND RUNNING SEEMS LIKE A
FALSE CHOICE AT THIS POINT SO I
I'D LOVE TO SEE. SOME FUTURE
CONSIDERATION OF RESTORING
THESE FUNDS- AND REALLY
VALIDATING THESE PROGRAMS FOR
THE CRITICAL IMPACT THEY HAVE
ON. ON THE STATE OR WE CAN
OVERSEE HIM A MASS EXTINCTION
EVENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THE NEXT DECADE
BUT- THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
PERFECTLY GOOD CHOICE EITHER.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD IT OPEN OBVIOUSLY. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING OVERTIME AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK OVERTIME THIS
COMING WEEK- LET'S MOVE TO THE
OTHER DEPARTMENT THAT'S BEING
CUT AT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE BASELINE- BUDGET WHICH
IS PARKS AND RECREATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WHO ARE THE
FOLKS ONLINE NOW READ ITEM
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO. WHICH IS. THE PARKS
RECREATION BUDGET CUTS LET'S
HEAR FROM MITCH SCHAEFER
SHOPPER FROM THE PART OF
FINANCE YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
CHARTERED PARKING LANES. GO
AHEAD OKAY AS NOTED ON THE
AGENDA AND THE BUDGET INCLUDES-
TWO PROPOSALS ONE IS A
SATISFYING FOR THE PART OF
PARKS AND RECREATION OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AND
FIFTY MILLION IN THEIR CURRENT
YEAR AND A HUNDRED IN EACH YEAR
THEY SET ASIDE- WHOSE MAJOR
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT PARKS HAS
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
DECLINES IN REVENUE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE WHITE CLOSURES- THE
EXACT IMPACT OF THESE
REDUCTIONS IS THAT I KNOW NOW
I'M OF COURSE BECAUSE IT'S ALSO
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY A HOW
QUICKLY. PARK SCANNING EACH USE
RESTRICTIONS IN A MANNER THAT
STILL CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC-
HELLO ORDERS AND AN ACCIDENT
THERE IS WHEN NAV ACTION OF THE
BUDGET AND OTHER- IT'S NOTED AS
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
CHANNEL FIND REDUCTION- THAT
WOULD BE A TRIGGER REDUCTION AS
NOTED AND- DOT INSTEAD SIMPLY
TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
ADDITIONAL- ONGOING EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS WILL NEED TO BE
MADE. PARKS. AND WE'LL BE
WORKING. VERY CLOSELY. WITH
LOCAL FEDERAL AND COPPER. AND
USING SERVICE BUDGETING MODEL
AND TO ADDRESS HOW NEEDS AND
WANTS TERM. PROGRAMMING WOULD
BE ME. I'M STILL OVER MISSED
THE THINK THAT MILLION THIS
YEAR AS OF OR IS IT AT THE
CEILING OR SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN- I'D APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION A RIGHT NOW TO TRY
TO GET MORE INFORMATION ON. AND
IN A TYPICAL YEAR HOW MUCH OF
THE REVENUES INTO THE STATE
PARKS AND RECREATION FIND HIGH
MAN FINE LINE. AND IT'S NOT AN
UNREASONABLE AMOUNT AND GIVEN
THAT MOST OF THE REVENUES THAT
CURRYING ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
SPRING AND SUMMER AND FALL
MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR WE DO
THINK THAT THERE IS LIKELY TO
BE SOME MORE INFORMATION THAT
COMES TO LIGHT IN THE COMING
WEEKS. AND THAT MIGHT HELP YOU
REFINE THE ESTIMATE AND IT'S
POSSIBLE IT COULD BE SOMEWHAT
LAST IT COULD BE HIGHER AND-
BUT IT'S POSSIBLE IT COULD BE
LESS AS WELL WHICH MIGHT BE
ABLE TO FREE UP SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
SATISFIED- BEFORE BOTH THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THE BUDGET
YOUR PERKS BACKFILL THAT
CERTAINLY THE CURRENT YEAR
THERE SHOULD BE MORE
INFORMATION COMING TO LIGHT.
YEAH AND OUR STAFF REPORT
RECOMMENDS THE FUNDING TO BACK
FILL HOLDING OFF THE TRIGGER
BUDGET CUTS SO WHEN WE- IF WE
WHEN WE CONSIDER BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE IN JULY WE'LL HAVE A
BETTER IDEA OF HOW THAT SEASON
IS GOING AROUND. THE RECOVERY-
LOOKS LIKE AT LEAST FIFTY PARKS
PEOPLE. GOING OUT TO THE PARKS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
IF I COULDN'T- JUST A FEW
COMMENTS ON THE ON THE TRIGGER
CUT SO YES WE ARE AND SO JUST
TO KNOW THAT IT'S PROPOSED FOR
THE FOLLOWING YEAR NOT THE
UPCOMING YEAR STARTING JULY ONE
AND WELL IT'S DESCRIBED IN THE
BUDGET SUMMARY THERE DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE ATTACKED TECHNICAL
N. AS IN IN THE BUDGET TO
ACTUALLY EFFECTUATE THE CUT. IN
ADDITION THAT THAT TRIGGERING
OFF MECHANISM RELATED TO
GETTING FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS
I'M ARMOR STANDING AS APPLIES
ONLY TO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
YEAR AND SO IT DOES NOT APPEAR
TO APPLY TO PARKS AS WELL AND
SO WE THINK THAT BEFORE YOU
TAKE ANY ACTION YOU'RE GONNA
WANT TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
WHAT EXACTLY THE PROPOSAL EVEN
IS RELATED TO THE PARK'S
TRIGGER KITE IS OUR TECHNICAL
MECHANISM IN THE BUDGET TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT TAX CUTS-
AND THEN IS THERE A MECHANISM
TO IMPLEMENT THE TRIGGERING
COST- AND JUST YOUR STAFF.
AGENDA NOTES IN SORT OF SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE START WITH THE- DFW
CATS AND YOU MAY WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROCESS THAT AND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT GOES THROUGH TO
DEVELOPED WHAT REDUCTIONS THAT
WOULD MAKE ALSO LIGNS WITH
YOUR OWN PRIORITIES AND YOU MAY
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON FRAMING
PROCESS LOOKS LIKE DR COMMAND A
MAN GET OVER- SOMEBODY AT THE
PARKS YOU. DO YOU AGREE WITH
THE- ALLEY OTHERS ASSESSMENT.
SURE LISA I GET MISDIRECT. OF
THE OF PARKS REC I THINK I
AGREE WITH THE FRAMING THAT
WE'RE STILL VERY MUCH- KIND F
IN THIS POINT IN TIME WHERE WE
ARE WORKING ON LOOSENING THE
RESTRICTIONS- WE ARE AS AS WE-
SPEAKING TODAY WE'VE GOT
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE REOPENED-
PARKING LOT. AND YOU'LL- SEE
THAT IN THE NEXT COMING WEEKS
WE EXPECT TO LOOSEN UP EVEN
MORE OF THOSE RESTRICTIONS. AS
YOU'RE AWARE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION. OF OUR FUNDING BASE
COMES FROM- CAMPING
RESERVATIONS LARGE GATHERINGS
LIKE WEDDINGS AND CONCERTS- A
DANCE. THAT MAY HAPPEN IN OUR
PARKS MUSEUMS IN ADDITION TO-
ACTUAL GATE FEES. SO A LOT OF
FACTORS AT PLAY- WE COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO WORKING WITH NOT
ONLY YOUR STAFF AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO WRAP OUR ARMS
AROUND THE FISCAL IMPACT NOT
ONLY IN THE CURRENT YEAR. BUT
ALSO- THE BUDGET YEAR. IN TERMS
OF I THINK THE ELIAN HAD RAISED
SOME SOME CONCERNS OR COMMENTS
RELATIVE TO. HELLO TO KIND OF
FLASHING A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WE THINK
A SAVINGS PLAN MIGHT LOOK LIKE-
I THINK AS YOU FOLKS KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN TREMENDOUS PARTNERS
WITH US OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AS WE HAVE MADE VERY
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS IN THE
STATE PARK SYSTEM- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. WELL IT HELPED TO
GUIDE OUR INVESTMENTS. IT'S
ALSO GOING TO HELP US TO USE
MORE OF A SURGICAL- VERY
REFINED APPROACH IN FIGURING
OUT WHAT THOSE PROGRAMMATIC
IMPACTS R. AS WE DESIGN A
SAVINGS PLAN. IN TERMS OF WHAT
DOESN'T ENGAGEMENT LOOK LIKE-
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP- WE HAD
LOTS OF PUBLIC MEETINGS WITH
THE PARKS AD REC COMMISSION.
ON TO DISCUSS HOW. WE WOULD
INVEST THOSE FUNDS THE ANSWER
WE WILL TO MAKE. IN THAT SAME
PROCESS. AS OU KNOW THE PARKS
AND REC COMMISSION IS A PUBLIC
MEETING YOU HAVE ON WHAT ONE OF
YOUR MEMBERS IS A DESIGNEES. ON
THAT COMMISSION THEIR PUBLIC SO
WE EXPECT TO BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
EXECUTE. TO BE BEFORE- THAT
BODY AND BEING TRANSPARENT IN
SHARING- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE SAVINGS PLAN JUST AS
THE STRONG RELATIONSHIPS THAT
WE'VE BUILT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS REALLY FOCUSED ON
THE NOTION. OF ACCESS. ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC- WE'RE
GOING TO LEAN ON THAT VERY
STRONG- SIMILAR PARTNERSHIP AS
WE GO FORWARD. AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO YOU IS THAT IT'S-
FOR ALL OF OUR SPENDING PLAN OR
SAVINGS PLAN IT'S NOT JUST US-
THE ITEM BEFORE YOU TODAY. BUT
RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT THERE'S A
FIVE PERCENT- SAVINGS PLAN THAT
APPLIES TO ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND WE EXPECTING TO
MEANT TO BE SHARING THAT WITH-
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS ALSO.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION
CENTER DOLLY RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN THIS IS. I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED SO. WE'VE BEEN
SHUT DOWN FOR TWO AND A HALF
MONTHS. WERE BUT TRYING TO
BUDGET ON THAN JUST A GENERAL
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW YOU CAN
AS A WE KNOW THAT IN. PLACES
WHERE THE BEARS HAVEN'T
HAPPENED IN THAT WE'VE LOST
MONEY. NOW WE'RE WE'RE COMING
INTO AT LEAST IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE THE IN THE
SUMMER TIME WHERE WE'RE GONNA
SEE. HOPEFULLY ARE SOME PARKS
OPEN PEOPLE CAN USE THEM TO
WORK AND THEN. SO WITH THAT SO
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME.
INTERACTIONS TO WORK IT IS VERY.
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO BUDGET
BETTER SCENARIO WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE
BUT THE QUESTION I HAVE IS SO.
WE'RE WE'RE SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO
GET SOME FEDERAL MONEY COMING
BACK ON AND ALL THESE BUDGET
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE HERE OR
MAYBE THE LA O'S OFFICE CAN
HELP ME OUT OR SOMEBODY. CAN
GIVE ME THE INFORMATION THAT.
HOW DO WE RECTIFY. WHEN WE GET
MAYBE 75% OF THE RESOURCES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT KICK IN
BECAUSE OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HOW HAVE YOU PLAYED
THAT IN YOUR BUDGET PROCESS.
THIRTY ONE TAKE THAT. ACTUALLY
I THINK THAT STRIKES ME AS
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CAN
SPEAK TO A LITTLE MORE BROADLY.
IT CERTAINLY. OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES WE ARE TRACKING-
THE RESPONSE COSTS AND IT HAD
ASSUMED INTERNALLY REVISION A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS SO THAT. NOT
ONLY THAT 7525% REIMBURSEMENT
ON THE RIVER TO SENATOR BUT
ALSO TRYING TO TRACK. CHILDREN
ALLOCATE FOR THE KRONOS VIRUS
RELIEF FUNDS AS WELL SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN CREATE.
THE REVISION. WHO DETERMINES.
THE JUSTIFICATION OF WHAT GETS
PAID WHAT DOESN'T GET PAID. THE
OFFICE OF THE REGENCY SERVICES
OUR PRIMARY CONNECTION TO THAT.
ARE YOU NOT AND SO THEY ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM
TO KIND OF DETERMINE WHAT IS
PMR REIMBURSABLE DURING DURING
THIS EVENT AND SO THEY ARE
WORKING ON THAT HARD AS WELL AS
THE NUMBER OF ENTITIES LOOKING
AT POTENTIAL FEDERAL PLANS FROM
THE RECENT FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
NINETEEN SO THERE IS AN. EFFORT
TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL FUNDING.
YOU CAN USE. AND I HAVE YOU TO
INTO CONSIDERATION. THE AMOUNT
THAT WILL BE RECEIVING IN IN
THESE BUT AND GIVEN OUT OUT TO
EACH DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR PURPOSE OF DEBT OF
BUDGETING. YES WE ARE TRYING TO
TRACK. THOSE EXPENDITURES FROM
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS. AND IT IS
ONE OF THEM BUT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF APARTMENTS THAT ARE.
BEIJING COMING NINETEEN LATER
RESPONSE COSTS AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT THOSE EXPENDITURES
AND HOW THEY ALLOCATE TO THEM
AND HOW WE ASSUME THAT YOU ARE
REIMBURSEMENT. SO WHERE WOULD
WE SEE THAT INFORMATION. SO
THAT WE CAN THEN SEE WHAT'S
GOING TO BE. WE'RE PROJECTED TO
BE REIMBURSED VERSUS THE ACTUAL
BUDGET. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I CAN DO AFTER THIS HEARING IS
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR BUDGET
STAFF AND SENT IN A RECENT
LETTER THAT WE- SENT OUT ON.
THURSDAY OR FRIDAY FRIDAY- THAT
TRIES TO LAY OUT. EXPENDITURE
PLAN AS WELL AS OUR ASSUMPTIONS
ON REIMBURSEMENT SO I WILL. THE
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT. YOU
HAVE A COPY OF THAT HELPS
DISPLACE SOMEBODY THAT
SOMETIMES WE HAVE EXPENDITURE
AND- THOSE ARE THE REAL. ART TO
THIS BUDGET THEN WOULD BE TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT'S NOT BEEN RE
REIMBURSED AND THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT'S
ACTUAL IN WHAT'S REIMBURSED AND
THEN THE REVENUE- LOSS
PROJECTION I GUESS I AM FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WAY TO PUT IT-
FOR FUTURE BUDGETING WE KNOW
THAT THE ECONOMY IS DEFINITELY
GOING TO BE IN A DOWNTURN. IN
FUTURE IN. THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE BUT WILL HAVE THE QUITE A
BIT OF IT RESOURCES FOR THIS
ONE TIME- REIMBURSEMENT FROM
THE FEMA FOLKS AND SO THAT
INFORMATION IS GONNA BE
CRITICAL ON HOW WE- LOOK AT AT
TWO TO THREE YEAR BUDGETING SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE CAL FIRE. STUFF
IS GOING TO BE THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER IS HE IS.
IS CRITICAL TO KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT THE FEMA REIMBURSEMENT IS
SO THAT WE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO
HER THREE YEARS. VERY GOOD
WE'LL STAY ON TOP OF THAT ALL
RIGHT- SEE NO OTHER HANDS UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE FINANCE
IN A- AT THE DEPARTMENT BUT
LET'S MOVE ON TO HI ISSUE
NUMBER THREE FORTY THREE WHICH
SUSTAINABLE GROUND MANAGEMENT
ACT. THIS IS THE WITHDRAWAL OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION. IS A- NOTED
ON PAGE ONE FIFTEEN THIS IS TO.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
THAT IT MAY REVISE PROPOSAL TO
WITHDRAW THIRTY MILLION FROM
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME. TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO LOCAL. THE
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABLE
AGENCIES- FOR SEGMENTATION FOR
THE PROJECT BUT TO REJECT THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL TO WITHDRAW
THE NINE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND ON GOING ON THE
SIX MONTH LET'S HAVE. MISTER
AGUILAR FROM FINANCE ONCE YOU
GO AHEAD. REGULAR PART OF
FINANCE YEAH THAT MAYBE YOU
DON'T PROPOSE TO WITHDRAWAL THE
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH INCLUDES
FUNDING OR STAFFING AND ALSO
FUNDING FOR GRANTS- WE WILL
KNOW THAT THE STATE DOES REMAIN
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR TRANSITION
TO SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER USE
AND SO TO THAT END WE ARE.
PUSHING FORWARD SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS AT FIFTY EIGHT MONEY-
TO SUPPORT THE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS TO DEFRAY THEIR
COST OF STIGMA IMPLEMENTATION
OUTSIDE GONNA BE UP RECORDS
THAT THE BUDGET YEAR-
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT
RECOMMENDATION AND ALL WILL
NOTICE. OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
NOTWITHSTANDING YOU'RE NOT A
CRITICAL POSITION TO EXPAND
PROGRAMS AT THIS TIME GIVEN
THE- DRASTIC. BUDGET
ACCOMMODATION RECESSION. THE
AUDIO. MICHELLE THANK YOU MR
CHAIR HI AGAIN RACHEL IT WITH
THE I OUR CONCERN HERE AS NOTED
IN YOUR AGENDA IS JUST AROUND
THE STAFFING IN THE STATE
OPERATIONS EVEN THOUGH IN
JANUARY THIS WAS PORTRAYED AS
AN AUGMENTATION AND A GROWING
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND STAFF IN
FACT THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF
LIMITED TERM FUNDING THAT'S
ABOUT TO EXPIRE AND SO IF THIS
PROPOSAL AT LEAST PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSAL ISN'T PROPOSE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY'RE- MAKING
REDUCTIONS TO THEIR SICKNESS
STAFFING IN STING OPERATIONS AT
A TIME. THAT THIS STATE IS
REALLY RAMPING UP SOME OF THE
KEY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OR THE PARTNER
WILL NEED TO REVIEW PLANS AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO
I THINK OUR CONCERNS ARE JUST-
YOU KNOW WELL THEY WILL THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT
AND CAN WE EFFECTIVELY MEET
THIS IMPORTANT STATE PRIORITY
SO- YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING NOT ALL OF THE FUNDING
BUT- I THINK OUR OUR CONCERNS
ARE JUST. CAN WE ACHIEVE THIS
IMPORTANT STATE PRIORITY WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT WILL. BE IN A
POSITION OF MAKING A REDUCTION.
YEAH SHE- REPORT ARE. INDICATE
WE'VE ALREADY INVESTED EIGHTY
MILLION FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT
AND FOR THIS PREVIOUSLY IN THIS
IS WORK THAT. MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE OUR
CONCERN WITH. ANYBODY AT THE
DEPARTMENT. ONE COMMENT. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS TIRING
REPRESENTING A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF STATEWIDE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND- WE DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE THAT CHALLENGING
TIMES THAT WE'RE IN AND-
PRECIADO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE'S POSITION AND SUPPORT
THAT POSITION. WE AS THE
PERMANENT FINANCE MENTIONED WE
ARE COMMITTED TO MAINTAINING
OUR- ABILITY TO SUPPORT THAT
LOCAL GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT WE
WILL BE RE PRIORITIZING- ALL OF
OUR- KIND OF HURTS BUT TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS.
SUCCESSFUL IN MAINTAINING ITS
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
DEADLINES AND SO WE'LL BE
FOCUSING ON THAT- BUT REMAINING
COMMITTED TO LOCAL PROVIDING
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE AND THAT
LOCAL ASSISTANCE I WILL NOT
WILL NOT BE STOPPING BUT WE
WILL BE NEEDING TO DO SIRI
PARTICIPATION. WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO- THAT'S A SEPARATE STATION
AS YOU KNOW I'VE PREVIOUSLY
COMMENT YOU'RE PRIORITIZING-
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
SAYING THAT THAT HAS TO BE
FUNDED BUT THEN WHEN YOU GET TO
THE GENERAL FUND. YOU'RE
REDUCING THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON THE MANAGEMENT OF THE BASIC
WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE ON
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT SO.
WE'RE THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
WE'RE DEALING WITH ALL THESE
DIFFICULT ISSUES ONE BY ONE-
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. OF THE
DEPARTMENT EARLIER WHEN THIS.
SINISTER AND QUICKLY VERY
QUICKLY YET THANK YOU I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE ON THE-
AGAIN CONCERNING SAME OVERALL
THEME- APPRECIATE THE REJECTION
THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE ON GOING
BUT- OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT WE
APPROPRIATE LAST YEAR HOW HOW
MUCH- IS ON TRACK TO GET
ALLOCATED TO THE GSA'S THIS
YEAR JUST ONE TRY TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW HOW MANY DOLLARS
WE'RE- PLANNING TO GET OUT THE
DOOR THIS YEAR UNDER LAST
YEAR'S DOLLARS. THIS RAISES ANY.
REV AS ANY. THANK YOU YES- THE
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION- WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE- ALLOCATE TWENTY
SIX MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS AND IT WILL NEED TO BE A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS FOR
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT-
REQUIREMENTS- BUT WE ANTICIPATE
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT AND GET THOSE AT TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS OUT TO
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASES
OUT BEFORE THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR. THIS UPCOMING
FISCAL YEAR. OKAY TO BE
CONTINUED THANK YOU LET'S MOVE
TO THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD THIS
IS. ISSUE NUMBER THREE FOUR
FOUR- WE HAVE A STAFF
RECOMMENDATION WE'RE TRYING TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING LAW
AND GET THE- RESOURCE BOARD TO
CONSIDER REGULATIONS TO IMPROVE
THE CAP AND TRADE WERE- YOU
KNOW WE'RE AN ADAPTIVE
COMMUNITY SO WE'VE ADDED
LANGUAGE ONTO THE WESTERN
CLIMATE INITIATIVE. DATA MARKET
REGISTRY DATABASE SO- FINANCE
YOU HAVE ANYTHING 212% OKAY THE
ACTING ADAMS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. A CLASS INCREMENTAL
INCREASES ONE POINT ONE MILLION
HOWEVER IT'S ONLY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR OUT AT THE COST OF MAKING
IMPLEMENTATION. HE'S OVER A
FIVE YEAR. FOR MEMBERSHIP
SERVICES INTO THE WESTERN
CLIMATE INITIATIVE. REQUEST
DOES INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THEIR
RESEARCH IS WORKING TO PROVIDE
ADVANCE PAYMENT I THINK 25% OF
THEIR QUARTERLY MEMBERSHIP
COSTS. INTO THE WESTERN CLAIM
THAT SHE- EARLIER DID YOU GET
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU WANT
ON THE I. T. R. SYSTEM IT WAS
HARD FOR ME TO HEAR. YEAH
MISTER OSTROM WITH L. L. AGAIN-
WE ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
KIND OF THE NEED FOR THE
PROJECT AND REQUESTED RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT KIND OF UPGRADE
AND DEVELOP A NEW SYSTEM I
THINK OUR MAIN ISSUE THAT WE
WANTED TO FLAG WAS JUST ONE OF.
OVERSIGHT THIS IS A BIT OF AN
UNUSUAL SITUATION WHERE THE
REQUEST IS BEING MADE BY THE
AIRPORT THE NEW- FOR SIGNS FOR
THE NEW I. T. PROJECTS BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY BEING DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED BY- THE WESTERN
CLIMATE INITIATIVE WHICH IS A
NONPROFIT ENTITY THAT.
ADMINISTERS THE AUCTIONS AND
SO. AS A RESULT IT DOESN'T GO
THROUGH THE NORMAL KIND OF
STATES- REVIEW PROCESS THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY IN
THE OVERSIGHT PROCESS THAT
PRESENTS I'M SO WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER SOME ADDITIONAL-
OVERSIGHT AND REPORTING YOUR
BUDGET NO LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE
UPDATES AS THE PROJECT MOVES
ALONG AND ANY CHANGES THAT
MIGHT OCCUR ALONG THE WAY. YEAH
SO I'M I'M I'M WITH YOU TRYING
TO- YOU KNOW IMPROVED THE
SUPPORT FOR THE CAP AND TRADE%
PROGRAM IN AND WORKING WITH THE
AIRPORT IN AND GIVING THAT
OVERSIGHT- SO THAT WE KNOW HOW
THIS- DATABASES. ARE BEING USED
OUR- ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ON THAT. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX CENTER STERN HAS ASKED THAT
WE REMOVE ITEM SIX CENTERS
DURING YOUR RECOGNIZE THIS IS
THE- FORMALLY DOUGHERTY CAL
GM'S- WITHDRAWAL OF A HUNDRED
TWENTY POSITIONS AND- BASED
OVER THREE YEARS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE ANYONE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO WHO CAN
COMMENT BUT- JUST TRYING TO GET
A SENSE AFTER WE SPENT A FAIR
AMOUNT OF EFFORT LAST YEAR-
REFORMING. DOGGER AND
CONVERTING IT INTO CAL JAM AND-
THE SORT OF JOINT EFFORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN OCCURRING AROUND.
DEALING WITH ARE IDLED- AN
ORPHAN WELL PROGRAM AND OTHER
SORT OF CRITICAL INSPECTIONS TO
REBUILD TRUST BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC AND- THE OIL SECTOR- HOW
DO YOU PLAN TO DO MORE WITH
WITH LESS. AND WHAT WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE FALLING OUT FROM.
FROM THIS SAT ABANDONED
AUGMENTATION. FINANCER SORRY
FROM CAL JAM ONE AT TAKE THAT.
THIS OUR FINANCIAL THIS COUPLE
WORDS IN A LIFE PARTNER
CONSERVATION LAND THAT I THINK
WHAT WE'RE DOING AT THIS POINT
IS WORTH IT YOU KNOW IMPACT
THAT. HAD ON THIS ISSUE A LOT
OF INDUSTRIES BUT THIS IS YEARS
WELL AT SOME OF THE WORKLOAD
THAT WAS ANTICIPATED IN CALCIUM
PCP. NEEDS TO BE RE EVALUATED-
AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO COME ALSO THAT
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE GOING FORWARD- THAT'S
REALLY FRAMEWORK AND WITHDRAWAL.
L. TALK A BIT MORE.
CONSERVATION MORE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
WHAT THEY HAVE NOW TO CONTINUE
THE GREAT WORK. I WILL FOLLOW
UP WITH THAT- SENATOR DESERVE
BETTER FROM THE PART OF
CONSERVATION I CAN. ADD A
LITTLE BIT TO IT MR MANSON SAID
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
SO CAL GEMS IS REMAINING
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON-
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THE ENVIRONMENT-
THESE POSITIONS WERE ADDED. TO
THE EXISTING REFORM EFFORTS
THAT WERE TAKING PLACE- PRIOR
TO THE- THESE AUGMENTATIONS.
AND WE JUST THINK WITH THE-
EXTREME ECONOMIC CHALLENGES-
THEY'RE TAKING PLACE ACROSS
MANY SECTORS OF THE STATE.
INCLUDING THEIR OWN GAS
INDUSTRY WOULD HAVEBEEN A
DIFFICULT CHALLENGE TO ADD
THESE. ADDITIONAL FEES TO THAT
MIX OF CHALLENGES- SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
OUR I WILL PROGRAMS AND-
RENEWING- WORKING ON IMPROVING
INSPECTIONS AND TESTING. WITH
INNOVATIVE NEW WAYS OF DOING IT
INCLUDING THE USE OF-
WITNESSING THROUGH VIDEO
TESTING- USING DRONES FOR
INSPECTION- AND THEN WE'VE ALSO
DONE A LOT OF WORK RECENTLY.
EXPANDING FUNDING THIS BENEFIT
IS AVAILABLE FOR DESSERT. AND
WELLS AS- IS OPERATOR DESSERT
THEY OR ARE AT RISK OF DESERT
THEIR THEIR WELLS SO I CAN
EXPAND ON THAT IF THERE'S
FOLLOW UPS BUT- MY ONLY
QUESTION WAS ON HIS SIDE I
GUESS THE QUESTION WASN'T
WASN'T THAT THIS. PACKAGE OF
LEGISLATION WAS ALSO INCLUDED
SOME LIMITATION OF THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL LIABILITY SO THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME SAVINGS IF WE
IF WE- IMPLEMENTED AT THAT THAT
WE WOULD BE LESS LIABLE FOR-
YOU KOW. SPILLS ARE EMISSIONS
AT THINGS LIKE THAT SO- STILL
GOOD IDEAS PUT ON. THEY HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON I GUESS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. YEAH YOUR CHAIR IF I
COULD INDULGE JUST NUMBERS ON
HOW MANY WELLS WE EITHER INTEND
NOT TO INSPECT NOW WITH THIS
AVOIDED AUGMENTATION I WANT TO
GET A SENSE OF THE GAP THAT
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE FACING I
APPRECIATE NOW THE DRONE
INSPECTION SOME OF THOSE IDEAS
BUT JUST GETTING THAT BACK FROM
CAL JAM WOULD BE. WOULD BE
IDEAL AND WE'LL WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL TAKE THAT VOTE SEPARATELY
THUNDERSTORMS WILL BE STAYING
OFF OF IT THANK YOU. AND THEN
WE'LL- MITI CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
THE REQUEST FOR THAT SO THANK
YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING THE- ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION WE'VE REACHED THEM.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE- NOT TO
CALL IN NOW PLEASE DIAL TOLL
FREE NUMBER ONE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR
FOUR ONE. THEN WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THE CODE ACCESS
CODE. 959-927-2759 NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. OKAY NOW LET'S BEGIN THE
PUBLIC. COMMENT PERIOD- AGAIN
WORRIED. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ANY ITEM TODAY'S
PART A PART B. VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR TO CATCH. I INSERT
DISCUSSION. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. BEGIN TO LINE UP HERE
WE HAVE ONE MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC- PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND THE ISSUE AND-
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS GIVEN
THE TECHNICAL CONSIDERATIONS
EVERYTHING WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT
EVERYBODY TO ONE MINUTE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT THAT'S NOT
OUR CUSTOMS IN SEPT TWO BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE STUCK HERE SO
SENATE GALLERY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF RIGHT IF CLIENTS
TODAY- MANY OF THEM WANT TO
APPROACH THAT POSE THE H. C. F.
CUT- OTHERS WILL SPEAK ON THAT
SO WE'LL SKIP TO THE NEXT ITEM-
SEVERAL THE WATER DISTRICTS I
WORK WITH GRASS AND WATER JUST
REPAIR CENTER GEISHA DISTRICT
OPPOSED THE SIGMA CUTS
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
TODAY BUT- WANT YOU TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS A
LARGE LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION PHASE. IS
MOVING FORWARD ADDITIONALLY WE
REMAIN CONCERNED THAT- D. W. R.
NEEDS THE APPROPRIATE STAFFING
IN ORDER TO OVERSEE THOSE
PROPOSED PLANS- FURTHER WITHIN
THE CITY OF W. BUDGET WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT PROPER NINE
ALLOCATIONS. SPECIFICALLY AS
THEY RELATE TO THE EQUITABLE
BALANCE AND DISTRICT
DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE
ALLOCATIONS BETWEEN PARKS AND
CDFW WE'VE CHATTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT
THIS- BUT IT'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE- THINGS THAT WE DO
SUPPORT IN THE BUDGET WE WANT
TO THANK- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FOR PROPOSING. THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD B. C.
P. THAT WOULD INVEST IN THE
WATER RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO- WE
WANT OUR SUPPORT PROPOSALS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WITH THEIR OCEAN
RESOURCES ENHANCEMENT HATCHERY
PROGRAM AND THE LAST ITEM. TO
SENATORS COMMENTS OR WE WOULD
ALL LIKE TO SUPPORT A BOND
MEASURE MOVING FORWARD BUT
CALIFORNIA FORWARD. ON THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL MANY OTHERS HAVE
APPLYING THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE NECESSARY TO GET OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR ECONOMY
MOVING AGAIN. BAY AREA COUNCIL
ESTIMATES THAT A BOND THAT
COULD CREATE BETWEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND JOBS. THESE
INVESTMENTS COULD FUND WATER
ENVIRONMENT ENERGY PROGRAMS AND
WE SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
MOVING THAT CONVERSATION
FORWARD THANK YOU- LET'S MOVE
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING IN IT.
THERE'S NO SPILLOVER ROOM THAT
SAID. IS THERE ANOTHER ANNEX
TONIGHT HERE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
OF THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS PLEASE
IDENTIFY THE ITEMS YOU'RE
COMMENTING ON. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY FOUR FIRST PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. GREAT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN LIKE
HOUSEKEEPING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CAN DELFINO ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE-
DEFENDERS OPPOSES THE NAVY VICE
PROPOSAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE THE OPERATION
BUDGET- TWO YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE IDENTIFIED THE
DEPARTMENT'S FISCAL AND
STAFFING PROBLEMS AND FUNDED A
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING EFFORT.
PROVIDED IMPORT INFORMATION
DEMONSTRATING THE DEPARTMENT IS
ALREADY OPERATING AT A DEFICIT
UNDER EVEN A GOOD BUDGET YEARS
YOU HAVE TO BE WITH ME ONLY ONE
THIRD OF ITS OVERALL MISSION
MANDATE AND MOST NOTABLY ONLY
25% OF ITS WORK IN THE
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION
PROGRAM. THE CUT THIRTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND EVEN IF THEY ARE TRIGGER
CUT FROM THE BIODIVERSITY
PROGRAM DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE
WHEN WE'RE EXPERIENCING ONGOING
BIODIVERSITY CRISIS AND WE NEED
THE DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE. OUR DECLINING WILDLIFE.
MOUNTAIN LION WELL MIGRATE
BIRDS. AND THEREFORE WE URGE
YOU TO READ THE- A TRIGGER A
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION REDUCTION BASELINE
GENERAL FUND. WE ALSO URGED THE
SENATE REJECTED SHIFTING FUNDS
FROM THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND- THE AGENCY UP TO THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THE H.
YET TRAILER THE LANGUAGE. OF
THIS WAS A DEAL AS YOU NOTED
LAST YEAR TO EXTEND THE H. F.
FOR TEN YEARS AND THERE'S NO
REASON TO UNDO THIS AGREEMENT.
THE ATF PROVIDES CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR HABITAT AND PUBLIC
ACCESS PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AT A TIME
WHEN THOSE COMMUNITIES NEED
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. FINALLY DEFENDER
STRONGLY PROPOSED AT THE PORT
THE PROPOSED APPROPRIATION
AFTER THE PHARMACY MANAGEMENT
PLAN AND NEW RIVER IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT IS ABOUT ONLY ITEM. ON
THE PROPOSED APPROPRIATION FOR
THE BAY DELTA BIOLOGICAL
OPINION THANK YOU. ABOUT ONLY
ITEM THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERN
NECKS. MIX WITNESS. NEXT IS
LINE FOR FOUR PLEASE GO OR IF
YOU THIRTY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WE WILL RETURN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE SPECIALLY OPPOSED THE
TRAILER THAT LANGUAGE WITH THE
HUGE THREE TWENTY FIVE AN
AGENDA B. WHICH WOULD ALTER
HE'D GIVE HER CREDIT YET YOU
WITHOUT REQUIRING STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCY THE DEPARTMENT. WE
HAVE A COLLECTION OF WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING DAILY. I YEAH. THAT
IS PART WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO
GET THERE IF YOU COULD GET THE
LOOK AT IT OUTGOING FEEDING YOU
CAN EAT YET HE ALLEGEDLY
DIRECTED TO THE NEW CAR MARKET
EVALUATED. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE STRUCTURAL. HONESTLY THANK
THAT'S PRETTY QUICKLY THAT THIS.
YEAH I MEAN NECESSARY IS BE
DONE THAT ACTUALLY STRUCK OVER.
WELL ALL THE RESPECT WE TO THE
COURT IN ADDITION THREE THIRTY
FOUR IN AGENDA BE THAT RECORD
THEY'LL- TO RE OPEN AIRY BOARD
WILL MAKING ENTRY INTO THE
LANGUAGE OF THAT WOULD WAIVE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT WHICH WILL. MAKE THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. NOTICING
COMMENT ON THE MICHIGAN LAW
REVIEW RELATED PROCEDURES WERE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED. BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROTECT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER.
YOU CAN GAUGE ENQUIRING
LEGISLATIVE PROCEDURE AND
DELEGATED TO THE EIGHTY FIVE
THE LEGISLATURE. WE THINK THAT
COMPACTION IS NOT APPROPRIATE
AND THREATEN THE CREDIBILITY
RELIABILITY AND THE BIPARTISAN
REGROUP ALL OUR LANDMARK.
MARKET BASED CARBON EMISSIONS
PROGRAM AS WELL AS OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL MAKING GENERAL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR THE NEXT WITNESS.
SIX FOOT LINED SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE RED CROSS ROOM AT
THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT- AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF AGENDA ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. DO YOU SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY BOARD FORTY PST. THE
FUNDING DEFICIT AT THE AGENCY
HAS BEEN A SLOW MOVING
EMERGENCY. WHAT WE KNEW WAS
COMING IS NOW HERE AND WE
CANNOT KICK THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD YOU LONGER. SPEAK IF YOU
NEED TO BE FULLY FUNDED IN
ORDER TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AT MOST
RISK LOESCHER. HOWEVER FINDING
THE DEPARTMENT AT THE MEDICAL
LOVELL WOULD NOT PROFICIENT
BECAUSE OF THE FIGHTING BROKE
OUT DID YOUR FREE PROGRAM IN
THE FORM. IF YOU IF YOU HAVE
BEEN COLLISION. OF PART OF ITS
MISSION AND YET MINISTRATION
HAVE FADED OUT OF MANY OF THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
POTENTIALLY CONTAMINATED.
AWAITING CHARACTERIZATION.
DESPITE THE ROUGH ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
SET THE STAGE NOW WHERE LARGER
STRUCTURAL CHANGES. ALL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF COUPLED WITH
BETTER OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
THE FUNDS ARE USED EFFECTIVELY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY BOARD
BY FAITH. THROUGH THE CRACK
NEED IF YOU WERE BORN IN OTHER
MAJOR GEOGRAPHICAL REDUCING
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND ENSURING
THAT THE FOCAL EXCELLENT THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WITNESSES LINE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA- WE REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED PTSD STRESS SCHOOL
REFORM PROPOSAL WHICH IS ISSUE
THREE TWENTY FIVE AND PART B.
OF YOUR GENDER OR STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY THE DTS YOU TO
AFRICA TO MANAGE HAZARDOUS
WASTE AND UNDERTAKEN OVERSEE
CLEANUP OF CONTAMINATED SITES
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE DPS THE
PATIENTS IT COULD NEVER CAPTURE
PROBATIVE DEFICIT. AT THE SAME
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALSO PAY
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL STRAINS
RIGHT NOW AS A RESULT OF CODE
NINETEEN ANOTHER NEW STATE
PROGRAMS WE SHOULD THIS
PROPOSAL WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DISPOSE OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE INTO ADMINISTER
EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR
COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT OF
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
USED OIL. WE HOPE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
TEETH THAT NEED TO CREATE A
BETTER PROPOSAL TO AVOID
JEOPARDIZING OUR LOCAL PROGRAMS
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
ALIGN KELP RESIDUAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION WITH THESE COMMENTS
ON ANOTHER HAPPIER NOTE- ITEM
ONE TWENTY SIX I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
MAINTENANCE OF GENERAL FUND
BOND FUNDING FOR THE NEW RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS. THIS IS A
LONG STANDING LEGACY OF CROSS
BORDER CONTAMINATION THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY VERY GOOD MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THAT ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER THREE TWENTY FIVE
FOR A T. T. S. C. FOR THE TRUCK
BUT THE TRAILER BILL IS. TO
DEFER WITHOUT PREJUDICE SO WILL.
K. THIS AN- JULY NEXT. PLEASE
CHECK YOUR CEMEX WITNESS NEXT.
NEXT DEADLINE SET GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
PROTECTED OFF ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY AND
NATIONAL MULTI TECHNOLOGY
EXPECTATIONS. HE W. SOLID
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOUR APP ON
SOLID STATE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM BECAUSE OUR MAIN
CONCERN THAT THESE PROGRAMS
WILL BE SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED OR
CUT DATA PRIORITIES LAID OUT
AND THEN THE REVISED WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH
THE GOVERNMENT OFFICE ON
DEVELOPING A FRIENDLY PLACE AND
I'LL KEEP THESE PROGRAMS AND
TAX. AS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRITIC
REVIEWS ON INVESTING IN YOUR
OWN MISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE EVEN
MORE PARTICULARLY BEATING BRET
MILLBURN APPROACH NEEDS AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND YOU
KNOW EXACTLY THINKING
TRANSPORTATION ARE ALSO
IMPACTED THINK ECONOMIC
RECOVERY BY THE LEADING LOCAL
ECONOMY AND GROWING QUALITY
JOBS. FOR ECONOMIC RELIEF IN
MOST DEMAND WE DO SUPPORT THE
FIFTEEN MILLION RE
APPROPRIATION TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION FOR EASY
INFRASTRUCTURE AT HER BEST IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I ONLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
RETAIN THE COMPUTER FOR CLONING
IT DECISION ON DRF INVESTMENTS
UNTIL THE TIMER TO THINK
THROUGH AND BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES. ON TO EUROPE. ON
WE BELIEVE THAT MAKE MORE SENSE.
TO GET A LOT. TO TIME TO TAKE
THE FULL PAY OF OPTION WITH.
ENSURE THAT OUTCOME IN. POLICY
DIRECTIVE. PUBLIC HEALTH AN
ECONOMIC RE YOU LOOK TO WORKING
ELECTED. AND THEN. TO NAVIGATE
THE- TIMES AND IN LIVING DATA.
ARE SPENT WISELY MAXIMUM IMPACT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIKE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO
YOU HAVE YOUR PHONE MUTED. WELL
NOT TO THE NEXUS LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PETER
LIKE ASKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS WAYNE NASRI EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
FIRST WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE
PRIVATIZATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. IN EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION INCENTIVE FUNDING
FOR THEIR DISTRICTS IN THE
MAYBE BY. HOWEVER WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK
OF EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING. YOU
HAVE TO TRADE AUCTION PROCEEDS
WILL LIKELY NOT ENOUGH TO ALLOW
FUNDING FOR THE BUDGET
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THAT WAS
GIVEN SECOND PRIORITY IN SORRY
IN THE BUDGET. WITHOUT THIS
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING WORK BY
THE DISTRICT WITH COMMUNITIES
TO CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW OR STOP ALL
TOGETHER. THE MATIC IF THAT'S
THE PRE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
GIVEN FINDING THAT EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION COMBINED WITH
COVERED NINETEEN MAY RESULT IN
INCREASED AT AN EXACERBATE
HEALTH IMPACTS. FIFTY MILLION
AND IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IT'S
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT THE
HEALTH COMMUNITY IS PROTECTED.
WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY DISTRICT
pBE GIVEN THE SAME LEVEL OF
PRIORITY AS CARD IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING. AND WE OBJECT TO THE
DIVERSION OF AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND MONIES FOR NON AIR
QUALITY PURPOSES. THIS WAS THE
START THEN FERMENTATION FUNDING
LAST YEAR AND SHOULD BE AGAIN
SO THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
SENATORS AND HAVE A GREAT DAY
THANK YOU MODERATE NEXT NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT IN LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
IN TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE I URGE YOU TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR ISSUE
SEVENTY IDENTIFIED IN TODAY'S
AGENDA PART A ADD STATUTORY
RELIEF FOR TRANSIT OPERATORS.
THESE RELIEF MEASURES ARE
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO TRADE
AGENCY STATEWIDE AT THE GRAPPLE
WITH THE FINANCIAL AND
OPERATIONAL IMPACT THE COMPANY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT'S AN ACT
IN THE STATUTORY RELIEF
MEASURES WOULD PROTECT TRANSIT
FUNDING ENSURE THAT TRANSLATES
INTO THEY'RE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE LIFELINE TRANSIT
SERVICE. TO COMMUNITY THAT
CONTROL WORKERS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE WE THINK YOU YOUR STAFF
AND- BELL AND PROGRAMMATIC AND
RECOGNIZING THE NEED OF TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND FOR CONSIDERING
THE INCLUSION THE STATUTORY
RELIEF MEASURE IN THE SENATE
BUT YOU'VE CROSSED. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE COURT
THERE INCLUSION A GYM BUDGET I
WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WITH
YOU ALL ADDITIONAL MEASURES
INCLUDING FINDING THAT WOULD BE
AFTER THE FOR THE FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE GOT PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE
ON THAT. NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR.
WITH IS NOW SIX. PLEASE CALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THAT KATIE BROWN COLOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE WHICH WE
ESTIMATE A FULL BOTTLE OF WATER
ON THE FIFTEENTH BUT NICK
INTEREST THE TRAIN I WILL FOCUS
ON OPPOSITION TO THE CAT THE
PROPOSED CALCIUM CONDITION
ANYTHING I AM EXPERT ELEVEN THE
TECHNICIAN BACK FULLY FUNDED BY
INDUSTRY RESULTS IN NO
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL I'M
THINKING. AN ACCEPTABLE
CONTINUE WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS SECONDLY I WILL SAY
THAT WHILE JUNIOR I HAD BEEN
TRANSFERRED WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER CONTINGENCY PLAN TO
KEEP THE PROMISE OF CLEAN AIR
AND CLEAN WATER NOT JUST AN
EIGHTY F. B. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX POINT BETTER THAN
OTHER IMPORTANT I CALLED AND
PROGRAMS AS WELL. AND
SPECIFICALLY ON WHAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALIGN
BUSINESS AND JOBS RECOVERY WITH
OUR CRIMINAL CALLED REFERENCING
BACK TO SENATOR STERN COMMENT
ABOUT A POTENTIAL BARN I JUST
RECOVERY WILL ONLY BE POSSIBLE
IF YOU HAVE AN ERROR IN WHETHER
IT'S FROM A BOND ANOTHER SOURCE
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO EXPLORE THOSE
OPTIONS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
MODERATE NEXT WITNESS. THANK
DEADLINE SHE'S TWO PLEASE CALL.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS YOUR
NUMBER THIS IS MICHAEL TURNER
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE SUPPORT THE POLICY
REFORMS THAT ARE PROPOSED BY
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION THAT ARE AN ITEM
SEVEN BE A PART OF YOUR AGENDA.
AND WITH RESPECT TO PARK THE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY ONE TO ONE
THIRTY SEVEN- WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CARDS CLEAN FUEL- PROGRAMS FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION PLEASE OUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA OUR
CONTINUED CONTINUING TO THINK
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OFTEN REVENUE-
MET LA METRO CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO ESSENTIAL
WORKERS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MAY CONTINUE TO OPERATE. A
TRAIN SERVICE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE REALLY NO OTHER WAY OF
GETTING AROUND- WE'RE CURRENTLY
PROJECTING A DEFICIT OF ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR AND WE'D
LIKE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE WITH THE COMMITMENT TO
FUND PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE IT'S
VITAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
WE KNOW THAT OUR INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL HELP
REINVIGORATE THE ECONOMY
PROVIDING JOBS THAT MOBILITY
ACCESS TO IMPROVEMENT- FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD THANK.
YOU MODERATOR NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
NECKLINE IS SIXTY. PLEASE CALL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS THE
BEST ALONSO ON BEHALF OF WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA SPEAKING TODAY
ON THE WATER RESILIENCE BCP
WATER REUSE APPRECIATE THE
REFERENCES TO EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN
FOUR BUT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR AN EXPERT PANEL ON DIRECT
POTABLE REUSE THROUGH WALL
WHILE WHILE WATER AUGMENTATION
AND TREATED DRINKING WATER
AUGMENTATION. AS OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S WATER RESILIENCE
PORTFOLIO THIS PANEL AND THE
SUBSEQUENT ADOPTION OF UNIFORM
CRITERIA IS THE ONLY THING
HOLDING BACK WATER AGE ISSUE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FERMENTUM
IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS THAT WILL
HELP MAKE REGIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA MORE WATER
RESILIENCE. RECOMMENDATION FOUR
POINT TWO OF THE PORTFOLIO
SPECIFICALLY CALLED FOR THE
COMPLETION OF THE WRECK
REGULATION AND WATER REUSE
URGES THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS RECOMMENDATION WITH THE
NEEDED FUNDING THANK. YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT. NEXUS LINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
KERRY MEMBERS WILL BE A
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY ONE ONE THIRTY TWO AND
ONE THIRTY SIX A PARTY AT THE
AGENDA TODAY THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FAITH IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE COUNTRY. THE
VALLEY IS HOME TO TWENTY OF THE
THIRTY MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE FOR
THESE REASONS WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PRIORITIZED
YOU ARE EXPENDING FOR CLEAN ADD
PEOPLE EQUIPMENT THROUGH THE
FARMER PROGRAM AND WE URGE THAT
THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM BE
MAINTAINED AT FIFTY MILLION AND
INCREASED THE FEASIBLE THE
DISTRICT ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED FUNDING OF THE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM. I WANTED
TO PROVIDE THE BUDGET PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR INCENTIVES WE ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE TO ALSO PRIORITIZE
FIFTY MILLION IN IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING SO WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO CARRY
OUT THESE MUCH NEEDED AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EX MODERATOR. NEXT
IS FOR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHAW WITH SHAW YOUR INTUITION
ALTERING LAND WE WANT TO
ASSOCIATE OUR REMARKS WITH
THOSE OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION'S MICHAEL PIMENTEL
ON THE PARTY AGENDA ISSUE
SEVENTY FOUR SEVERAL OF OUR
TRANSIT AGENCY CLIENTS
INCLUDING. THE SENATORS
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
SANTA MONICA'S BIG BLUE BUS THE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
THANK YOU MR CHAIR YOUR STAFF
APPROACHED HIM STAFFS IN REBEL
AND HIS STAFF AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM FOR MONTHS ON
THIS LANGUAGE CREATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR. IS
LYING SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT YOU WANT ON IT ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHORITY- WE
AREN'T FROM SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
THAN THE THOUGHT WOULD BE AS
OUTLINED IN- PART B. ITEM ONE
TWENTY SECOND TO SIXTY FIVE BE
BUT WILL PROVIDE DESPERATELY
NEEDED RESOURCES TO A DRINK THE
TOTAL ADDRESS THE DANGEROUS
LEVELS OF POLLUTION IN THE NEW
RIVER WHAT JUST LAST MONTH
PEOPLE CORE FORM WAS. FOUND AT
LEVELS F SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
TIMES THE FEDERAL LIMIT IN
ADDITION THE DOLLARS WILL
ENABLE THE NORTHERN STATE OF
THE PERIMETER MAKE OUTLINED IN
THE PUBLIC THE MANAGEMENT PLAN
AND ECONOMIC GAME CHANGER FOR
THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
WHEN JOB CREATION WILL BE
DESPERATELY NEED IT WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT THE
BUYER BUT IN MANY RESPECTS BUT
THE PUBLIC THE HAD BEEN DIRE
FROM TWO DECADES AND NOW IS NOT
THE TIME TO. UNDERFUND OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO THE REGION WE
ARE A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
GOVERNOR- INVESTMENT IN ORDER
TO DO FOR HIM AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEW
INVESTMENT MEMBER SO- MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. HIS LINES. FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T FEEL
THE BARLOW WITH THE OF THE
AFTER THE HELP COUNCIL BAYERN
ACCOUNT BALANCE WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE ISSUE- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ISSUE THREE
FORTY FOUR- IT IS OUR SURGEON
THAT WE UNDERWENT A COMPLETE
INEXPENSIVE WILL MAKING ON THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM THAT'S
WIDELY REJECTED MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE STAFF IS
RECOMMENDING AT THIS TIME I.
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE EIGHT THE
EXEMPTION APPROPRIATE AND
UNNECESSARY TO CHANGE A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IN THIS TIME OF
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY THAT
DEALING WITH- FOR PRICING AND
DURING A STRUGGLING ECONOMY
WILL RESULT IN BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA IN FACT WE BELIEVE
THE SUBSTANTIALLY IMPACT.
RATEPAYERS FROM CALIFORNIA THE
WHOLE. THAT REASON. WE QUADRIGA
OF THIS APPLICANT NATION WHAT
WE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE- I.
T. INFRASTRUCTURE. THE CHAIR
PRESHEAF YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
LINE SIXTY SIX GO AHEAD.
SECRETARY SENATOR THIS IT MIGHT
TAKE BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
COMMITTEE DOCUMENTATION ISSUE
THREE FORTY FOUR WHICH REQUIRES
CART TO CONDUCT A RULEMAKING ON
CAP AND TRADE BUT AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE RECOMMENDATION AS IT
INTERFERES WITH THE MARKET AT A
TIME WHEN IT IS ALREADY IN THE
CITY. AND AS WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF AN ECONOMIC CRISIS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING IT THE
EPA EXEMPTION UNDERMINES ANY
THOUGHTFUL AND MEANINGFUL
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REFORM
PROPOSAL ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC AND CONTROL. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE ISSUE IN EIGHTY NINE NINETY
FIVE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM TO TEACH TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIVENESS FROM THAT
APARTMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NECKS WITNESS MODERATOR. IT'S
LIKE SIXTY NINE PLEASE AHEAD.
MR SHARON MEMBERS TELLING ON OF
THE CALIPH AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIZATION OF TEACHER
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR THE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
ARE PROTECTION PROGRAM AND FOR
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
UPGRADES AND REPLACEMENT.
HOWEVER WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
THERE WILL BE LITTLE TO NO
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM. INCENTIVES. AND
IMPLEMENTATION GO HAND IN HAND.
PROFICIENTLY WORK BEING DONE BY
COMMUNITIES- DISTRICTS. TO
CLEAN UP AIR POLLUTION IN
COMMUNITIES WILL SLOW
DRAMATICALLY OR STOPPED
ALTOGETHER WE HAVE AN INPUT WE%
HAVE AN IMPLEMENTATION THE FUN
AT LAST YEAR'S AMOUNT OF FIFTY
MILLION. WELL SO MUCH LESS THAN
THE ACTUAL PROGRAM BECAUSE IT
WILL AT THE VERY LEAST HAPPEN
SURE THE WORK CONTINUES AND AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS ARE
REALIZED IN COMMUNITIES LASTLY
THE MAY REVISION DOES NOT
PRIORITIZE THE TWO MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
LOCAL AND DISTRICT DESCRIBED
FIRE GRANTS WELL THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS MODEST. INVESTMENT
PROVIDES MICHIGAN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY BENEFITS AND COST
SAVINGS BY HELPING PREVENT
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES. AND THE
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
GIVEN THE PRIORITY COMPANY FOR.
PREVENTION CATEGORY. PUSHED
FIRE GOING TO BE INCLUDED IN
THAT AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU BY MODERN NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
NEXUS LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M ALAN ABBAS WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT AND I'D LIKE TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SOUTH COAST CAPCO AND SAN
JOAQUIN- WE HAVE SUPPORT FOR
THE B. X. SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- WITHIN THE G. G. R.
AFTER HOWEVER WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION DOLLARS. IN
INDIA PAYS YOU GO- PLAN WHICH
MEANS THAT IMPLEMENTATION LIKE
WE WOULD NOT BE FUNDED OUT OF
THE G. G. R. AFTER.
IMPLEMENTATION FUND FOR SIX
SEVENTEEN OR USE FIRE DISTRICT
PROVIDES SUPPORT TO COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY AIR POLLUTION.
AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN RECENTLY
THAT A LOT OF THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT SUFFER FROM UP MOSTLY FROM
AIR POLLUTION ALSO HAVE A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD OF- OF BOB BEING
INFECTED WITH THE COPAY
NINETEEN- IMPLEMENTATION WORK
INCLUDES ENHANCED MONITORING
AND MODELING EMISSION
REDUCTIONS PLANNED TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THOSE PLANS. IT'S
ALSO CONCERNING THAT IN THE
PAST THE MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDING FOR THIS IMPLEMENTATION
CAME FROM AIR. TO FIND NON AIR
QUALITY WORK. LASTED LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR- FOR
FUNDING THE WILDFIRE SMOKE
CLEAN AIR CENTERS PROGRAM THIS
WAS A MODEST AMOUNT IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR- BASED ON
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR.
AND IT WOULD BE A PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IN
MITIGATING THE IMPACTS OF
WILDFIRE SMOKE DURING
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR NICKEL NEXT
WITNESS. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RICO MONSTER
BUT NOT WITH THE TROUBLE PUBLIC
LAND URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ISSUE THREE FORTY THREE THE
AUGMENTATION TO THE LOCAL PARKS
AND COMMUNITY RIBOT
REVITALIZATION PROGRAM. THAT
PROGRAM COLLAPSED AROUND THE
GRANTS WITH OVERSUBSCRIBED 100%
WHICH MEANS A LOT OF GREAT
PROJECTS THAT ALREADY WENT
THROUGH EACH WEEK WE REVIEW AND
COMMUNITY PART TO THIS PATIENT
WERE REJECTED IF WE GET THAT
MONTH WE COULD GET THAT MONEY
OUT IN THE FALL PUT THE SHOVELS
IN THE GROUND PUT PEOPLE TO
WORK RIGHT AWAY. IF WE LOOK AT
SPECIFICALLY AT THOSE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED- ALSO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE REGARDING HCF.
TECHNICAL VACATION FUND IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING
SPECIES OR GOING TO AN EXPECTED
CLINCHING THE TEAM WORK- FUN
PROVIDE HABITAT RESTORATION-
MAINTAINS WILDLIFE CORRIDORS-
FISHERY ENHANCEMENT- WE REALLY
HAVE THE CHEAPEST MODEL THE MAN
OF MINING. AT W. C. B. TO DO
THOSE ACTIVITIES AND LASTLY I
JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
PLANET TO CONTINUE DOING THEIR
GREAT WORK ON A TWENTY TWENTY
CLIMATE RESILIENCE BOND-
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY I
HEARD TODAY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT ITEM IT'S
NOT- I'VE BEEN TOTALLY CLOSED.
AND A LOT OF GREAT WORK- IT'S
GOING ON INTO THAT I THINK WE
NEED THAT AS AN ECONOMIC
STIMULUS OBVIOUSLY THE CLIMATE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE ARE NOT GOING
AWAY AND THE ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO GET WORSE THANK YOU SHE GAVE
MY OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT IN LINE SEVEN
NINE GOING PLEASE HEARING
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ABOUT
HALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION FOUND.
THAT PLAN OF THIS AND THAT
CREATED THE HABITAT ON. FUND
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE TRAILER
BELL THAT WOULD SUNSET THE ATF
AND TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
BASELINE CUTS TO CDFW WHICH HAD
BEEN CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDING
CANNOT SUSTAIN A CUT OF THAT
MAGNITUDE WITHOUT DOING A
PREFERABLE HARM TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S WILDLIFE
PROTECTION EFFORTS- ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS. APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROPRIATE A
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE U. P.
LICENSE PLATE FINE TO MEDIUM
GRANT PROGRAM URGES YOU TO
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ALLOWING GRANT TO GO OUT AND
HOLD IT NINETEEN RECOVERY
SUPPORT. ALL FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS MUSEUM SCIENCE
CENTER AT THE STORE BECAUSE THE
FIGHTING BEGAN ACCORDING TO THE
KOREAN CLOSED DURING THE
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER WITH
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOST REVENUE. I NEED A
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY OR POLICE ISSUED A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE THE
FARM TO SCHOOL FUNDING THE
NEIGHBOR OR DORM EURO RELIEF
PROGRAM ONGOING INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP AND THE
FLIGHT NUMBER SAID TEACHER A
FEW CLEANING PROCESS. WE JUST
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER ALLOCATING
A MILLION DOLLARS ON AN
EMERGENCY WHEN I NEED TO HELP
SMALL AND MEDIUM SCALE FARMERS
SUCCESSFULLY PULL DOWN MUCH
NEEDED FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUNDING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. TEXAS LIKE EIGHTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL MASON WITH
FOR TRUST WE PREACH THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD WITH OUR
OWN HELLFIRE BUT AUGMENT. AND
DRAWING OUT THE BAD NEWS
STAFFING WILL ALSO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT GET THEIR PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
TARGETS- WE'RE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY REALIZE
WE ARE PRIORITIZING THE FOREST
HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM AS ONE OF
THE PRIORITY ITEMS IN THE G. G.
R. S. OUR OFFICE WILL SUPPORT
OF CAPITAL IS- REQUEST THAT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS HE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR. THEIR PRESCRIBED
FIRE GRAHAM PROGRAMS IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THESE TINGS UP
AND RUNNING I MEAN- AREAS OF
CONCERN THERE AROUND THE
PROFESSIONAL WILDLIFE- BUDGET
ITEMS AND ALSO HIT MYSELF WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION BOTH
OF WHICH WENT INTO MORE DETAIL
AROUND THE FOLLY OF THE SUN
SETTING THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. YOU HAD THIS
CONVERSATION LAST YEAR HAD A
DEAL ON THIS ISSUE AND IT'S
WILDLY OUT OF SCALE TO SUNSET-
TEN YEAR YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
THE CONSERVATION PUBLIC ACCESS
FUNDING OVER THE NEXT DECADE
THE ONCE YOU START LEVERAGING
OTHER FUNDS PROBABLY HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER TO
HELP PATCH- WHICH HOPEFULLY A
ONE OR TWO YEAR BUDGET
SHORTFALL. SO WE CAN REFER YOU
TO THE LETTER THAT WAS SIGNED
ONTO ALONG WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE ABOUT LINE FOUNDATION
AND URGE YOU TO REJECT BUT A
CHANGE OF POSTAL FOR- THEIR
STRUCTURAL CHANGES I'M SORRY
THEIR BUDGET CHANGES AS WELL AS
A CS THANK YOU EXCELLENT.
MODERATOR NETWORK NEXT WITNESS.
TEXAS ONE EIGHTY TWO AHEAD
PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
ANNUALLY WHICH I AND WHEN YOU
TODAY OF THIS OF LOS READ A
GREEN WHAT WAS THAT RECOMMEND
THERE SEVERAL ITEMS MOST OF
THEM ARE IN THE PART BE PART OF
THE AGENDA. EARNINGS GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION DOLLARS THAT
WOULD GO TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD- THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT THE FOR ACTION ON ITEM.
AT THIS TIME WE AGREE WITH
THAT- SCORE SO MUCH OF THIS
BUDGET- MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND OTHER BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN GENERAL BEING
ASKED TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW TO STRUCTURE A BUDGET
WITHOUT. THE BENEFIT OF ACTUAL.
RECEIPTS THE FIRM THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ON THE TIMELINE
FOR ADOPTING THE WORKLOAD LIKE
IT POSSIBLY TO AUGUST. WHEN AT
LEAST ALLOW MORE TIME FOR KNOX
AND PROCEEDS TO COME THROUGH.
AND WOULD MAKE. A MORE
INFORMED- THE BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISE HAS HUGE
CONSEQUENCES IT MIGHT BE A
PRACTICAL BUT THE STRATEGY BUT
THAT WAS THE DETAILS OF WHAT
GETS PRIORITIZED. WITH RESPECT
TO THE PAY AS YOU GO DECISIONS.
AND WE URGE THAT YOU HAVE. AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE
ABOUT AUCTION PROCEEDS ON WHAT
THE TREND LINE IS GOING TO BE
BEFORE YOU GO AHEAD. AND SET
UP. A PAGE YOUR GOAL
ARRANGEMENT. WE URGE YOU TO
DEFER ACTION ON THAT AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THE MODERATOR. NEXUS
LINE EIGHTY FOUR GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS
ELECTED TO HIRE ABOUT HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION SPECIAL
DISTRICTS MAINTAIN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY SERVICES
TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IF THEY
WOULDN'T BRONCO PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY CLIMAT
RESILIENCY BOND PROPOSAL
DISCUSSED IN PART BE UNDER
ISSUE THREE THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE FORTY ONE AND WHILE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN WE APPRECIATED IT
DISCUSSION AND COMMENT. THE
FINANCE AND CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
MOVE FORWARD IN CONSIDERING AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BONZO GOES ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCY WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF CODE
NINETEEN RESPONSE AND BELIEVE
THIS STUNNING WOULD BE WOULD
ALLOW SHOVEL. READY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. IT
LOOK WHAT. WHILE DANCING. COLD
AND CREATING RESULTS COMMUNITY
ACCOUNTS CAN YOU. IN THE DOCTOR.
ADDITIONALLY WE ECHO THE ALLEY
OF THE- ON ISSUE THREE FORTY
THREE REGARDING CHECK MY
FINDINGS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH THE NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR.
LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DON KHAKI WITH
MCCUE CALCULUS AS YOU'RE COMING
UP THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE. THE PROPERTY TO RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNANCE OF
THE SCHOOL REFORMS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL UNDER ITEM ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND THREE TWENTY FIVE. A
FEW SPECIFIC POINTS OF CONCERN
FIRST TO AVOID POLITICIZATION
OF ANY BOARD PROPOSED
APPOINTMENTS TO THE BOARD
SHOULD BE ASSISTING WITH MORE
SPECIFIC EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE ASSOCIATED WITH
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE
REMEDIATION AND CLEANUP AND
REGULATORY PERMITTING.
ADDITIONALLY THE CRITICAL
REFORM PROPOSAL COMPLEX
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES FEES
FOR MANY GENERATORS NUMBER
MATISSE. HIGHLY CONCERNED THAT
THESE CHANGES WILL RESULT IN
FURTHER DECLINE IN PERMITTED
FACILITIES SERVICE THE
DISINCENTIVES RECYCLING USED
OIL AND RESULT IN DIMINISHED
CAPACITY OVERALL FOR CALIFORNIA
TO MANAGE DON'T HAZARDOUS
WASTE. FOURTEEN GREATER
RELIANCE ON EXPORT HOUSES WHICH
OTHER STATES FINALLY E URGE
GREATER SPECIFICITY BE INCLUDED
TO ENSURE COMMITMENT TO THE
BOARD AND DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS
DUPLICATIVE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHER AGENCIES
TO. ESTABLISH METRICS FOR
IMPROVED ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY INTO PROGRAMMATIC
REFORMS TO REDUCE COSTS WHILE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU IT
HAS BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ASSEMBLY ON EIGHTY NINE NINETY
FIVE ON THESE ISSUES. I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
CURRENT NEWS ITEMS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TYPE PERSON A
QUESTION ON THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT LINE SIXTY EIGHT GO HEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE BALL AT THE
BOTTOM BITERS A COUPLE OF THAT
IS ON FIRST ON THEM I REMEMBER
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TRADE. THE
GOLD GATE BRIDGE DISTRICT NOT
MILITARISATION FORTY AND CAL
ACT I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT ARE
CRUCIAL FOR COLLUDING
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE ON THIS
ITEM WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON IT- AND IN ADDITION
ANOTHER ITEM NUMBER THREE FORTY
YEAH THE CALGARY TOGGLE LIGHTS
WE DO SHARE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY OTHERS ON THE
ELIMINATION OF THE HELP DESK
OFFICER PATIENT. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU. THE MODERN
NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS FIFTY EIGHT
GO AHEAD PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS LOUIS
BROWN CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA RESEARCH ALLIANCE
TENSION THE FORTY MINUTE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
WITH THE MINISTRATIONS CLOSING.
FOR THEIR NETWORK WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS ONLY DOES
NEED FOR STATE AGENCY FARES. AT
LEAVES OUT A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
COUNTY FAIRS THAT ARE HURTING
JUST AS WELL IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY THAT WE'RE
ENTERING FIRE SEASON. CAL FIRE
DOESN'T AFTER DISCOUNT EASTER
OR STATE AGENCY FAIR WHEN THEY
NEED THOSE PROPERTIES FOR BASE
CAMP SO WE ASK THAT THAT FORTY
MILLION BE UTILIZED TO BE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL PLAYERS. IN
THE NETWORK WE ALSO ASK THAT
THE EIGHTY FOURTEEN NINETY NINE
MONIES. THAT WERE IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET YOU'RE
REINSTATED THIS IS MONEY THAT
WAS GENERATED BY THE CURRENT
NETWORK AND IS. EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THESE DAYS AS ALL
SHARES LOST SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
THAT'S MONEY IS NECESSARY TO
KEEP THEM IN SURVIVAL MODE AT
LEAST FOR NEXT YEAR PROCEDURE
TIME TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. HIS LINE. EIGHT
GOING PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- BANKRUPTCY AND LET'S
MAKE CONTRABAND THROUGH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE A CAL STAR I
WOULD SUPPORT DELAYING ANY
DECISION MAKING RELATED TO THE
CAP AND TRADE SPECIAL PLANNING
TO HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE OF HOW
MUCH POPULAR AVENUES ARE
AVAILABLE WHAT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL SUPPORT MY COMMAND. I
SAID I CONSIDER THIS PLAN AND
ANY LARGER ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGE WHETHER THAT BE A BOND
YOU SHARE AT THE END OF THE
COMIC BOOK I RESPOND FOR THE
COMBINATIONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THERE BE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
BE INCLUDED OTHERWISE HARVESTED
A IN BUILDINGS AND SHE COULD
UNRAVELTRANSLATIONS OF THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES MASSIVE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. IT'S THE
BEST COMBINATION G. ISSUED
ACTION AND ECONOMIC PROVIDING
ONE DOLLAR PUBLIC INVESTMENT.
OVER JUST SIX DOLLARS AT THE
CAPITOL. ON BEHALF OF YOUR
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE IT. WE
LET THE WHITE HOUSE FOR THE ONE
NO DOLLARS THE DC CREATURE.
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE IT'S ONE
INCHES FANTASY. ALLAH TO THE OF
THE- THIS MONEY WILL BRIGHTEN
CARDS THE MILITANTS IN SRI
ESCORT CALIFORNIA STAY ON
TRACK. WITH OUR QUALITY GOALS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. I'M ONE PLEASE CALL
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND
COMMUNITIES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
THREE ITEMS VERY QUICKLY AND I
APOLOGISE NOW IF YOU HEAR MY
CHILDREN SCREAMING IN THE
BACKGROUND HI. WHAT I REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE CONSIDER ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FUNDING THAT IS
FOCUSED ON CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
I WANT TO ECHO SENATOR STERN'S
COMMENTS REGARDING NOT NATURAL
RESOURCES FUNDING AND UPON HIS
LEADERSHIP AND OTHER MEMBERS-
ON THIS COMMITTEE THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. OPKO
RECOGNIZES THAT HE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKED ON THEIR
PROPOSAL FOR A BOND THAT
BELIEVE THAT NOW MORE THAN EVER
THE STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
WATER RESILIENCE. AT THE NEED
TO CREATE JOBS AND STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON A PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL. WE
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL NIGHT IN THE COMING
WEEKS. REGARDING BOND
AGREEMENTS. THE CALPE A. B. B.
C. P. FOR LITIGATION WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RELATED TO
BIOLOGICAL OPINION. I JUST
REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO A VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT PROCESS DESPITE THEIR
PCP REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. FOR LITIGATION. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
OUR MEMBERS ARE REALLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING THAT
PROCESS WORK. I MEAN AND LASTLY
REGARDING SIGNUP FUNDING WE YOU
KNOW WE BELIEVE THE SIGNAL IS
REALLY A PRIORITY SCOTS WOMAN
PATIENT SIGMA. WELL I CONTINUE
TO ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
AND MINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING IS DEDICATED TO
SUCCESSFUL SEGMENTATION-
SPECIFICALLY THE NINE POINT SIX
MILLION TO ENSURE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES IS ADEQUATELY
STAFFED. TO PERFORM THEIR
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS. AS
MANDATED UNDER STATE LAW THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU MODERATE NEXT WITNESS.
NINETY SIX BECAUSE PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND A
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
THIS ENDEAVOR RESTOCK APOLLYON
THINKING ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY MY
COLLEAGUES EARLIER REGARDING
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN FUNDING IN
THE MAY REVISE BUDGET NOW WE
ARE INCREDIBLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S BEEN ALLOCATED TO
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PLAN
THE FUNDING FOR AIR DISTRICTS.
HOWEVER IT IS PROBLEMATIC IN
THE REVISED THE LACKING A B.
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING BUT I'VE BEEN GIVEN
SECOND PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET
UNFORTUNATELY CAP AND TRADE
AUCTION PROCEEDS WILL LIKELY.
WON'T BE ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING. AND
WITHOUT WE WERE BY OUR- CLEAN
UP LOCAL POLLUTION WILL BRING
UP ONLY SLOW OR STOP ALTOGETHER
AND ONLY GOING TO. GREAT BIG A
PROBLEM CONSIDERING THE ALREADY
EXISTING NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACT
OF EXPOSURE TO AIR POLLUTION
AND IN COMBINATION WITH THE
CURRENT. HEALTH CRISIS
REGARDING OPEN NINETEEN. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE MILLION DOLLAR
COMPENSATION FUNDING IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTED PARK IN UNITY. AND WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE SAME
PRIORITY LEVEL SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO YOU CARBONATION FUNDING AND
ARTISTIC IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING.
AND FINALLY- WE OPPOSE THE USE
OF AIR POLLUTION CONTROL TWENTY
DOLLARS FOR NON AIR QUALITY
PURPOSES. IT WILL BE PART OF
THE APPLICATION FUNDING LAST
YEAR AND WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD
BE USED- AGAIN THAT YEAR. THANK
YOU FOR COMING CONFEDERATION.
THANKS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
MODERATOR CAN YOU GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON HOW MANY MORE
MEMBERS. OF THE PUBLIC ARE
WAITING IN LINE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE APPROXIMATELY. FIFTY FIVE.
OKAY NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT. FIFTEEN GO AHEAD NOW
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LILLIAN MARTIN AND I AM
WITH THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY I'M CALLING TODAY ABOUT
AGENDA ITEMS AND NUMBER
THIRTEEN IN PART A OF THE
BUDGET AND WE SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE FOR FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS YOU KNOW TURNED
IT AND WE'RE LOCAL YOU'LL AND
YOU CALL TECHNOLOGY PLAN. FOR
YOUR EMISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED SUPPORT
HAVING AN AGENDA ITEM BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY. AND NOT TO
HURT YOU LATER DATE. THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE IN. PROJECT
COLLEAGUE IT. HAS HELPED PLAY
OVER FOUR THOUSAND. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATION. 40%
OF WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
END OF THE DANCE COMMUNITY IS.
THESE ARE CRUCIAL TO BOTH
THROUGH THE STATE AND NEEDING
FIFTY ONE MILLION YOUR MISSION
GET CALLED BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH IS CRITICAL I'M CREATING
CLEAN AIR AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HOW EASY IT IS CURRENTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND THEIR SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE
PIPELINE RIGHT IT FELT. THIS
YEAR THE FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS MADE AVAILABLE THIS
YEAR CALIFORNIA CONCERN THAT
ANYTHING COULD OCCASIONALLY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT AND-
OVER AGAIN WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR B. T. T. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AT
THE EARLIEST DATE POSSIBLE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU IN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT ARE
COMMENTING ON THAT THE ACTION
OF PROPOSED ACTION TO DEFER THE
M. CAP IN TRADE SPENDING PLAN
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE. A PLEASE
NOTE THAT WE WERE TRUSTING THE
SENATE ACTION IS TO ADDRESS THE
REVENUE SIDE AT NIGHT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE REVENUE DAYS IT'S
GREAT TO ADEVICE ALL TYPES OF
IT PRIORITIES AND IDEAS OF HOW
YOU WANT TO PLAN IF IT WORKS
THE INTENTION IS TO GIVE A
STABILISATION FOR THE REVENUE
SIDE A MODERATOR NEXT. WITNESS
NEXT DEADLINE TWENTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ON A LOT
OF ON THEM SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA TROUT AND CRAP
LIMITED FIRST FOR ETFS- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE PREPOSITION GET
INTO EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN
THAT'S PART OF THE OVERALL
CONVERSATION UNDER HERE AT.
WHICH WE KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE PLACE OVER THE SUMMER-
HOWEVER GIVEN THAT THE FUNDING
STREAMS- UNCERTAINTY WE DO
ENCOURAGE LET SOCIAL WORK ON
FINDING A- PERSONABLE FUN
SOURCE THAT CAN STILL MAINTAIN
BOTH IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
OVERALL PROGRAM MOUNTS- NEXT-
THEN WE SUPPORT PDF SUPPORTS
THE NINE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND COULD BE W. R. FOR
STAFFING TO MAKE STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS OF SICK MASTER HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY. ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER BC
FROM JANUARY- THE PROPOSED
SCRAPPING. FOR SOLVENCY. FROM
CROPS EIGHT IN THE MAY REVISION
C. P. ALSO. TO WITH PRODUCE IN
ADDITION TO THE NINETY EIGHT
MILLION IN THE JANUARY B. C. P.
FOR MULTI BENEFITS INCLUDING
THE PROJECTS- AND FINALLY
BURGER PREVIA. THE SUPPORT OF
THE TWENTY EIGHT MILLIONS FOR
THE NEWER PROJECT- AS AS BEEN
MENTIONED AS A CRITICAL PROJECT
THAT HAS BEEN- I PLAYED A LOT
OF THESE CONVERSATIONS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME LOCAL TO SEE
PROGRESS BEING MADE HERE- IN
THIS BDGET- LASTLY I JUST WANT
TO MENTION YOU KNOW ON THE
OVERALL QUESTION OF SUPPLANTING
DOLLARS YOU KNOW. WE'VE STATED
BEFORE THAT IT IS THE INTENT OF
THE VOTERS THAT PROP SIXTY NOT
BE UTILIZED AS PLANNED.
UNDERSTANDING THAT NEED. YEAH
CAN I WHICH OR IN. YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE MANY MANEUVERS THAT
WE'RE WITNESSING- POINT AND ADD
TO THE PARTS DEPARTMENT RIGHT
WHERE YOU SEE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THEM LAST YEAR FROM THE GENERAL
FUND BEING PULLED BACK. AND NOW
AND THEN HAVING TO REPURPOSE
PROP SIXTY DOLLARS FOR THE PART
FOR THOSE- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS. YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
IDEAL BY ANY LONG SHOT BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION AT
HAND. AND THEN FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA TRAVELING FROM
LIMITED WANTED TO MENTION TO
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THE GREEN
TAPE INITIATIVE THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED- UNDERSTANDING THAT-
CAL TROUT AND TRAVELING ALONG.
ALONG WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. A VERY EFFECTIVELY
ON DEVELOPING THAT PROGRAM IT'S
REALLY ABOUT. ENCOURAGING
EFFICIENCIES THAT WILL LEVERAGE
EXISTING DOLLARS DOWN THE LINE-
OR RESTORATION PROJECTS. NOT
ONLY IN THE NORTH COAST- ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO THE SOUTH COAST
ABOUT. REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
EARNED 8% POPULATIONS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY CONFINED- HAD A SHOT.
OF THINKING RIGHT- BELTING BACK
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK. YOU WOULDN'T NEXT
WITNESS MODERATOR. LINE FORTY
SEVEN AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO
CHAIRED MEMBERS CHRISTIAN VERA
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AJ
THINKERS BY IN THE COURT THE
MINISTERS IN CIRCLE USE
PROPOSITION SIXTY BOND FUND TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO STATE PARKS
AND URBAN AREAS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO PARKS THAT
SERVE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
REMOTING ACTIVATING BY
INCREASING ACTIVELY PARKS THAT
CRUCIAL PREVENTING TRYING TO
DETERMINE THE AGE I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE. THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF ALL
THANK YOU. X. MODERN. LINE
NINETY GOT PLEASE. THE MORNING
PERSON AGAIN ACTING IN CHAMBERS
STEPHEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
MARIN AGRICULTURAL LAND TRUST.
ORDER OF THE PRESERVATION OF
GPRS CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
FUNDING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE. ITS INSURANCE CRITICAL
FUNDING TO PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
STYLE PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE TO
CONSERVE AGRICULTURAL LAND.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND
TRUSTS ME TO CRAWL. AND
INTERESTS THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLAN
COALITION. BLANCHESTER SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND SOME PROVIDER
IN FRONT WE EXPRESS OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT ABOUT THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE CRIME FINDING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
EFFORTS TOWARD THE NEW FUNDING
SOURCE FOR ECONOMIC STIMULUS
ALSO INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR THE
MANY CONSERVATION PROGRAMS THAT
CREATE JOBS WELL IN TAKING
IMPORTANT. CHRONICLES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
MODERATOR. LINE TWENTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE SUBMITTED
A LETTER EARLY THIS WEEK WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IT JUST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT MAY
REVISE RIGHTLY RECOGNIZES THE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE THOSE HIT
HARDEST BY CODE NINETEEN BUT
THE BUDGET BUT TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN IT INVESTING IN
THE RECOVERY. ENDED UP NOT
CRITICAL STATE WELL I WOULD SAY
HI AND SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PRIVATIZE GIGI R. F. FINDING
FOR EIGHTY SIX POINT SEVEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER. AND WE
ALSO REQUEST PRIORITIZATION OF
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION AND
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES REGARDING SIGMA WE
AGREE WITH THE PROPOSAL TO
RESTORE NINE POINT SIX MILLION
FORGET D. W. R. STAFFING
HOWEVER FUNDING MUST BE USED.
TO PROTECT SOURCES OF DRINKING
WATER. WE AGREE WITH THE NEED
TO TAKE BROADBAND. THIS IS NOW
ONE OF THE ONLY FORMS AVAILABLE
FOR PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
GOVERNMENT AND ACCESS
EDUCATION. WE REQUEST INCREASED
INVESTMENT AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ADVANCES
ACTIVE IN ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION CLEAN ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. WE ALSO ALIGNED
WITH THE COMMENTS OF CRP ON
DUTY AT THE REFORM AND FINALLY
WE AGREE WITH SENATOR STERN
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
CANNOT BE VIEWED AS EXPENDABLE.
THANK YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND SURE AND YES
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THANK YOU-
NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR. EIGHT
POINT SIXTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
NUMBERS MARKED ON THE RECORD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS PROVIDED PREVIOUSLY BY
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
OTHERS. OPPOSE ANY BUDGET CUTS
TO OUR MEDICATION WILDLIFE AND
IN PARTICULARLY THE PROJECT AND
I HAVE A CAT CONSERVATION FUND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE NORMAL
WATER WHAT YOU'RE ALIGN
OURSELVES SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE PREVIOUSLY ON THE
WITHDRAWAL ON THE PROPOSAL FOR
CIGNA- BUT REALLY DO SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
MAINTAIN AT LEAST A NINE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR STAFF
AT B. W. R. RIGHT IT'S GOING TO
BE CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE.
TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE AND-
STAFFING LEVELS. ON GOING INTO
MY- AND CO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
LINE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER EIGHTY
NINE ON THE HAPLESS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. OUR MEMBERS ARE
ALREADY WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
AID THE STATE AND MEETING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOAL AND WE HAVE
CONCERNS AND OPPOSITION TO THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION AND ISSUE
THREE FORTY FOUR. ON THE CAP
AND TRADE. HM THE LEGISLATURE
DEBATED A CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND THIS ISSUE PUBLICLY AND HOW
IF YOU THREE NINETY EIGHT. AS A
RESULT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ABOUT THE PROGRAM THE PUBLIC
PROBLEMS WE HAVEN'T EVEN
STARTED ON THE PROGRAM WHICH
BEGAN IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOW ALREADY
PROPELLED ME CHANGE THAT
PROGRAM. THE STATE PARTNERS
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
MAKES THE BILITY TO CARRY OUT
THEIR LONG TERM PLAN TO MEET-EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS. THE
LEGISLATURE UNDER THREE NINETY
EIGHT CREATED THE ARE YOU NOT.
HEY MARKETS CURRENTLY STUDYING
THE VERY ISSUES- WHAT THEIR
DETERMINATION DUE OUT THIS
YEAR. THIS PROCESS WILL
CIRCUMVENT IT NOT CONTENT BYE
BYE CUSTOMARY NONSENSE AND THE
LEGISLATURE BY CREATING
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT ANY ANALOGY
FOR DEBATE. AND WHAT'S THAT HOW
CAN YOU BYPASSING ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS. BY EXEMPTING IT FROM
THE APA WHEN YOU'RE ALREADY
PROPOSING TO INCREASE COSTS FOR
ENERGY FOR EVERYONE IN THE
STATE ACCORDING TO QUALITY OF.
TRANSPORTATION AND RESTAURANTS
ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS AS
WELLAS THE STATE. PERSONAL
INCREASE RATES FOR ENERGY FOR
CALIFORNIA WHEN ARE YOU PICKING
THE CREDIBILITY CRISIS THANK
YOU I THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
THE SET ACTION IS GOING TO BE
TAKING IS THE AIRPORT DOESN'T
HAVE TO CHANGE THE PROGRAM PUT
THE AIRPORT HAS TO IS THE
REQUIREMENT. THAT THEY CONSIDER
WILL MAKE AND THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND GET THE INPUT FOLKS
IF WHAT THEY'RE DOING ALL GRAY.
AND THEY GET THE- OF MY THEN
THAN L. THE WITNESSES THAT HERE
CAN GO DOWN TO THE BOY. TEST
YOUR A REAL MY- ALL RIGHT.
MODERATOR NOW. WITNESS IT. LINE
FIFTY PLEASE CALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK CASKEY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
RICKY THOMPSON WITH THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING THE FOCUS AS
THEY CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
RELATED TO THE CAP AND TRADE-
BUT THAT METROPOLITAN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AT THE
LEGISLATURE IN INSTRUCTION
CONTINUE CONSIDERATION AS HOUSE
REPORTING SAFE AND HABITABLE
CHECKING WATER AS I STATE MY
PRIORITY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS LINE
TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THIS IS CATHERINE PHILLIPS OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA- FIRST
WE AGREE WITH AND WOULD LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THE
FOLLOWING THE WITNESS WHO SPOKE
IN FAVOR OF FUNDING FOR SOME
THE MANAGEMENT K. BALANCE WAY
LOOK FOR COMMENTS FOR SAY HI IN
FAVOR OF THE CAL GRANT FUNDING
AND WE STRONGLY REJECTED
MINISTRATIONS JUSTIFICATION FOR
ABANDONING THAT FUNDING. CAN
DELFINO AND JENNIFER FEARING
COMMENTS SUPPORTING RETAINING
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
IS APPROVED BY VOTERS IN PROP
ONE SEVENTEEN AND OPPOSING THE
DRAMATIC BUDGET CUTS TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND ALSO FOR THE
WITNESS WHO CALLED FOR
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR
INCENTIVES FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WE WOULD EMPHASIZE-
HEAVY DUTY BUT- HEAVY DUTY
TRUCK AND BUS INCENTIVES
ESPECIALLY SECOND WE APPRECIATE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
CHANGE THE PROPOSED TRANSFERS
FROM THE AIRPORT YOU CAN
CONTROL FUND TO ONE TIME LOAN
FUNDS THAN WE HAVE AT LEAST
HAVE A CHANCE. OF GETTING TO
CLEAN OUT SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
IN THE FUTURE THIRD THAT WE
SUPPORT IN PART EIGHT ITEMS
SEVENTY THREE TO FIND THE BUILD
PROGRAMME AND ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
IT'S ON THE UNUSUAL CANYON
STUDY FOCAL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE JOBS
AND REDUCE DEPENDENCE ON IT.
GREENHOUSE GAS FOR THE PART BE
ITEM THIRTY NINE WE HAVE
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO WITHDRAW THE JANUARY
PROPOSALS. FOR FUNDING FOR THE
FRESH WATER. HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS. A WE- THAT STAFF
RECKONED IT BE HELD OKAY. IN
PART BE I DON'T. WE OPPOSE
MINUTES. PROPOSAL TO IT DROPS
FOR THE STREAMING PLAN. AND
APPRECIATE THE STAFF RECORD A
HOLE THAT OPENED. AND WE
SUPPORT ITEM TO SEVENTY NINE IN
PART BE THE FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THE LITIGATION CHALLENGING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
BIOLOGICAL OPINION. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE SENATOR STERN
COMMENT- REGARDING- THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE NEED TO-
CONTINUE FINDING IT THANK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THIS IS LINE EIGHTY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON I CAN
WITHOUT LOOKING GILBERT ROBESON
AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITY
AND ASSOCIATION ANYWAY AND THE
GLASS PACKAGING INSTITUTE BOTH
OF WHOM WERE OPPOSED TO THE
STAFF RECOMMENDED TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE ON ISSUE THREE FORTY
FOUR. WANTED TO CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE ANYWAY THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION COULD INCREASE
COUNCIL PUBLICLY. OWNED
UTILITIES AND THEIR CUSTOMERS.
ELECTRIC RATES THE LOWEST IN
THE STATE ON AFTER. BETTER
STILL SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN THEIR
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES
COMING IN THE FUTURE. THE
COMPANY NINETEEN CRICHTON- NEW
UNEXPECTED COST PRESSURE ON PM
YOU CUSTOMERS- AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC YOU USE AROUND THE
STATE ARE SEEING UPTICK IN ON
TEAM BUILDING AND WORKING WITH
LOW INCOME ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
NOW SIMPLY ISN'T THE TIME TO
ADD ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES STUDENTS
CRICHTON. GENERALLY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE CONTACTING
INCIDENT ECONOMY GLASS BOTTLES
PRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA LESS
COMPLICATED COMPARED TO. CLASS
COMING FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. IN ADDITION TO
OUR- OBJECTIONS WE AGREE WITH
OTHERS THAT THEY WERE GONNA
APPROPRIATE FOR AN EIGHTEEN
INCH WHEEL MAKING- AND ON THE
NOTRE TRANSPARENCY WE JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE LAST TIME THE
LEGISLATURE WE DIDN'T
SUBSTANTIVELY ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM WHICH IS VERY
COMPLEX- IT TOOK. A YEAR AND A
HALF OF NEGOTIATION AND
DISCUSSION AT THE AIRPORT IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WE THINK THE
SWEEPING RECOMMENDATIONS MAY
NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND WOULD BE
BETTER CONSIDERING A POLICY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT IN LINE FOR. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
RECALL YOU KNOW THE IS JENNIFER
QUITE SPEAKING ON BEHALF CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND WE JUST WANTED
THE COMMENT THAT THEY HARDLY TO
SHIP COUNCIL SUPPORTING ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PRIORITIZING TO
DIRECTLY BACK. AT THE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN TWELVE I COULD HAVE
SAID I DON'T WANT TWO WHICH
ADDS TO THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO IMPLEMENT THE
FATE THE BUCKLE DRINKING WATER
PLAN WE ARE GOING TO JOIN
OTHERS IN SUPPORTING- ITEM
THREE FORTY THREE AND- A HALF.
DECISION OR RECOMMENDATION TO
RETAIN THE NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THE APPLICATION
YEAH OVERSEEING IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE AFFORDABLE I'M SORRY THE
THING ABOUT GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT- PARTICULAR.
WE'RE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. INSURING DRINKING IS
PROTECTED YEAH. ABOUT AND
PROCESS AND FINALLY I LIKE TO
JOIN SPEAK AT THE COURT I. THE
MAKEUP ON TO THE NEXT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WHAT PLEASE.
S. LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHICH MANY MORE
KNOWLEDGE ON BEHALF OF OUR
CULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
COMMISSIONS ON A COUPLE
DIFFERENT TEMS- FIRST THEY'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD IS REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SIX NEW
POSITIONS IN THE MAY REVISION.
FIFTEEN OF THOSE ARE IN ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR AND ITEM
NUMBER Q. EIGHTY NINE AND WE
HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THOSE AND THEY WOULD BE PAID
OUT AND- INCREASING PERMIT FEES
ON BATTERY CHEATERS. AND MANY
OF YOU KNOW AGRICULTURE AND
OTHER INDUSTRIES HI. THANKS IN
PART TO GET MEDICALLY BY KOBE.
NINETEEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO RECOVER. AND CAN'T
HAPPEN INCREASE ON THEIR PERMIT
FEES. ALSO A SENATOR STERN
POINTED OUT WE'RE HEADING INTO
A DROUGHT SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION
IS RAMPING UP. AND WITH THAT WE
CAN HAVE A POTENTIAL ONE
MILLION ACRES OF ARABLE FIELD
THOUGHT FOLLOWED. SO WE THINK
IT'S INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE
STATE WATER BOARD. TO BE
INCREASING FEAR THAT WE MAY BE
AN ACTUAL CONTRACTION IN THE
INDUSTRY- NEXT WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
PRIORITIZING. BIG DRINKING
WATER IN AFRICA REPLACEMENT A
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON.
I KNOW THAT YOU CAN FINDING WE
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THOUGH
ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO- THE
WATER BOARD HAS REQUESTED AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY EIGHT NEW
POSITION. FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER THIS IS ON TOP OF THE
TWENTY THREE POSITIONS. THEY
RECEIVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ARE. IS THAT THE TWO WAS VERY
CLEAR. THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OFTHE- DRINKING WATER
FINE HAD TO BE CAPPED AT FIVE
PERCENT. WITH THE PAID HUGO
SYSTEM WITH CAP AND TRADE
APPROACH. IS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WORKING CARING
ABOUT THOSE. SEVENTY ONE
PETITIONS WILL PUSH THAT OVER
THE 5% CAP. THAT WE THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE CONFIGURED VERY
HELP CAREFULLY THANK YOU LASTLY
ALKALINE MY COMMENT. A. BIG
THANK YOU TO ENTER. NEXT
WITNESS FOR. NEXT IN LINE FIFTY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARGOT PARK WITH BUT
YOU TAKE CONTROL IN MITIGATION
THAT WE SHARE OUR OUR POSITION
WITH MR OCCURRED ON IRAN THREE
FORTY FOUR RELATED TO CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN A STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED THEIR REGULAR PUBLIC
PROCESS NOT A LAST MINUTE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AS YOU ALL
KNOW IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED EIGHTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT. AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- ABOUT PUBLIC
PROVIDENT ECONOMIC NOW THAN
THEY WERE HELD OVER THE AIR B.
WHERE THEY ADOPTED. FINAL
REGULATIONS AND NOW TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS LATER WE'RE CONCERNED
WITH THE INTENT TO RE OPEN THE
PROGRAMS OR ANYTIME AT ALL
MARKETS INCLUDING THE CAP AND
TRADE MARKET ARE IN FLUX WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
INCREASING THE FLOOR PRICE
OTHERWISE MEDDLING IN THE
MARKET WILL ONLY SERVE TO
ACTUALLY INCREASE COST TO
CONSUMERS THERE'S NO
JUSTIFICATION THAT THAT
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE PROPOSED
CHANGES. CAP AND TRADE WORK IN
CONCORD CALIFORNIA OTHER KIND
OF PROGRAMS YOU NEED R. TWENTY
TWENTY GOLD FOUR YEARS EARLY
THE PROGRAM WILL ONLY BECOME
MORE STRINGENT AT THE CAP TO
KIND OF PULL FOR PRIDE A GREAT
DAILY BROUGHT THE CONCERN WITH
THE LANGUAGE- THAT EXEMPTS THE
PROFIT THIRTY EIGHT PM I THINK
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. FINALLY
LET MY KIDS GO ON RECORD AS
OPPOSING THE TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE YOU KNOW I CAN
SEE WHICH INCREASES
SUBSTANTIALLY EVERY YEAR AND
STARTED SAYING IT WAS INTENDED
TO BE FUNDED THROUGH THE TWO
YEAR PROGRAM WHAT THE PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED OKAY THANK YOU
GET YOUR APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
LINE FORTY. GO PLEASE. THANK
YOU RICHARD THIS IS MATT
ROBERTS WHICH I HAD A INTO EACH
WEARING ON THE OF THE CENTRE
OKAY TRANSIT DISTRICT AS WELL
AS CALTRAIN. WE ALSO GOT THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALGARY TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION IN TERMS OF- THE
APERTURE OUTLINED IN ITEMS
SEVENTY AND PART A OF THE
AGENDA AS WELL AS THE COMETS
BAILEY OF THAT WE NEED
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR. ZERO
EMISSION BUS IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND. NEXT WITNESS
PLAY. NEXT DEADLINE WON ALL
FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- NATALIE MARK ON
BEHALF OF THEM BUT ORIGINALLY
OPENED THE THIRD. ARMY CALCUTTA
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION OF THE
COUNTRY TO COURT AND THAT
REQUIRED- ON ECHO THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT OTHER DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND NOT MINE
FOUNDATION REGARDING THAT YES
IN ORDER TO GET PEOPLE TO POST
ABOUT WHAT. BUT THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. I'M BEHALF
OF HEALTH HOTEL COMPLAINING
BECAUSE UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE
WANTING THAT YOU LOOK AT IT
YOU'RE LIKE THE ONLY FOR AFRICA
TO CONQUER PLAN AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION. OR BOND THAT YOU
PLAN TO MINE PERMIT FOR AND
DEVELOP AND TO. CONNIE LASTLY
I'M OF THE PROVIDER SUN WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED BE THE BUDGET FOR
THE DEPARTMENT PARKS AND
RECREATION WILL BE REDUCED BY
THIRTY MILLION STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND NOT GOING. WE HOPE THAT THE
STATE DEVELOPMENT ALTERNATE
FUNDING STRATEGY FOR PROTECT
PARK SOME CLOSURES PARTICULARLY
DURING A TIME WHEN THERE IS A
GREAT REMEMBER OR. RECORD UP TO
RECREATION YEAH. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
ALL ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON NUMBERS CHAIRS- THIS
IS MERION WARMER DOWN THROW
CANDY REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL WE'D
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR THREE MONTH
COMMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AIRLINES WITH RESPECT TO NEED
FUNDING AFFECTS ON THE CHAIRS
I'M IN PARTICULAR IS NOTED WE
ARE ENTERING WHAT IS PROVING TO
BE A ROBUST FIRE SEASON AND
THERE'S CERTAINLY. IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SYSTEM SECONDLY WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT SHAKING
HEAD THE OTHER DAY OTHERS HAVE
NOTED- WILL BE COMING INTO ITS
OWN HERE SHORTLY AND WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED. THAT THE
REDUCTION IN FUNDING. WELL MOST
OF SERIOUSLY AFFECT SOME OF THE
TWO. COMMUNITY THAT ARE TO COME
UPON GROUND. WHICH WELL AS THE
OF THE- TAX OF WHAT IS TRENDING
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT LAND DOWN
THE LINCOLN CONTINENT. FINALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO REFER YOU TO
OUR LETTER WITH RESPECT TO THE
BENEFITS OF CONTINUING ON THE
FUNDING FOR THE MULTI BENEFIT.
PROGRAM CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH. RESPECT TO
THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT. SHE
CAN. CONTINUED SUNDAY FOR THE
STATE THE FOR DRINKING FUND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE ONE OH FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN ADAM ROBIN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS IN PART
B. OF YOUR AGENDA WELL BE
ASSOCIATED WITH RECOMMENDATION.
WITH RESPECT TO ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN W. OURS. WHAT
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT PROPOSAL
PRODUCTS INCLUDE IMAGE I WILL
UPGRADE AGING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE MUST
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENHANCING THE
FUNCTION OF A RIVER ECOSYSTEMS
FOR THE BENEFIT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WITH RESPECT TO ITEM
TWO EIGHTY NINE WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM RELATED ELEMENTS OF THE
STATE WATER BOARDS WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO BTP THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP ADVANCE THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH PROBLEM- TWENTY
FOURTEEN PROPOSITION ONE.
INCLUDING ECOSYSTEM WATER
QUALITY AND FLOOD CONTROL
BENEFITS AS WELL TO IMPROVE THE
OPERATION STATE WATER SYSTEM
THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE HAVE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
EIGHT THREE AHEAD PLAY. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LOUISE ALL METAL I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALL ME
GET RECALL THEM RIGHT AWAY AND
I'M NOT JUST SOLD IN THE
STATION. ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CLICK COLLISION- AND-
QUITE A COLLABORATIVE I HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS TO BE ABLE
TO FIT IN MORE BUT- WE HAVE
INFECTIOUS CONDITION AND- I CAN
CALL THE CASES IN THE BORDER
REGION. AND FOR THAT REASON
WE'RE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT AND
THANKFUL FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
PRIORITIZING MANY RIVER THE
SALTON SEA. AND WE ALSO. VERY
MUCH IN. OF I NEED A
MAINTAINING FINDS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE EIGHTY
SIX POINT SEVEN AS WELL MRS
REDUCTIONS IN COMMUNITY CARE
GRANTS. IN ADDITION TO THAT I
LIKE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT. BTS
EITHER VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL
AGENCY BUT THEY DO NEED THE
FUNDING. AND I LIKE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO. TAKE INITIATIVE AND ADDING
VERY STRICT PERFORMANCE
MASURES AND- IN FIRST TIME IN
ALMOST TWO DECADES BRING BACK
TO THE FOREFRONT. THE IT'S A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS- WHEN
THEY WERE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THAT AGENCY AS WELL PART OF THE
CORE MISSION IS WHEN WE HAD TO
MAKE MAJOR MOST SUCCESSFUL TIME
IN IMPLEMENTING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE THANK YOU OUT WITH THAT
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WITNESSES LINE
ONE OH SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS I'D
LIKE TO MAKE COMMENTER ON ITEM
THREE FORTY THREE RELATED TO
SEGMENT FROM THE NATION YES YES
OF COURSE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO MAINTAIN THE
NINE POINT SIX MILLION FOR
STOCKING THAT D. W. R. AS
MENTIONED BY OTHERS THIS IS A
CRITICAL YEAR FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT CLASS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT YOU HAVE
YOUR HOW TO STOP CAPACITY JUST
OTHER STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
REVIEW THIS IS THE INABILITY
PLANS SUBMITTED BY THE STATE
THE CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASIN WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR IN
ORDER FOR THE THING ABOUT THE
DEMAND FOR. ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AMONG
GOING GAUGE RIGHT THE CENTRAL
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PLAN TO THE CREATION OF A PLANT
FOR MEDIUM AND HIGH PRIORITY
BASIS AND THAT WILL BE
DEVELOPED THIS COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE THAT
YOU DERIVE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF G. EUROPE INVESTMENTS THAT
REDUCE EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR BY
SUPPORTING COMMERCIALIZATION OF
ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES INCLUDING MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXUS LINE ONE EIGHT
AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH HI OUR
MEMBERS ALEX REPRESENTING GROUP
TRIED JUST FORTY ITEM BY THE-
REQUIRE ON PART B. OF YOUR
AGENDA ITEM THREE TWENTY NINE
IT'S- AUGMENTATION OR ARCHIVAL
SUPPRESSION FUNDING OF THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT HOLDS ALL
THE RESPECTS TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY- WOULD PAVE THE
WOODLAND PRESCRIBED BURNS BY A
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED TRIBAL-
BUYERS RUSSIAN CRUISE THAT ALSO
POINT TOWARDS MANAGEMENT FUELS
REDUCTION OF FIRE PREPAREDNESS
BASED OF SPEECHES- TREATMENT
AND- VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECT- THE PROPOSAL FINALLY
BENEFIT TRIBAL LAND BUT ALSO
REDUCES WILDFIRE THREAT- FOR
THEIR NEIGHBORS AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
IT'S LIKE NINETY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
HI MORGAN KEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT- WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FROM
FORGET THAT HE'S CUTTING THE
GREEN TAPE INITIALS ADJUSTER
INSURE THE CONTINUED AND
EXPANDED PROGRESS WITH CRITICAL
WILDLIFE PROJECTS ADDITIONALLY
WORRY I'M HERE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE CAP AND TRADE AUCTION
REVENUES. COMING IN AS EXPECTED
THAT IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE TYPICAL P. EIGHTEEN PEOPLE
STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
ORGANIZATIONS WILL FACE IN
PLANNING PROJECTS UNDER A PAY
AS YOU GO MODEL I ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE CONTINUED CAPITAL
PROJECT FUNDING FOR W. C. B.
THAT THEY CALLED THE
CONSERVANCY AS WELL AS THE F.
W. I LASTLY WE'RE DEFINITELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
DECISION TO WITHDRAW THE PORTAL
FOR FOUR POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BOTHER HERE. I AM
HERE TO BODY STILL ADVANCED
ECONOMIC STIMULUS BOND FUND
THAT INCLUDES AN ACKNOWLEDGES
THE ECONOMIC AND JOB POTENTIAL
PROJECT. ACTOR THE CLEAR I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE FINDINGS
IDENTIFIED INTO GET TOGETHER
BAY AREA BAY AREA LAND PEOPLE
AND ECONOMY A SNAPSHOT REPORT
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR GREEN
STIMULUS SUPPORT I WOULD HAVE
TO DELIVER TO YOU ALL I WANT
THAT MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED NEW GREEN JOBS
THAT COULD BE IMMEDIATELY
CREATED IN THE BAY AREA ALONE.
BESTING AND READY TO GO.
CLIMATE BENEFICIAL PROJECTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. IT'S ONE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBER WITH US IN JEANETTE
CALIFORNIA BY HERE ON BEHALF
MUD I WANT TO PURCHASE THANK
AND YOUR FROM THE WORK ON THE
CONTENT TIME FRAME THREE
QUICKLY WE WANTED TO GIVE OUR
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOCATION- OF FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN. PDF FUNDING
AT THE CCP CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- THIS ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
IN PART A IS- RECOMMENDED TO BE
DEFERRED TO A LATER DATE WE
JUST URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT MONEY STAYS IN THE
C. C. FOR EASY TRUCKING
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND SECONDLY-
WE RESPECTFULLY- MUST OPPOSE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR
ITEM THREE FOR FOUR IN PART BE.
TIME FOR THE SECOND TIME WILL
ECHO THE CONCERNS AND COMMENTS
THAT WERE DONE BY TAKING IT
ANYWAY THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND THE
IRON. WEEK ONE PLEASE IT'S ONE
SIX GO AHEAD. ONE OH SIX DO YOU
HAVE YOUR MUTE ON. WE MOVE ON
TO LINE ONE ELEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKUP CRY OUT ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINTS I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON PART A ITEMS
THIRTEEN- AND WE'RE MINDFUL OF
THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS EARLIER-
REGARDING THIS ITEM BUT ALSO
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE- EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE-
FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR.
EASY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
INCENTIVES- THROUGH THE CDC'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THE COVERT- NINETEEN INDUCED
RECESSION IS IMPACTED EVERY
ASPECT OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
IN THE EASY CHARGING INDUSTRY
IS CERTAINLY NO EXCEPTION-
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE TO
MAINTAIN GROWTH IN THIS
INDUSTRY IS CRITICAL AND NOT
ONLY TO MAINTAIN JOBS AND
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT BUT ALSO TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA ON TRACK WITH
MEETING ITS AIR QUALITY AND GHG
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS- AS
YOU PROCEED WITH THE BUDGET WE
WOULD STRONGLY. URGE YOUR
MAINTAINING THE FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR- APPROPRIATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HIS LINE ONE TWELVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. AFTERNOON WE'RE
BACK MARKET ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND
SUPPORTED FUNDING FOR SICK MY
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIFICALLY FOR
LOCAL PLANNING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND THE PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FIVE FEET CONTINUING THE
ONGOING WORK COULD BE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT WORK
GROUP AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. ON BEHALF
OF ALL THREE ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORTED ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE
FEET TO FIND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE'S FARM TO
SCHOOL PROGRAM AND LASTLY WHEN
THE TIME DOES COME FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT CONTINUED
FINDING ALCOHOL PROGRAM AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE AND
LEGISLATURE TO ELEVATE THE
HEALTHY HEALTHY SOIL PROGRAM
FOR CONSIDERATION I THINKING
ABOUT THAT FOR FARMERS DURING
THE UNPRECEDENTED TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HIS LINE TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEEN SPORT MODEL WITH A WHITE
MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE COMMUNITY ENERGY TO LOOK
SERVING ENTITY THAT PROVIDES
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS ACROSS
ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE KNOWLEDGE
THAT IT SHARES COMMENTS BUT WE
DO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN ON JAN EIGHTY
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE ENERGY
COMISSION FOR EASY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT HAS
COMMITTED TO BRINGING FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT TO THE TABLE TO
MATCH THE EASY DOLLARS PROVIDED
THE PROGRAM GETS THE CRITICAL
FUNDING FOUND IN THIS AGENDA
ITEM. FOR YOUR DUE TO ABOUT
THIS ITEM AS PART OF THE JUNE
BUDGET RATHER THAN DELAYING IT
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WITNESS
IS LYING. FORTY GOING PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER STATION WBUR
MARIN COUNTY FIRE CHIEF
REPRESENTING THAT CAL FIRE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT CLASS
CAN BE THE CAUSE OF THE FORMS A
LOT THEY LOOK INTER
CONTEMPORANEOUS MORAN. REGARDS
THE ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY FIVE
FORTY ISSUE THREE TWENTY NINE.
GOING TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OF THE CAL FIRE WOULD BE
STEPPING PCP OF EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HEADLINE ONE SIXTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR IN NUMBER YEAH A LITTLE
LESS RED WITH 20% IT'S WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CURRENT FISCAL
SITUATION AND THE REALLY
DIFFICULT TASK AT HAND- BUT
EVEN MORE CRITICALLY I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT INEQUITY IN THAT
AND THEN UNDERSCORED BY THE-
FACT THAT MANY. WE THE COURT
THAT THE AFRICAN. AND ITEM
THREE FORTY HERE AND WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH. PROPOSED
ABOUT YOUR PRODUCTION IS THAT
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. AS WE'VE SEEN NOW
MORE THAN EVER ACCESS TO PARKS
AND OPEN SPACE OUR INITIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AND THE RESOURCES TO
IDENTIFY DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION PROVIDE LOW COST
RELIEF UNDER RESOURCE URBAN AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE.
EXPERIENCED DISPROPORTIONATELY
THE ECONOMIC UNEMPLOYMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT. EVENING
BURDENS RESULTING. FROM THE
KERR THAT NINETEEN CRATE THAT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WITH THE-
AND THE AGENCY IMPLANT SOME
SORT OF ALTER SOLUTIONS NEEDS.
CUTS ALERTED SOME OF OUR
PARTNER. OR WOULD BE. REALLY
THE CARD AND DEVELOPING I'M
KINDA ECONOMIC RECOVERY ANYWAY-
MY CONTACT THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE NINETY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CALLING HERE THEY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND THE
NORMALLY INTO CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY UNLIMITED
CALIFORNIA TROUT CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE RESPECTED RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
PARTNER BILL ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. CDFW OPERATIONS
BUDGET. WELL I THINK SETTING H.
P. DOING THE EXPANSION PACK THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR ALSO ON
THE ABOLITION OF DOORS AND WALK
INTO A RESTAURANT IN THE PARK
NOW COALITION LETTER TO YOUR
COMMITTEE WE ASKED THE STATE
INSURANCE. DEPARTMENT EQUITABLE
ACCESS CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY. FOR THE STATE
REFLECTED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
YOU'RE PLEASED THAT PROP SIXTY
APPLICATION FOR THE LOCAL PARK
PROGRAM WERE INCREASED HOWEVER
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
FOLLOWING WEEK JOHN AND YOUR
VISION THE TWENTY MILLION FOR
THE OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL.
EDUCATION GRANT PROGRAM THE TWO
POINT NINE MILLION CARPORT AND
GT TWELVE ACTORS PROGRAM
EXPANSION THE DOG THE ONE
MILLION CARDS FOR THE COACH AND
HIS FAMILY CAN LEVERAGE.
CONTRIBUTING AND TURN MAINLY
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC BUT IN
EQUITABLE. TO THE OUTDOOR
APPROVING TO BE. BUT FRONTAL
HOW AND WELLBEING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS FOR. HIS
LINE ONE FIFTH BUT PLEASE. BUT
THEIR NUMBERS MAINLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE THE
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR FOR
THIRTY TWO COMMUNITIES IN LOS
ANGELES THERE AND HER
ACCOUNTING FOR THE LARGEST THE
CITY AND THE STATE PROVIDE
POWER TO APPROXIMATELY THREE
MILLION PEOPLE. A WEEK YOU ARE
MINDFUL OF THE SHARED EARLIER
COMMENT BUT THE CLEAN POWER
LINE PUSHES TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE CDC
BUDGET REQUEST THE LAST ONE
TIME FIVE FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR EXPENDITURE FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS NINE AND THIRTEEN
INCARNATE THAT JENNA. WERE PART
OF AN EFFORT WITH THE P. EASY
TO BRING MORE EASY TRACKING AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTH
CENTRAL COAST THROUGH THE TV
SCREEN HELLO THE I. P. PROGRAM
THEY HAVE COMMITTED HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS AND EXPECT TO
PUT IN OVER ONE POINT FIVE.
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. L. U. B. I. PROBE.
FOR INCREASED BEAT HER INVENTOR
ACCOUNT. THIS FUNDING IN THE-
FOR THE PART MOVED. IN THE
OFFICE US SOME MOMENT TAKE. THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AT THIS
COMMITTEE CONSIDERS
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET CHANGES
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
FURTHER IN THE WHOLE COUNTY D.
A. P. AND- WHICH WILL HELP THE
STATE MEDIA COLLECTION VEHICLE
GHG EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN
CLEAN AIR COLD. ALL WHILE
CREATING IMMEDIATE GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE- ECHO THE
SUPPORT FROM SENATOR STERN
COMMENTS AND PREACHING THE
SENATOR THE SENATE LEADERSHIP.
IN CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
ALONG THE LINES OF THEM HAVING
AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY BOND
FOCUSED ON CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SIX LIVE ONE THIRTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND OF
AMERICORPS OLSON JOINING WITH
THE PREVIOUS WITNESS CHIEF
JASON WEBER OF RAIN CANDY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT HOW
THIS FIRE DEPARTMENTS OF KERN
LOS ANGELES MARIN ORANGE SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTIES
THE SIX COUNTIES PROVIDE FIRE
PROTECTION PREVENTION SERVICES
TO S. R. A. OR STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA LANDS
WITHIN THEIR BOUNDARIES. AND
THEY'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATIONSFOR CAL
FIRE INCLUDING THE EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR RELIEF STAFFING
FOUND ON THE PAGE ONE OF FIVE A
PART BE THE AGENDA ISSUE THREE
TWENTY NINE AS DISCUSSED
EARLIER TODAY BY CAL FIRE CHIEF
TOM PORTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LINE ONE TO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE WHEN
IS CORNELL IRAL AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA TODAY YOU WANT TO
COME IN AND SEVERAL ITEMS OF
COURSE WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
pAGREE WITH HIM ALL MORE ON
UNDERSTANDING. RELATED TO THE
RESEARCH BUDGET WE'RE ACTUALLY
UNDER RESOURCES AND AS IT IS
AND WE LOOK AT IT AND AS WE
LOOK AT THIS BUDGET WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT HAVE LONG TERM NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT. HE SHOULD BE
ADDED THAT INVESTMENT AND NOT
USED TO SUPPLANT MONEY. THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO MAKE. I WANT
TO MAKE THE STATE HOME GIVING
STATE TAX ID HERE. ARE THE
SPECIFIC PLAN ITEMS THAT WE
SUPPORT OUR AND OPPOSE THE PART
BE. WE SUPPORT THE MINISTRY
PAPA FOR THREE MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONS CONTINUE SUPPORT THE
JANUARY. BUT THE NEW MEMBER
AGREEMENT PROJECT ON AUTUMN
MORNING JORDAN INTO NINE
SUPPORT CREATION TO SEE IF. SEE
IT AS A AND P. EIGHT FOR ONE
TIME COSTS THAT YOU. FEDERAL BY
OPINION. FOR ITEM SIX I WAS
APART JANUARY B. C. PETE
CALDERA TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
STAFFING LEVELS- SO THAT'S-
WHAT YOU GET BACK TO BEIJING TO
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN HARDLY.
ALL ISSUE THREE FORTY THREE
FORTY OF ALL THE U. SIX
FOOTBALL SEASON AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WHILE FROM THE- YEAH.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER. NINE
POINT MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
SEGMENT. HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE PART THAT MONEY USED FOR
AND THE W. TWO DAYS. I WILL BE
THE BEST CAN BE SHARE. NEXUS
LINE EIGHTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
I THANK YOU THAT WILL PAIR UP
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ONGOING EFFORTS OF THE
STATE REALLY TO ADDRESS THE
LONG HELP ENDEMIC WORLD FACING
TOGETHER SO THANK YOU.
LEADERSHIP OF WHAT CALIFORNIA
IN LEADER IN ADDRESSING LONG
HEALTH THREAT POSED BY AIR
POLLUTION CLIMATE CHANGE
SEVERAL BUT YOUR LOCAL.
CONCERNED THAT WALKED DELAYS IN
OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE THAT
THE PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN MAKING.
CATION SECTOR IS THE LEADING
SOURCE OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION
YET THE G. EUROPE PROPOSALS
LEAVE CRITICAL PROGRAMS WITHOUT
PRIORITY AND LIKELY WITHOUT
FUNDING- INCLUDING THE CLEAN
TRUCK BUS AND AWKWARD.
DEPORTMENT CATEGORY THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROGRAMS. AND A CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM. THE ITEMS ONE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE AND
THIRTY SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO
PRIORITIZE ME TRANSPORTATION AS
AN IMPORTANT COMPLEMENT
REGULATORY EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE
WHAT THE SECOND WINNER. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXPENDITURE OF FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNUSED
ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING. COURT
TV INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT THEIR
TEAM OR A- WE APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS WITHIN THE G. TERRA
CATEGORIES FOR- EIGHTY SIX AND
SEVEN TO TEN FUNDING. BUT I AM
THE ONE THIRTY TWO BUT WE WOULD
ALSO ECHOED THE CONCERNS OF THE
PROGRAM WILL BE GREATLY
IMPACTED BY THE LACK OF CLARITY
FOR AIR DISTRICT. AND COMMUNITY
PLANTATION PONDERING THANK YOU
ONE THIRTY ONE ONE THIRTY THREE
AND THEN FINALLY AT SENATOR
STERN AND OTHERS- NOTED EARLIER
THE DIVERSION OF. FUNDING OUT
OF THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND TO COVER UNRELATED BUDGET
GAP AND HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC AND
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK. GOING
ON BY THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO AVOID THAT DIVERSION
AND ON CONTAINERS THANK YOU
AFFECTED AGENCIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. IT IS ONE TWO ONE
GOING PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M JENNIFER THE GENERAL MAN
FOR THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
WERE AN ORGANIZATION OF PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO DELIVER WATER TO
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIA
RATEPAYERS AND BY THE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND. I'M COMMENTING ON
ITEMS TO- FOR AN TWO SEVEN
NINE. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE STATE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW TO DEVELOP
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS TO UPDATE
THE REGULATIONS FOR SIERRA
NEVADA RIVERSIDE DANCING AT
FIFTEEN YEAR FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PLAN. TO PROVIDE MORE
WATER AND HABITAT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT WHILE PROTECTING
THE WATER RIGHT THE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES. LOBBIED
MINISTRATION. ABOUT TO THAT END
HOWEVER WE ARE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE STATE OF THE NATION
CHALLENGING THE FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL. CONTINUED TO MOVE
FORWARD. LEFT UNRESOLVED
THERE'S NO CLEAR PATH TO GET TO
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT. PERHAPS A
BETTER USE OF THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
WOULD BE TO HIRE FACILITATION
SERVICES. TO FINALLY RESOLVE
THE ISSUES BETWEEN THE STATE
AND FEDERAL WATER AGENCY. COULD
HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RESOLVED IN TWENTY NINETEEN. WE
WOULD ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
SIGNALED PREFERENCE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO RETURN TO A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. BY
ABANDONING THE LITIGATION
REGARDING THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP UNDER THE
TYPICAL AND UNPRECEDENTED.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. SHE IS
LINE ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU SURE NUMBERS MAKE IT
A CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ON
ENERGY PLEASE PROCEED LIKE TO
APPLAUD THE COMMITTEE FOR COURT
RECOMMENDATION ON THREE
PROPOSALSTODAY FIRST PART A
ISSUE SEVENTY THREE THE BUILD
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION THE PROGRAM WILL
HELP PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
INCENTIVE NEEDED TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS EIGHTY
CARBONATE CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING
SECTOR. SPECIFICALLY BY JUMP
STARTING THE MARKET FOR CLEAN
AND EFFICIENT HEATING
TECHNOLOGIES AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR STERN FOR HIS
WORK ON A P. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN AND HIS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE SECOND
PART BE ISSUED TO A FOREIGN TO
SEVENTY NINE RELATED TO THE
STATE'S LEGAL COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE EIGHTEEN BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS LITIGATION. THE PEOPLE
THE CASE AGAINST TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THE
BAY DELTA THE THOUSAND THE
FISHING JOBS THAT DEPEND ON IT
THIRD PARTY ISSUE ONE FIFTY
FIVE MEGABYTES DOCKING IN
FUNDING FREE PDF BASED PART OF
THE SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT
INVESTED IN HEALTHY SUSTAINABLE
COOL DUDE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
DON'T GO HUNGRY BUT CALIFORNIA
SMALL AND MIDSIZE FARMERS
SURVIVE THIS CRISIS. YOU GET
ACCESS TO STABLE MARKETS IN THE
LONG TERM THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME IN TODAY
AND FOR ALL YOUR WORK AT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. HIS LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIS
IS MY NAME IS SHOT LINE DEPUTY
POLICY FOR COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR WE UNDER HOW THIS FUNDED
SCHOOL SITUATION IS BUT WE THE
OF AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND
THIS FUND RUNS A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT IT SHOULD ONLY BE USED
TO REDUCE IR POLLUTION- WE DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO SEE. EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE VITAL TO
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S D. B.
DEPLOYMENT COMMITMENTS- BECAUSE
OF THE UNCERTAINTY OVER THE
OPTIONS- WE DO APPRECIATE
PUTTING OFF ANY SORT OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
DECISIONS. HOWEVER WHEN YOU
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS WE URGE
PRIORITIZING COMMUNITY
ARCHITECTURE PROGRAMS EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN. AND CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PARTICULARLY
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INCENTIVES BECAUSE THOSE
INCENTIVES WILL- WELL AND IN
THAT SENSE COUPLED WITH
REGULATION WILL PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. PUT PEOPLE TO WORK IT'S
AN ESPECIALLY BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN HIT HARDEST BY THE
PANDEMIC RECESSION. AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AS WELL HELPED. REACH ITS AIR
CALLED IN. REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON REMEMBER RIGHT
NOW MY PRIMARY GOAL. YOU BETTER
BURNT ALMOND BURNING THE FIRE
UPON NEED FOR INVESTING NEARLY
89% OF ALL CALIFORNIANS LIVING
IN URBAN AREAS RESPECTS
COMPOUNDING EFFECT AND WE'RE
BATTLING HEALTH IMPACT. OF IT
IN EXTREME HEAT EVENTS DATE
MUST BEGIN PREPARATIONS FOR
THAT BECAUSE YOU WAIT A MONTH.
WE ALSO URGE CONSIDERATION OF
FUNDING FROM THE CLIMATE THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT WHAT WE'RE
DOING TACKLING THE GREATEST.
WRESTLER APPLYING CLIMATE
CHANGE. ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
BORROWER FUND AND RELATED TO
EACH PROGRAM. FOR ANY MEDIUM
AND HEAVY TRUCKS REALLY THE
TECHNICIAN OUT NIGHT DOCKSIDE
THE THROUGH MISSION. MAKING UP
A SMALL PORTION OF THE BOOK
ABOUT ROAD. CONDITIONS REDUCING
POLLUTION AND BENEFITING HUMAN
HEALTH AND QUALITY OF LIFE
INVESTMENT IN YOUR MISSION
TRUCK THE MONEY FOR THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY BY REDUCED
FEEL- FEELING POP. CULTURE
CREATING JOBS. WE REALLY NEED
TO TALK. TO ANYBODY JUST TRY.
TO BE PRIORITIZED BASED ON
IMPACT THEY CALL CAN FROM THIS
MOMENT THAN EVER THANK YOU
THANK VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT IN LINE ONE THIRTY AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OPERATOR MEDINA WITH MATH UP
AND PHILIP ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT I
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSEOF THE
SALTON SEA AUTHORITY AND
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR ITEM
ONE TWENTY SIX LISTED ON PART
B. OF THE AGENDA. THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE NEW
RIVER IMPROVEMENT PROJECT AND
THE SALTON SEA MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM- THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH BOTH BODIES OF WATER HAVE
BEEN LONGSTANDING CRISIS THEN-
THIS WAS EVEN BEFORE THE COPA
NINETY PANDEMIC SO WE- URGED A
STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT LINE ONE THIRTY
ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. MEMBERS
PATRICK MORAN WITH THERE AND
READ IT SAYS HE IS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTIST. WHAT
CAPS UNDERSTAND THE SEVERITY OF
THE ECONOMIC PREDICAMENT
CALIFORNIA FACES IN THE
DIFFICULT TASK FACING YOU
COMING UP WITH A BALANCED
BUDGET. HOWEVER WHEN YOU COUPLE
THE PROPOSED CUTS WITH THE
POTENTIAL REDUCTION IN EMPLOYEE
WORK HOURS AS A RESULT OF
POTENTIAL FURLOUGHS OR SOME
OTHER SOLUTION WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DELIVERY OF ESSENTIAL
SCIENTIFIC WORK AT THE BERRIES
DEPARTMENTS EMPLOYS NINE KIDS
WE CERTAINLY HOPE YOU TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. HIS LIFE ONE
THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN RITA SOCIUS
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE OF COURSE ALL
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
PATIENCE ON THIS LONG SUNDAY
AFTERNOON. THE WEATHER IN
SACRAMENTO IS GOING TO BE OVER
A HUNDRED DEGREES NEXT NEXT
WEEK AND A LITTLE FIRE SEASON
IS EXPECTED THE GOVERNOR SAYING
60% GREATER THAN THE LAST THREE
YEARS THAT WE HAVE FACED. WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE ITEM THREE
TWENTY NINE. THAT THE
AUGMENTATION OF EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION WILL GRAIN
FIREFIGHTERS TO AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL TECHNOLOGY COURSES
DESPITE WILL CONTINUE. INTO TWO
LETTERS LATER SESSIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. THANK
YOU THE NEXT WITNESS. NEXT IN
LINE FORTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. DO
YOU CARE AND MEMBERS USUALLY
GARINGER WITH COUPLE CULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA WHEN THE
TIME RIGHT OR THAT THE
COMMITTEE CAN MAKE DECISIONS ON
TGIF WE WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT QUEUE ITEM WITHIN PART
B. OF THE H. AND THAT BOTH THE
UNDER ISSUE ONE EIGHTY FOUR WE
SUPPORT AFTER HER CONDITION IN
THE MAIL I CAN'T. OF THE ACT OF
DIESEL EMISSIONS FUNDING FROM
DG ARE ASKED WHICH IS. HELPING
TO SLASH EMISSIONS QUALITY IF
BECAUSE- COMMUNITIES. WE ARE TO
PROTEST AS WELL AS- SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PRIVATIZATION OF
FUNDING FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO ENSURE CLEAN WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ALSO UNDER ISSUE
THREE THREE FOUR IN PART BE WE
RESPECTFULLY. ECHOED THE
CONCERNS. AND OTHER COMMENTS TO
OPPOSE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FOR A R. B. TO CONDUCT A
RULEMAKING REGARDING TRAPPING
TRADE. RP FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES WE
PROBABLY CREATING THIS. I'M A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL IN
PARTICULAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. HIS ONE
THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HI MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS INTO
THE MOLINE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA EGG
FARMERS THE PACIFIC A
COMPULSORY SUSPICION THE
CALIFORNIA GREENPEACE CESSATION
I LIKE THE COMIC ON PART B.
ITEM THREE OH EIGHT. THEY WERE
EXPRESSING CONCERNS WITH THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL FOR
CONFINEMENT OF LIVESTOCK ALSO
KNOWN AS PROPOSITION TWELVE
CONCERNS OF THE FOLLOWING ARE
THE PROPOSAL ESTABLISHES A NEW
PROGRAM THE NEW FREE AND WANTS
TO GET A COURT DEAL WITH EGGS
THE EGG INDUSTRY ALREADY HAS A
MILKY ASSESSMENT AND PROP TOLD
FORTUNE REQUIREMENTS THE
CONCERN IS THAT THE EGG
INDUSTRY WILL BE PAYING FOR A
DISPROPORTIONAL AMOUNT
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE OTHER
INDUSTRIES. SUCH AS DO YOU WANT
OR DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROGRAM SET UP THERE'S NO
IDENTIFIED METHOD TO COLLECT
FROM THESE ENTITIES NOR WILL
COMMUNICATE AND ENFORCE
REPORTERS THE ELECT THE MOMENT
I'M ADDITIONALLY THERE WILL BE
DUPLICATION WITHIN THE PROGRAM
THE CURRENT SHELL A PROGRAM AT
CDFA DOES MORE THAN JUST WORK
THE REGULATIONS FOR FOOD SAFETY
AND HEALTH. THE INSPECTION
INSPECT PACKAGING LABELLING
TAKEN BY ALSO THERE ARE SEVERAL
OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES FOR FOOD
SAFETY PROTECTION- AND FINALLY
THE SHELLING PROGRAM HAS AN
EXISTING FULLY FUNDED PROGRAM
AND THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INCREASE FUNDS FOR ENFORCEMENT-
THAT THE DIGITAL STATUTORY
AUTHORITY NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED
TO ENFORCE THE NEW LIQUID X.
RAYS PROP TWELVE WE ARE OPEN TO
ADDRESSING THESE CONCERNS- IN
STATUTE RATHER THAN CREATING A
NEW PROGRAM. I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR CONCERNS TODAY
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO FIND THE
ONE YEAR PROGRAM AND THEN NOT
THE LONG TERM SO WE WILL GET A
CHANCE. TO LOOK AT THAT NEXT
WITNESS. CORRECT EIGHT. LINE
THIRTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
YOU KAREN AND ON NELSON THAT
MEETING WATERS AND THANK YOU
SIR YOUR PATIENCE HER ECHOING
MULTIPLE OTHER OKAY WE ARE BUT
THE PROPOSED CONTINUATION BUT
AT THE WATER THEY IN THE
QUARTER DRINKING FUND PROGRAM
SECOND ON ITEM THREE FORTY
THREE LIKE MENTAL PATIENT WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT RECOMMENDATION
TO KEEP THE NINE POINT SIX
MILLION IF YOU ARE. TALKING
ALTHOUGH WE HAD BIRDS INCREASED
FOCUS ON ANALYZING FOR SAFE
WATER IMPACT RECENT EXTRA NOW
SAYS FOUND THAT OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
COULD LOSE ACCESS TO WATER
BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF ONLY.
THE GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN ACROSS THE BOARD YOU KNOW
YOU ARE AND CONCERNS ARE
GROWING IN LIGHT OF THE
INCREASING DROUGHT CONDITIONS
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE W. AREN'T IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD EXPERTISE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T UNDERMINE
RECENT PROGRESS THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR HAD MADE ON THE
WATER. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE ONE FINAL PART
IF ONE NINE AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE AND
COMMITTEE EMBERS MY COMMENT
TODAY TO THE BC THE- WHO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE J.
FUND FOR ONE TIME WITH. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINION. THE THREE
PM. THE SIGN INTO REP THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS IN
AN UNFORTUNATE CHOICE FINALLY
ADMINISTRATION QUESTIONS
STAKEHOLDERS AWAY FROM
COLLABORATION AND BACK TOWARD
CONFLICT IN LITIGATION WE URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE TE PCP THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY FINAL WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE TO
BE JUST A MOMENT HERE. MY
APOLOGIES IS TAKING JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT. N. Y. NINETY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY ONE MOMENT
HERE. GO AHEAD TRY THAT AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE ONE MOMENT. NINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. THANKS SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR LIKE HOW CAN
SENATORS LOOKING FOR COME AFTER
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY OUT
APPRECIATE THUNDERSTORMS
PRODUCING CONCERNS AND WORRYING
FEELING IT THOUGH THAT BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BUDGET AND THE
BEING EXPENDABLE AND THE
CHOICES PRESENTED TODAY
REPRESENT A HOBSON'S CHOICE WE
SHARE THE SAME CONCERN. I T. NG
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU REJECT
PROPOSED BUDGET CUT THE CFW
ESPECIALLY PROPOSAL TO GET RID
OF THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND JUST LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE LED BY THE SENATE
INCLUDING SEVERAL OF YOU
NEGOTIATE AN EXTENSION OF EIGHT
C. UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEAD COUNSEL IN
GERMAN THE HCF TRAILER BILL
REQUIRING FOR HIS RECORDER
CHOIR FOR FIFTEEN BUT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE KNOWLEDGE
OF MY IDEA WENT FURTHER IN THIS
HEARING THAT COURSE IT VOTED
LIKE THE REQUIRED AS WELL. IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO PRESERVE HCF IN
PART BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL LEVERAGING
INVESTMENT ACROSS THE STATE
CONSERVATION AS WELL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE SUPPORT NEEDED
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR C. F. W.
AND I PURCHASED IT IN THE
SERVER SPACE BUDGET STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS. FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS BUT THE H. C. F. B. C. P.
TO REJECT IT AS FOR D. W. R.
AND SIGMA FUNDING WE SUPPORT
KEEPING ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
SIX MONTHS AFTER THAT YES YOU
ARE WE URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING SOME PORTION OF THE
JANUARY FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR
CITY OPERATIONS TO ENSURE YOU
HAVE YOU ARE CONSTRUCTIVELY
GLANCING MY WAY TO THE KEEPS A
PARTY. AT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY ALSO DOES SUPPORT
OPPOSE CUTTING GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVES THAT PROPOSAL WILL
INCREASE THE SCALE AND PACE OF
RESTORATION WORK WELL WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE STILL ADDITIONAL
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CONCEPT OF EXPEDITING
THE PERMITTING AND GRANT MAKING
PROCESS WITH BOTH NEEDED IN
STRATEGIC. AND WE WORK WITH GFW
AS WELL BUT ACTUALLY SORRY HE
IS ONE OF THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS
ON A COUPLE OF ALL OF ITS
DEVELOPMENT THANK N. LASTING
STRONGLY AGREE THAT SOME TYPE
OF STIMULUS RESILIENCE BOND IF
NEEDED AND APPRECIATE THE
RECENT IN A LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR MAKING A CASE FOR WHY
BOTHER. A TIME TO DO IT NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU IN
WITH THAT. WE WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING. THREE MOTIONS
ON. OURS ON THE PART EIGHTY
SECTION ONCE IT WILL BE N. FOR
MOTION SEVEN MOTIONS ALTOGETHER
ALL RIGHT WE ARE IN RECESS FOR
TEN MINUTES.
THIS IS
SUBCOMMITTEE TO. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL TAKE THEM OKAY SURE
RECOGNIZE SENATOR MINING. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN JUST BEFORE WE
GO INTO OUR NEXT PHASE SOMEONE
I THINK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THE ORGANIZING AND ALL THE
STAFF WHO. HELPED ORGANIZE THIS
SUFFICIENT. GATHERING IN FOR
ALL THE WITNESSES WHO CALLED IN
AN- FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET
THEIR TESTIMONY AND BY PHONE- I%
JUST WENT OFF FOR A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS BEFORE WE GO INTO THE
VOTING- ALIGNING WITH SENATOR
STERN'S.OVERVIEW COMMENTS OF
WHEN WE SEE CUTS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS. BUT
WE KNOW WE HAVE A HUGE FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR PROJECTED
SHORTFALL. BUT I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO LEARN. AS COVERT
NINETEEN HAS TAUGHT US. ADVERSE
IMPACTS ON DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK WE'RE
ALSO SEEING THAT WITH CLIMATE
CRISIS IN THAT WE HAVE TO DRAW
FROM THIS EXPERIENCE OF COVERT
NINETEEN. THIS MAY BE AN EARLY
WARNING OF THE PREPARATION WE
NEED TO DO AROUND CLIMATE
CRISIS. AND THAT WOULD SUGGEST
OUR CONTINUED WORK ON.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS THAT
PROTECT. THE PUBLIC HEALTH MMHM
A COUPLE OF SPECIFIC AREAS. I
WANT TO OFFER MY SUPPORT FOR
THE- COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATION.
TO REJECT THE PROPOSED CUTS ON
THE SIGMA FUNDING OF NINE POINT
SIX MILLION. BUT WITH THE
CAVEAT THAT I WOULD HOPE. IF
THAT FUNDING IS RESTORED AS THE
SIGMA WORKING EVALUATIONS MOVE
FORWARD. THE EVALUATIONS
INCLUDE- SOME MONITORING OF
ATTENTIONAL ADVERSE IMPACTS TO
SAFE AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER
AS PART OFTHAT EVALUATION
PROCESS. MMHM IT ALSO ENCOURAGE
THAT WATER SERVICE CONNECTIONS.
THAT WERE CUT OFF AROUND THE
TIME OF THE COVE IN NINETEEN. I
WANT TO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO REQUIRE
WATER SERVICE AGENCIES NOT TO
CUT OFF THE LIFE SUSTAINING
WATER SUPPLY WHO PERHAPS CAN'T
AFFORD. THAT MONTHLY WATER BILL
AND I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THAT
THAT PROTECTION CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD IN THAT THERE BE A LOOK
AT ANYONE THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
CUT OFF SHORTLY BEFORE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. FOR THEIR
PROTECTION IN THERE RIGHT THEIR
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO JUST THANK THE GOVERNOR.
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
THE CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER FUND-
IN AGAIN RECOGNIZING. THE
CRITICAL LIFE SUSTAINING
SUPPORT OF CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER IS THE STATE WE CAN STILL
ACHIEVE THAT EVEN AS WE FACE
THESE BUDGET CHALLENGES. A
FINAL COMMENT MISTER CHAIR I
KNOW WE ARE FINE LOOKING FOR
FUNDING WHEREVER WE CAN I WAS
SORRY TO SEE THE PROPOSED CUTS
IN ITEM THIRTY SIX THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION A PROPOSED CUT OF
ONE POINT EIGHT SEVEN MILLION
FOR MONITORING OF AIR IN OUR
MONITORING OF POTENTIAL BY
PRODUCT IMPACTS OF CERTAIN
PESTICIDES IN EIGHT COUNTIES-
AGAIN MINOR IN THE TOTAL DOLLAR
AMOUNT BUT CRITICAL FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PARTICULARLY OF
RURAL RESIDENTS. IN FARM WORKER
FAMILIES. AND FINALLY THE CAL
FIRE POSITIONS. FULLY SUPPORT
THAT FUNDING AS RECOMMENDED. BY
THE COMMITTEE AND JUST. TO LOOK
TO THE- PARTICULAR CHALLENGES
THAT WE KNOW CAL FIRE WILL FACE
AS WE MOVE IN TO FIRE SEASON.
AND COMPLICATED NOW BUT THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. JUST A
SHOUT OUT AND THANKS TO THE COW
FIRE FOLKS ON THE FRONT LINES
END THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT
TO MAKING SURE OUR CAL FIRE
RESOURCES ARE AS ROBUST AS
POSSIBLE. IN WITH THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE THANK YOU
CENTER MINING TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SECURELY VERY QUICK-
JUST ON TO COOL IT TO BRIEF
ITEMS NUMBER ONE THAT AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR YOU'VE LED THIS
COMMITTEE AND ON THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE LARGE
SCALE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING ACROSS
THE STATE WITH EVER INCREASING
SEVERITY IN CURRENTLY AFFECT
BETA TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
TRIBES CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS STRUGGLE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE TO GRANT
MAKING PROCESSES WHICH OFTEN
FAIL TO FULLY RESPECT. TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY. DESPITE PROGRESS
IT HAS BEEN MADE BUT THERE ARE
BEEN SOME ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN TRIBAL LEADERS AS WELL
AS CAL FIRE WHEN LOOKING AT A
POTENTIAL CARVE OUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OUT OF THE ALREADY
ALLOCATED. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S GOING TOWARDS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO
BETTER WORK WITH TRIBES TO
ADDRESS WILDFIRE RISKS. AND
RESPECT TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
WOULD HOPE THAT- THIS IS GOING
TO BE SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND THERE HAVE
BEEN A DIRECT CONVERSATIONS
WITH CAL FIRE IT THEMSELVES SO
THE GROUP TRIBE REPRESENTATIVE
BROUGHT THIS UP TODAY ON THE
PHONE. I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
IT COULD ALSO BE EXPANDED AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND FINALLY
SUPPORT THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IN REGARDS. TO
THE BIO DIVERSITY PROGRAM
WITHIN FIVE FISH AND WILDLIFE
TAKING AWAY THAT EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
WILDFIRE CONSERVATION BOARD AT
ITS IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM THIS
IS BEEN INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM- THAT WAS INDICTED
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION
PROPOSITION ONE SEVENTEEN. I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
KEEP THAT STATUS QUO NOT-ADVANCING THE ADDITIONAL MONEY
TOWARDS FISH ALIVE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE. ALL RIGHT-
LET'S FOCUS HERE WILL ENTER
THIS IS IN PART A- WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS THAT WERE ON DISCUSSION
BUT LET'S GO TO THE CONSENT
ITEMS THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADOPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ISSUES ONE.
THREE FOUR SIX EIGHT TEN.
TWELVE THROUGH FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN. EIGHTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FIVE. TWENTY SEVEN TO FORTY
SEVEN. FORTY NINE TO FIFTY TO
FIFTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY
NINE SIXTY ONE SIXTY THREE
SIXTY
MONITORS ARE SENATOR DOLLY
THAT'S MOTION. SO MOVED THIS
MOTION- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BY
CASKEY. HI DOLLY BY THE CHOIR
HI MORNING HI STERN RIGHT. THE
I. SEVENTY FIVE ZERO THE
MOTIONS APPROVED WE HAVE
ANOTHER MOTION- UP TO THE TOP
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ISSUES NUMBER. 251-115-1720
TWO. FIFTY THREE AND FIFTY FOUR
FIFTY SIX AND FIFTY EIGHT SEVEN
NINE EIGHT IS THAT A MOTION YES
THE MOTION BY CENTER MINING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHY CASKEY
HI DARLING NO REQUIRE FIVE
MONEY. HI STERN HI. THE I.
SEVEN FORTY ONE OF THE MOTIONS
ARE PROOF AND FINALLY WE HAVE A
MOTION TO STEP STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ISSUES
SEVEN. TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SIXTY FOUR AND SEVENTY
CENT REQUIRES THAT THE MOTION
THE MOTION BY SAM ACQUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BY CASKEY
HI DOLLY. REQUIRED BY MINING HI
STERN RIGHT. THE I. SEVEN FOUR
ZERO ALL RIGHT LET'S GO THE
ISSUES THAT DISCUSSION WE HAVE
SEVERAL ISSUES THAT WILL BE
HELD OPEN SO WE'RE THERE'S
NOTHING TO DO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE IT'S THE ENERGY.
AND CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION'S BUILDING
INITIATIVE FOR BILL- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET IS THAT EMOTION CENTER
STERN YES SOME OF THE MOTION
BASED CENTERS STERN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL I CASKEY HI DARLING
NO. THE FIRE. MORNING BY. STAN
HI. THE I. SEVEN FORTY ONE THE
MOTIONS APPROVED FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN THE STUDY ON A
LEASE CANYON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE ITS
AS MUCH IS THAT EMOTION CENTERS
ARE CLOSED MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY
CASKEY HI DOLLY HI REQUIRE.
MONEY HI DURING FIVE THE I.
SEVEN FIVE ZERO AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR WORK ON PART. A
DALLAS TURNED THE PART BE THE
CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO TOP STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR. SEVEN
THROUGH THIRTEEN.
1-921-242-6220 EIGHT. THIRTY
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION YOUR ORDER.
THREE TO SIXTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT SIXTY NINE. SEVENTY SEVEN
THROUGH SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY ONE
THROUGH. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
ONE OH THREE ONE THIRTEEN.
1-621-212-3120. FIVE ONE THIRTY
ONE TO ONE THIRTY EIGHT ONE
FORTY ONE. ONE FORTY THREE ONE
FORTY FOUR. ONE FORTY EIGHT ONE
FIFTY ONE ONE FIFTY THREE ONE
FIFTY FOUR POINT FIFTY SIX ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. ONE FIFTY NINE ONE
SIXTY ONE THROUGH ONE SIXTY
SEVEN AND- ONE SEVENTY TO ONE
SEVENTY THREE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT ONE EIGHTY
ONE . ONE EIGHTY FIVE
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN ONE EIGHTY
NINE THROUGH ONE NINETY ONE ONE
NINETY. THREE AND.
1-949-619-7190 NINE THROUGH TWO
OH THREE TWO OH FIVE IN TWO OH
SIX TWO OH NINE THROUGH TWO
SIXTEEN. TO NINETEEN TH AND.
TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY FOUR. THROUGH. TWO
THIRTY TWO TO THIRTY FOUR
THROUGH 240-240-2240 FOUR. TO
FORTY SIXTY TWO FORTY NINE TO
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY FIVE TO
TWO FIFTY EIGHT TO SIX.
SIXTY ONE TO SIXTY FOUR TO
SIXTY SIX THROUGH TWO SIXTY
NINE. TO SEVENTY EIGHT TO.
848-428-6872. 872-892-9290
THREE THROUGH THREE OH TWO.
THREE OH SIX AND THREE OH SEVEN
THREE TEN TO THREE TWELVE.
THREE SIX FIFTEEN THROUGH THREE
SEVENTEEN AND THREE NINETEEN
THREE TWENTY THREE SET IN
MOTION CENTER DOLLY THE MOTION
BY SENATOR DOLLY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MY CASKET BY DIALING
HI REQUIRED BY LEARNING NINE
STERN. CLOSE ROOM TELL YOU BOTH
YOU GUYS HAVE A FIVE ZERO. WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO TOPS
AFRICAN NATIONS ON ITEM SIXTY
FOUR TO SIXTY SEVEN. SEVENTY
FOUR THROUGH. 768-512-6140. ONE
FORTY SIX ONE FIFTY ONE SIXTY
NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE
EIGHTY SIX ONE EIGHTY EI OR. NINETY EIGHT
ZERO FOUR ONE TWO OH SEVEN AND
208-233-2403 TO FORTY FIVE TO
FIFTY TWO. TO SIXTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY TWO TO SEVENTY SEVEN TO
SEVENTY NINE TO EIGHTY ONE TO
TWO E
THREE OH THREE AND THREE OH
FOUR THREE OH EIGHT AND THREE
TWENTY FOUR SAID A MOTION
SENSOR MONSOON MOVES THAT ARE
MINING HAS MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CASKEY HI DARLING
NOPE REQUIRE. MORNING NINE
STERN BY. FIVE THE I. SEVEN
FOUR ONE. AND FINALLY WE HAVE
POWER NOW FINALLY THAT WILL
HAVE A MOTION TO DROP STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ITEM SEVENTY
THE SEVENTY THREE ITEM EIGHTY
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN TO ONE OH TWO
ITEMS ONE OF FOUR TO ONE TWELVE
AND FOURTEEN. ONE TWENTY ONE
AND. ONE TWENTY TWO ONE TWENTY
FOUR ONE TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH.
ONE THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE ONE
FORTY TWO ONE FORTY FIVE ONE
FORTY SEVEN ONE FORTY NI. FIFTY TO ONE FIFTY FIVE
ONE FIFTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT ONCE IN NINE ONE
EIGHTY ONE NINETY FIVE. TO
EIGHTEEN AND TWO SEVENTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN EXCUSE ME.
221-223-2401 TO FIFTY INTO.
FIFTY ONE TO FIFTY FOUR TO
FIFTY NINE. TWO SIXTY TWO A TWO
SIXTY THREE TO EIGHTY EIGHT
REAL FIVE. THREE THIRTEEN AND
THREE FOURTEEN THREE EIGHTEEN
AND THREE TWENTY FIVE TO THREE
TWENTY. 8% OF MOTION CENTER
MINING CENTER YES HE MOTION. UP
PLEASE CALL ROLL MY CASTING BY
DIALING. THE CHOIR HI MORNING I
STAND BY. THE I. SEVEN FOUR
ZERO THERE'S A MOTION TO TOP
STAFFER CONDITION IN ISSUE
NUMBER SIX CENTERS- SO MONEY
DOES EMOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL X. Y. CASKET FIVE OR SIX
DOLLARS BY. REQUIRE MONEY NINE
STERLING NO. CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTES THE EYES HAVE IT
FORTY ONE MOVING ON TO THE
ISSUES FOR DISCUSSION IN PART
BE. IF THIS IS THE FIFTH THE
FIFTY. WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER
THREE TWENTY NINE WHICH IS A
MODIFICATION TO FIRE PROTECTION
ENHANCEMENT IN RELIEF ATOP THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION- CORRECT-
I REJECT THE CONTINUOUS YEARS
SOME OF THE BY. SENATOR MONEY
HI PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
QUAKE OWSKI HI SALLY ARE
REQUIRED THE MORNING. NINE
THIRTY FIVE. THE I. SEVENTY
FIVE ZERO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THIRTY IS THE INNOVATION
PROCUREMENT- SPRINT PROGRAM FOR
CAL FIRE SAID EMOTION CENTER
DOLLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY
CASKEY HI CALLING. THE CHOIR
MORNING NINE STERLING BY. THE
I. SEVEN FIVE. ZERO WE'RE
HOLDING OPEN ISSUES NUMBER
THREE THIRTY ONE TO THREE FORTY
ONE AND. BUT ISSUE NUMBER THREE
FORTY TWO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE THE
GENERAL FUND BACK BUILDING AND
PULL OPEN ALL THE TRIGGER ****
CENTER MINING HAS A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHERE
CASKEY HI DARLING. REQUIRE
MORNING BY STIRRING CLOSE REAL
TELLY VOTER AT SEVEN FOUR ZERO.
NEXT WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER THREE
FORTY THREE SEPARATE CONDITIONS
SPELLED OUT. IS THAT A MOTION
SENATOR STERN SO MOVED MOTION
BUT CENTER STERN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BY CASKEY HI DARLING
NO REQUIRE. AT MORNING HI STERN
BY. CLOSE REAL TELLY BOTH WITH
I. SEVENTY FOUR TO ONE AND LAST
MOTION ON THREE FORTY ONE THE
CAP AND TRADE AUCTION- PLATFORM
CENTER MINING MOVES PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I CASKEY HI DARLING
NOPE THE CHOIR BY MORNING NINE
TURN BY. CLOSE REAL TELLY BOTH
YOU GUYS HAVE IT BUT- FORTY ONE
THIRTEEN RIB RESEARCHER ISSUE
THREE FORTY FOUR CORRECT JUST
RE RECORD THREE FOR THAT OR
OKAY NO THREE FORTY FOUR.
THAT'S THE FINAL ACTION ITEM
THAT WE HAVE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OUR BUSINESS IS DONE
WE'RE NOW AT YOUR.